All right.
In compliance with chapter 551 of the
open meetings act of the Texas
Government Code, I call to order an
information session in a special meeting
of the board of trustees of the Austin
Independent School District for Tuesday,
October 9th, 2025
at 6:02 p.m. A quorum of the board is
physically present at the Austin ISD
office to conduct this meeting. This
meeting is being broadcast on cable
channel 22 through Spectrum, a sound
broadband, and on channel 99 through
AT&T Universe. Closed captioning in
English is available on these platforms
for individuals who are deaf or heart of
hearing. Welcome and thank you for
joining us. Next is an opportunity for
the public to share comments with the
board. This time allows speakers to
comment publicly on any topic of their
choosing directly to the school board.
We have time for up to 60 speakers. As a
reminder, the district continues to
provide time during the regular voting
meeting board to hear from the public
about agenda items for consideration and
vote. This is an opportunity for the
board to take part in listening to our
community. While we wish we could
respond or provide feedback, Texas law
requires us to limit our questions to
requests for clarification or follow up
directly to the administration.
So that means after you are done
talking, it's going to feel very awkward
that the board might just sit here um
because we are not allowed to comment on
things that are not on the agenda or
we'll have to wait until that agenda
item comes up.
All right. Um, members of the public
wishing to participate in the public
comment portion of our meeting, call a
dedicated AISD phone line in advance of
the meeting to sign up to speak in
person or to audio record their remarks.
Today, we have 35 signed up to speak in
person and we have 25 who left a
recorded message. We will now move to
in-person comment. In order to provide
as many opportunities for input as
possible within a limited time period at
this meeting, each speaker will be
allotted one minute. No substitutions or
yielding of time to others is permitted.
Callers who speak signed up to speak in
person are welcome to come to the
microphone when their name is called. As
you come to the microphone, please press
the button to turn it on. And I know we
have a lot of people who are experienced
with public comment. So if you um anyone
wants to help and stand up there, it's
can be tricky with the buttons. Um so
this device lights up as you move
through your one minute aotted time.
When the buzzer buzzer sounds, please
make your final thought in one sentence.
Again, we ask that whether you come to
give a compliment or praise that you
reference the staff member by position
or by abbreviated last name. We ask that
all audience members, whether speaking
or not, please show respect for others
at all time.
Our in-person speakers tonight, um I
will read, do we read about five?
>> I'll read. Yeah, I I'll read I'll read
five at a time so then you can come and
line up so you can um so you have your
one minute. Um, so our first five
speakers tonight are Corey Pomeoy,
Roberto Lago, Megan Vasquez,
Joseph Ariyaga,
Philip Cunningham.
Yes. Uh, there is a podium. Thank you.
Welcome.
Is it on now? Yep. Okay. Superintendent
Sigura, President Boswell, Vice
President Whitley Chu, members of the
board of trustees, my name is Corey
Pomeroy. Uh I live on Westover Road in
Petton Heights neighborhood and I
appreciate the opportunity to visit with
you uh this afternoon on and give you
feedback on your draft plan. I would
urge you to keep Pimton Heights
neighborhood zoned to Cassiss Elementary
um as it currently is, as it
historically has been, and it as it is
and remains under the draft plan.
Maintaining the current boundary uh will
ensure consistency and it will hit on
the the four uh guiding principles that
AISD has put forward in its draft plan.
Namely, it minimizes impact because the
neighborhood is close to the school. It
adheres to a balanced enrollment because
of Cassissa's current student population
makeup. And the current zoning maintains
a clean feeder pattern as well as a
long-term stability of Cassiss and the
neighborhood. I appreciate you'd allow
me to share my thoughts this morning.
Thank you for your service to public
education in the city of Austin.
Good evening. I'm here to express
concern about AISD's proposed boundary
changes that would reszone Circle C
Wildflower Park from Gitzky to Bailey.
Because we're east of Mopac, we've
repeatedly been subject to reszoning
proposals proposals that ignore actual
geography and connectivity. Three years
ago, AISD tried to reszone us from
Kiker, which is a 15inute walk to a
school that required driving several
miles on Mopac. This proposal repeats
that mistake. Gitzky is a five-minute
drive from our neighborhood. Many
students bike there safely. Bailey, by
contract, by contrast, requires a 9mm
toll road drive or a six mile drive that
takes longer because of congested
streets, limited sidewalks. This commute
uh would triple travel travel time for
our families at a minimum. In the entire
history of Geritzky, our neighborhood
has never exceeded 2% of their
enrollment, removing us as negligible
impact on capacity, but major one on
families. This change would also split
our community. We the only current Kiker
Elementary neighborhood that would not
feed to Geritzky, breaking long-standing
peer networks and contradicting AISD's
stated goal of keeping communities
together. Thank you.
[Applause]
How specifically are we prioritizing our
historically underserved students and
communities in these decisions? I know
the district has conducted an equity
audit and made the findings public. But
naming inequities is not the same as
appropriately addressing them. The audit
itself points to deep racial,
linguistic, and economic disparities
that shape not only our district but our
city. Historically, school closures and
consolidations have not impacted
communities equally. They fall hardest
on our low-income communities, black and
brown neighborhoods, and campuses
serving large numbers of EB students.
Looking at the four proposed no
attendance zone campuses, there are
major red flags that show we might be
unintentionally repeating an old
playbook. All four no zones serve a
majority of Hispanic students between 89
to 91% and with 84 to 95% ecois. And
while a no zone is not a closure, we'd
be remiss to not name the harm it
causes. Displacing parts of a school's
community is harm. George Sanchez is a
civil rights icon who fought for
educational equality for
Mexican-Americans. To fracture the
students at the campus named after him
to three separate schools is deeply
contradictory to that legacy. We can
address inequities by deepening them. An
intention of progress doesn't excuse
pain in practice. How will this plan
protect not displace the very
communities most impacted by inequities?
[Applause]
Okay. Uh, I'm a Becker parent and Oh,
I'm a Becker parent and AISD graduate.
Uh, what started as an ask for my son to
not let his school be closed because the
chickens would be homeless has evolved.
I've been reaching out to members of
underperforming schools like Sanchez to
understand how these changes would
impact them and hopefully your
consultants have done the same
consistently. I've heard that the
district from the district um how this
plan is rooted in fairness and helping
the underserved. If that's the goal,
this plan is vastly lacking. It creates
immense transportation challenges and
kicks out the non-dual language students
telling them they can't attend their
newly renovated campus so that kids with
no choice so kids with choices like my
son can. The inequities dressed as hard
change still don't sit right with me.
This is just one e example that echoes
across the district. While I don't claim
to speak for this community, I do speak
speak with them. When I do, I see my
father who's an immigrant who worked
tirelessly to give the opportunity for a
better life.
[Applause]
>> Good evening. My name is Philip
Cunningham and I live in Pton Heights. I
have three young children, one who tends
Cassiss and two who I hope will follow
in her footsteps. Um, tonight we're
talking in the consolidation plan about
lines. But for lines, like many
neighborhoods that are here, they define
our homes. For generations, our children
have walked and biked to the very, very
short distance to Cassiss. This isn't
just a boundary, but a historic and
living connection the draft plan is
rightly chosen to maintain. I urge you
to preserve the current Pimton Heights
zoning to Cassiss. Doing so aligns with
your own objectives and AISD's guiding
principles found on page 14 of your
report. It minimizes disruption for the
neighborhood. One, two, it supports the
balanced enrollment consistent with
today's cassiss community. And three, it
ensures long-term stability and a clean
feeder path that has served families for
decades. Thank you for listening to one
voice in a neighborhood that proudly
chooses Austin ISD because it allows our
children to attend Cassiss. Appreciate
it.
>> Thank you. Next up, we have Tracy
Dunlap, Ellen Price, Brenda Malik, and
Adam Sparks.
My name is Tracy Dunlap. I'm a leader
with Education Austin and a proud
teacher at Maplewood Elementary. I'm
here to talk about the district's
closure and consolidation plan. I cannot
support a plan that closes thriving,
diverse neighborhood schools. Before
Maplewood, I taught at Brook for many
years, closed. I feel angry and sad as I
witnessed the ongoing destruction of our
public schools. This plan moves
Maplewood students to Campbell, but
staff have been told we'll have a job
somewhere. I'm skeptical. Most of the
cost savings comes from the elimination
of staff. So, this seems like a layoff
without actually calling it a layoff.
I'm concerned for our vulnerable
classified staff who are not under
contract. And from a teacher standpoint,
being reassigned to another campus
certainly feels like a loss. The focus
right now must be on supporting schools
with turnaround plans, not rushing to
close schools. Where is the evidence
that community input was used to guide
this plan? I understand our number one
priority is to avoid a TEA takeover, but
closing schools is obeying in advance.
I'm ready to fight for my school and all
public schools. Are you? Please slow
down and listen. We have to get this
right.
[Applause]
Not very tall.
need to do this. Is it working?
>> Is that working?
>> Okay, cool. Hi guys. My name is Ellen
Price. I'm a Becker Elementary
kindergarten mom. Um, I am in the
absence of being able to yield my time.
I'm going to speak on behalf of one of
our heritage families. This is Alexander
Chavez. I'm speaking on behalf of
Alexander Chavez. I'm a dual citizen and
Venezuelan parent raising a first
generation American at Becker
Elementary. At Becker, my son has been
able to learn about our heritage while
also learning to read and write in
Spanish. Many of us transferred in and
commuted from different areas of the
city or outer counties. As an emergent
bilingual parent, I asked at AISD to
guarantee that displaced dual language
students can access any schoolwide dual
language program that works for their
family rather than being assigned to a
specific campus. Our families are rooted
in this community. Many of us from
working-class and historically
marginalized backgrounds, and Becker has
built a thriving, inclusive bilingual
environment. Please protect that success
and ensure our children's bilingual
education continues wherever they go.
Gracias. And I have 10 seconds. So I
would like to say please don't break our
program at Becker. And please don't
displace the Sanchez community again.
They have been through displacement
during COVID displacement while their
new building was built. This building
was built for them. It was not built for
us. Please allow them to stay.
[Applause]
Nope. Okay. All right. Greetings board
members and staff. My name is Brenda
Malik. I'm a longtime resident of the
Washington Holy Cross Historic District.
I went to LL Campbell
when I grew up and had two sons. They
went to LL Campbell.
I have six grandchildren. Two of them
went to LL Campbell. I'm telling you all
this because I know how invested I am in
the ongoing health and vitality of our
neighborhood school.
For generations, we have fought for the
students, faculty, staff, and excellence
of what came out of a school like LL
Campbell. And I'm not the only one. and
I represent hundreds of concerned
parents and neighbors of the only
elementary in the district with a
predominantly black student population.
We have a history of structure, culture,
and excellence that has been cultivated
and strengthened by principal Moore that
needs to be recognized and appreciated.
So before any final decisions are made,
we encourage the board to bring all
stakeholders together in order to
preserve the integrity of what we have
built. Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Hello. AISD is in crisis, but is an
academic crisis, not a financial one. We
have 23 failing schools in this
district, and instead of putting all of
our attention into those schools, and
figuring out what they need, we know it
is $13 million. Uh, instead, the
district is giving us a plan that closes
13 campuses whose land value alone is
$300 million, fires 700 teachers and
staff, displaces over 5,000 students,
and for what? This process isn't even
finished. My school's consolidation has
a paragraph. It doesn't address
programming. It doesn't address all of
the many cultural issues that have to be
addressed. We need more time for this.
We need a year instead of a month to
make these generational decisions. And
how are we going to get the money for
that? Maybe we can look to 2019 and the
schools that we closed then. The
campuses of Mets and Brook are still
empty. You can make $15 million by
selling those two immediately. Those
people did hard things. Those people had
shared suffering for the Austin
community. And did AISD get better? Are
we going to be here seven years from
now? Everybody in this room knows the
answer is yes to that. We need the
trustees to say to the district, please
present us with multiple plans on
November 6th. And we're trying to
organize the entire community together.
Let's get it right. Aisd.com. Join us.
Thank you.
>> Thank you. Next up is Matt Heriger,
Stafy Stacy Figura Figareroa, Reinie
Camaretti, and Mary Alice Rusie.
I'm Matt Harer and the proud parent of
two kids in the district and on most
days I like the district.
My concern is that fostering a sense of
financial emergency is being used as a
tactic to sell a closure plan which was
the only option presented. Okay. How can
the district for the last 20 years
running, including the years that we had
to change our policy to reduce our
reserves from 20 to 15%. Earn the
highest financial rating from TEA under
its financial uh accountability system,
the superior achievement. How much did
we save six years ago when we closed
four schools? More importantly, what was
the impact on enrollment? I hope it
wasn't like San Antonio's experience
where it made their budget deficit
worse. But I want to be clear about one
thing. I really appreciate the
district's effort to pursue a process
based on data equity and fiscal
responsibility. But when that process
suggests shuttering a school, an A-rated
diverse school fully enrolled with
students within the attendance zone, it
signals something is the underlying
process is flawed. Let's get it right.
AISD
[Applause]
Hello, dear AISD board and district
trustees. Thank you for hearing from the
Zilker community. The current resoning
plan introduces inequities, safety
risks, and logistical challenges for 117
current Zilker students and hundreds of
future East of Lamar families who would
be reassigned from Zilker to Galindo
Elementary. We share AISD's goals of
equitable, stable, and thriving
neighborhood schools, but believe they
can be achieved without fracturing,
established communities, or creating new
barriers to access. The district's
current proposal is increasing travel
distances and ignoring the district's
long-standing practice of treating the
railway as a natural boundary, causing
safety risks and logistical challenges
for timely arrival. It disrupts feeder
patterns, negatively impacting the
quality of students educations. Our
community developed a thoughtful
database proposal with three realistic
options all aligned with AISD's stated
framework. We shared some of the
proposals also with Miss Boswell and
they are in your hands tonight. We ask
that you pause, review it, and meet with
us to better understand our neighborhood
and work together towards a safer, more
consistent solution for South Austin.
Thank you.
[Applause]
There we go. I'm asking you reconsider
the zoning proposal for the Wildflower
Park section of Circle C and do not
disrupt the feeder pattern. The proposal
would make the Wildflower Park the only
section of Circle C whose children would
attend Kiker Elementary, but not Gitzky
Middle School. This change would
fracture a deeply connected community
and disrupt the social and academic
continuity that our children need. My
family lives in the wildflower park and
my daughter goes to daycare with other
circle C and ker kids. By the time she
reaches middle school, she will have
friendships built over 10 years of
shared experiences in daycare, school,
swim team, and other community
activities. These relationshipships are
not just casual, they are foundational.
Middle schools are ready already a
challenging transition. Facing that
transition with a familiar group of
peers helps kids feel safe, supported,
and confident. The impact on the
Wildflower Park on the GMS headcount is
minimal. only 24 to 28 students over the
next several years by the impact on our
children and community is substantial.
My three nieces are zoned to Gitzky and
their grandmother who joined me today
just lives 5 minutes away. These
connections matter. They create a
network of care and consistency that
supports our children's growth. Thank
you.
[Applause]
Good evening, Superintendent Matias and
esteemed board members. My name is Mary
Alice and I've had the privilege of
serving students and providing services
at Title One schools for over 40 years
and currently I provide dyslexic
services along with my partner uh Miss
Y, the special ed chair. I'm here
tonight to respectfully voice our
opposition to Austin's preliminary plan
on behalf of Sancha's Mets community.
We've already lived through the painful
impact of past closures, consolidations,
and modernizations. Disruptions that
left deep scars on our families,
students, and staff. The two-year
transition made it even harder during
COVID. Please do not reassign our
students again. do not implement these
boundary changes. As part of the
consolidation process, AISD approved our
proposed dual language and English uh
programming. In good faith, we
implemented these programs to ensure
equal access for all our students. We
urge you do not dismantle the
programming that we currently have that
we work so hard and support it. Um we're
concerned with the long-term effects on
our students uh to our emergent
bilingual and students with
disabilities. We ask you to reconsider
and seriously evaluate the counter
proposals being offered. Lastly, happy
principal appreciation week to all AISD
principles and especially to our
wonderful Sanchez principal. Thank you
and good night.
[Applause]
>> Thank you. Next up is Lesie Mason,
Lauren Baker, Delicia Mlean, and Tanner
Venison.
now. Okay. All right. Hello. My name is
Lesie Mason. I'm here regarding the
draft consolidation plan specifically to
get your attention on a very small
request to keep my small subdivision,
Brody Springs, zoned to Baronoff
Elementary. Brody Springs is the only
neighborhood taken out of Baronoff. We
surveyed our neighbors and found there
are only 10 children who are pre-K and
younger who this will impact. Their ages
range from infants to 5-year-olds. So
that's maybe one or two students per
year over the next 5 years who will
enter elementary school. That small
number of kids does not justify removing
our neighborhood from Baronoff to
balance enrollment, especially given how
connected we are to the Shady Hollow and
Baronoff community. It's simply not fair
to single out one small neighborhood and
sever us from our community school. I
understand that you cannot make everyone
happy, but this is a very small change
that you can make that won't upset your
goals or cause a ripple effect. And
after hearing everybody's concerns,
there are some serious problems with
this consolidation plan. So, please keep
Brody Springs with Baronoff Elementary.
Thank you.
>> Hello.
Hi. My name is Lauren Baker. Is it Is it
on? Yes. Thank you. Um, I'm here on
behalf of the Breerwoods Neighborhood
Association, of which I'm a board member
and a parent of a Breerwoods student in
fifth grade, Wilder, and in first grade,
Leo. I'm here because AISD
administration is running scared. The
TEA has put us at risk and under
scrutiny for several years, leading you
to be asked to consider a plan that is
built on unverified data that is flawed.
It's built on arbitrary and illogical
variables, and approving a plan like
this would likely hasten TEA takeover,
not stop it. You were elected to
represent your districts and to hold the
administration accountable to bring
forth a um plan that is sustainable.
That is not this. This puts people in
harm's way. And it's just bad math. And
if you support any plan rep representing
the one that was put forth last Friday,
you're failing our kids and your
constituents are watching. Thank you.
[Applause]
Hello. Yes. Hi, I'm Delicia Mlan, Becker
parent.
Is this better?
>> Okay.
Bottom line up front, the draft plan
isn't about students and it's not a
tactical plan to help the district
succeed. It's meant to cause widespread
panic and chaos to protect central
office jobs and inflated salaries. It's
manipulation, a psychological tactic,
ask for something outrageous, and then
settle for the real target, which we
believe is closing four dual language
programs and calling it equity. But they
didn't even choose to move these
programs to the schools with the highest
numbers of EBS because the EBS for the
north they're in 78758 and 78753 and in
the south they're in 78741 and 78744.
Six of seven districts are affected with
closures and conversions. Parents are
outraged. The district is overwhelmed
and you are being overwhelmed.
The district is also giving you an
opportunity for an out. Oh, I saved as
many as I could, but we see through it
and we're not panicked. So, I ask you,
trustees, what are your values? What do
you see? Are you strong enough to demand
effective reform rather than trade our
children's future for somebody's
paycheck?
[Applause]
Hello.
I'm a parent. a parent who Austin ISD
sta staff told that my voice doesn't
matter. I'm here to prove to my kids
that it does matter. The draft
consolidation plan looks like a Hail
Mary to avoid TEA oversight. It pours
gasoline on this fire. Closures
routinely cause firstear drop in
performance. That's well documented. The
report is thin on numbers, heat maps,
too many TBDs, and it doesn't include
your attrition rate or the vouchers. So
whatever savings you think you're going
to get is probably wrong. You're
disrupting 19 communities to save 7% of
your budget. Closers should be a last
resort after scaling back HQ. You've
added directors as enrollment has
declined and AI makes central office
work faster and easier. Where most
companies are trimming, you're adding
employees. Leadership matters most in
the hard moments. The superintendent's
absence has been felt by the affected
communities and absent leadership is the
worst form. Kids aren't a line item. Cut
bureaucracy before you cut schools.
>> Thank you speakers. Next up is Jennifer
Ashambo, Laura Garcia, Selena Martinez,
and Scott Brut Scott Brutico.
>> I'm Jennifer Ashambo. After reviewing
the ASSE's proposal, the numbers in both
the student impact reassignment matrix
and the enrollment forecast by
attendance do not add up. Here's one
example. Kiker Elementary's current
enrollment is 715, not 795. The proposal
of the proposal claims 185 students
would move to Mills and 123 students
would move to Clayton. Campus verified
enrollment data for the affected areas
show only 89 students in the first group
and 57 in the second. With numbers this
inflated, this plan creates the very
imbalance it's meant to solve,
overcrowding one school, under rolling
another, promptly prompting boundary
changes that ma that may be unnecessary.
I have shared the inconsistencies with
trusty Kaufman and trustee Whitley Chu,
further underscoring how rushed and
errorprone this process has been.
Pausing now to ensure accurate data
isn't a setback. It's a responsible step
that protects students, teachers, and
the long-term stability of our local
schools. Ensuring boundary decisions
strengthens our campuses rather than
create lasting problems. Thank you.
Is it on? Okay.
Baker.
Gracias.
[Applause]
My name is Victor Rodriguez, interpreter
for AISD.
Good. Good afternoon. I'm a parent, a
voluntary parent, and a substitute for
the Becker Elementary. I believe the the
motives behind this decision to move
programs, dual language programs. Uh
although I believe that the option to
move it Becker to Sanchez is not a
viable one. uh without a comprehensive
plan of retention, it would be difficult
to reach the qu the amount of students
bilingual students the emerging
bilingual students I'm sorry and to
justify the the transfer uh the policies
of the actual current uh
transportation implies that many of our
students and science elementary would
would would lose their transportation
and without a plan a communication plan
adequate communication plan with the
community Um the um the I'm sorry I
think I can't read it right in here.
>> Well, just just tell me what it says
here.
>> Okay. Without uh without the right
communication
>> the right communication I'm sorry the
adequate communication with the
community um the it could be a break a
bad great problem. Uh uh furthermore,
the u the widening of I35 would cause a
lot of contamination and could be a a
grave problem for the health of our
children in the daily activities. Uh our
um our back community is formed by
immigrant families uh that from Hispanic
heritage that are learning Spanish and
the English speakers are are learning as
well. Um maybe these uh the facilities
are not as new as uh we would have in
other uh places of resources uh like the
uh green garden where students are
learning uh nutrition and sciences. Um
so and and getting a an adequate
education
in their surroundings.
Thank you.
[Applause]
My name is Selena Martinez. Is that
good? Okay. Um, my name is Selena
Martinez and I'm a parent of a third
grader at Becker Elementary. Like many
families, we love our school, but we'd
be willing to make sacrifices if there
were clear evidence that closing schools
would produce equitable outcomes for
students and prevent a TEA takeover.
That that evidence isn't there. The
savings projected from closures are
small compared to the potential losses
both financial and people that come when
families and staff lose trust and walk
away from the district. Speaking
specifically of the dual language
program that have served me and my
heritage family who are ignored in this
plan.
The real challenge ASD faces for this
program, sorry,
is is recruitment and retention. Closing
schools won't fix that. Trustees, I ask
you, please challenge the assumption
that closures will solve our financial
or academic gaps. Let's find solutions
that keep our communities intact,
protect our strongest programs, and
rebuild trust between families and the
district.
[Applause]
Good afternoon. Is it working?
>> My name is Scott Brutico and I'm the
president of the Brierwoods Neighborhood
Association.
When you prune a tree for the health of
the tree, you pick the branches that are
interfering with the health of that
tree. You don't prune healthy branches.
And if you improvidently prune those
branches, you can end up killing the
tree. Bryerwoods Neighborhood
Association, I'm sorry, Brierwoods
Elementary School is an 86year-old
historic school which is the heartbeat
of our neighborhood. It is the only IB
elementary school in in the city and it
cannot be replaced by AISD. Only the IB
group decides that. By all accounts,
it's an exemplary school. It's full and
it's turning people away who want to go
there. A prized asset of the
neighborhood, AISD, and the city of
Austin. I don't have enough time to go
into the rubric and to go into the cost
savings, but we will submit why those
are flawed. Please, we urge you to keep
your eye on the ball and focus on
avoiding the state takeover by
concentrating on failing schools, not on
prized assets of the community, not on
healthy branches. Thank you.
Next up, we have Eric Ramos, Hannah
Ston, Annie Kllum, and Taylor Kevin.
>> Good evening. I want to highlight a
couple of things tonight. First, I want
to acknowledge that we are here to many
missteps over time. We have schools that
get told what is best for them, and even
when they push back, they are still
still told what is best for them. When
these schools do what is imposed on them
and still don't get the desired grades,
we are hit with the blame. We have not
had people who truly come to campuses
and ask the staff that are directly
impacted on this and not just
administration what we need to be
successful. Instead, they we are told
what is best for us. Partially because
of this, we are in this situation and
now some schools will pay the ultimate
price, closure. What makes this worse is
that how I have seen this presented at
least at my community is the same way it
has always been where we are asked for
feedback and ultimately we don't get
listened to. We expect better. We must
do better starting now. What doing
better looks like is genuinely listening
to the communities and not just hold
listening sessions and passing the draft
version exactly as is without any
changes. And in fact, some communities
have already been told that little to
nothing can change in their plan. This
is a huge decision and we must ensure
all communities are listened to equally.
Also, is there someone I can give to
with some papers with more feedback for
y'all?
[Applause]
>> Hi. Uh my family and I um and so many
others chose Campbell very intent. Is
this on? Sorry, I don't Okay. Uh chose
Campbell Elementary um very
intentionally. Campbell is one of the
last predominantly black schools
standing in Austin. My children are
mixed race and we want them to go to a
school that reflects the real diversity
of Austin and honors the black history
of this neighborhood. CA Campbell does
that. It's home to so many when they
need it the most. While we are not at
risk of closure, we will be welcoming a
huge influx of students from a white
school if this is to take place.
Recently, I spoke with a parent who had
children at Maplewood itself years ago
that was highly diverse. When they
returned years later with a with a child
they had many years later, they said
that it felt very different. She felt
like she no longer belonged there. That
shift shows how easily a school's
identity can change. And if we if we
aren't careful, AISD still wears the
scars of what happened at Anderson High
not so long ago. We all uh we all see
that black history in Austin is
continuing to be an afterthought of
leadership. Under Principal Moore's
leadership, Campbell has been a model of
what equity and community can look like
in action. We need to protect our
critical supports in title one and our
title one status interventionists that
work with our struggling students. Let's
remember that those that have the most
to lose will lose the most if we do not
take this decision carefully.
[Applause]
Good evening.
My name is Taylor Carrick Caven. Um I'm
currently at Doby Middle School and I'm
a proud member of Education Austin. I'm
speaking not just for myself, but for
the workers and families who couldn't be
here tonight, those who will bear the
weight of a rush timeline. No matter no
matter where we live, work, or learn, we
are all affected by a potential
takeover. What I keep hearing from
custodians, cafeteria staff, and TAs at
affected campuses is fear. Fear about
losing jobs and not being heard. Many
workers rely on Austin's public broken
public transportation system just to get
to work or to for the parents to get to
their children's schools. With
reassignments across town, it's not just
an inconvenience or quality of life
issue. It's people's livelihoods on the
line. If there are savings on staffing,
that sure feels like a reduction in
force. The district is barreling forward
as if our feedback is a box to check in
the name of avoiding a takeover. None of
us want a takeover, but we can't let TEA
bully our district into decisions that
harm our communities when you have a
responsibility to hold the state
accountable for underfunding public
schools. Slow down. Listen, do what's
right.
>> Thank you. Next up we have Sharon Bain,
Steve Swanson, Brian Mixel, and Travis
Alrech.
As a homeschooling parent of three who
came to the district only because of Win
Montasaur's program, staff, and
leadership, I am very grateful the
district has plans to keep Montasauri
and our staff. However, the current
consolidation proposal is not in the
best interests of our community and
students in affected schools. Not only
does it displace current families and a
program success, it also creates
barriers for access and throws multiple
disadvantaged communities into chaos.
For when alone, 82% of our student
population is in close proximity to the
campus. One roundtrip commute to Goval
is 40 minutes during peak school times
and unrealistic for many. Is it feasible
to bus over 350 students across town? It
also doesn't propose student success now
and long term if multiple staff
positions are made redundant and those
who remain must essentially double their
workload. There are better alternatives
we can propose that would minimize
student disruptions and better serve all
students as we navigate transition
challenges. We need financial
transparency and true collaboration so
we can have a better academic plan for
all. Thank you.
[Applause]
I thought I had it right this time.
Uh I think I think you heard the 30-year
part. Um, being honest,
Austin ISD isn't being taken over.
We are giving schools away.
Since 1995, the start of chapter 11 of
the Texas Education Code, our school
boards and superintendents have not done
their lawful job to hold TEA
accountable,
accountable for providing our school
district training in and surveys to
improve authentic community-based
planning of schools. Johnston High
School in East Austin should never have
been closed by TEA in 2000.
TEA uh turnaround plan should not exist
in Austin today. Seize your lawful
rights and obligations. Hold TEA
accountable. Stop school turnaround
planning and get training in planning.
Get the process right. If you're not
going to hold TEA accountable, be honest
and tell our students and the Austin
community. The hope is history will
reveal you stood up for our rights by
helping TEA start doing its lawful job
in chapter 11 to serve not harm Texas
schools.
[Applause]
I'm Sharon Bain, parent of two AISD
graduates. We need more on academics in
the consolidation draft. A timeline by
November is not enough before a vote.
Aside from the list of non-negotiables
and areas of flexibility for campuses,
there is little new here about an
academic baseline in terms.
What do kids learn in elementary? What
math should they know by 8th grade? When
do they read full novels? Are they
reading full novels? The document shares
too little about special education.
Baseline academics is also what happens
if a child needs support. Special
education can't be in a silo. The
ingredients exist in the long range
plan, in the equity audit, even in the
course catalog, which really should
detail what's available everywhere and
what's only available on certain
campuses. Please make this happen. We
need to know that these cuts will lead
to something better, not just cheaper.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Good evening.
My name is Brian Mel and I'm the parent
of a kindergartenner at Maplewood. I'm
here tonight on behalf of let's
getitright aisd.com
but more importantly as a voice for the
thousands of young children like my own
who don't know their small worlds are in
jeopardy. I want to acknowledge that you
are in an incredibly difficult position
and we appreciate that these are not
easy choices.
However, as trustees your fiduciary duty
This plan is presented as a financial
necessity. Yet, we have not been shown a
detailed analysis that proves it will
solve the shortfall. Without clear
accounting for additional costs,
including the long-term costs of
families leaving our district, a vote
for this plan is a vote of blind faith,
not fiscal responsibility. Therefore, I
urge you to vote no in the rushed
proposal. Instead, direct the
administration to come back with a range
of options that address the budget
without sacrificing our neighborhoods
and children's stability. Let's get it
right. Thank you.
There you go.
All right. I'm a longtime resident of
Circle C. I happen to live in a small
pocket called Wildflower Park. I'm here
tonight to express concern about the
proposal to reszone us away from Gitzky
Middle School. I understand the
district's goal of balancing enrollment,
but the proposed adjustment for
Wildflower Park seems to be based more
on lines on a map, only recognizing that
we're located east of Mopac rather than
on meaningful outcomes. The first point
in your plan is to create clean feeder
patterns so communities can stay
together. Our small pocket of homes is
connected physically and socially only
to Circle C and would be the only part
of Kiker, not continuing to Gritzky.
Separating our kids from the rest of
their peers only for their middle school
years does not make uh meet your plan's
intent. Wildflower Park is a small
landlocked and fully built out pocket
within Circle C. Reassigning only six of
125 kids per grade per year won't
relieve overcrowding. It will disrupt
relationships that have been built over
years. As an architect and urban
planner, I know how easy it is uh to
just draw lines on a map. But behind
every line, there's a human story. A
story of families, friendships, and
communities that have grown together.
Thank you.
Thank you. Next up, we have Shannon Kho,
Carla Landry, Drew Martinez,
and Jordan Hartman.
Hello. Okay. Do I hit the
>> Oh, I see. Thank you.
>> I don't have to touch anything to make
the timer. You're good. Okay.
>> Good evening. I'm Shannon Kho, the
librarian at Sanchez Elementary, a
Sanchez parent, and a 17-year resident
of its neighborhood. I've served ASD
since 2008 as a bilingual classroom
teacher, then as a UT teacher, educator,
grad student, working in Sanchez and
many other AISD schools, um, and a
librarian. I chose to work at Sanchez
and then to send my daughter there
because of the teachers, the families,
its history and um relationship with UT,
the students, and because of all of that
reflects the best of public education
and the best of AISD. My daughter is a
Spanish dominant Colombian-American
child with family in Colombia uh
experiences and identities that
intersect with many of excuse me of her
peers.
All of whom would be scattered to three
different schools according to the
proposal. I too would no longer um teach
them. The current plan would erase the
Sanchez history and legacy, our staff
identity, and turn it into a transfer
only campus without buses, cutting off
the very families, the very bilingual
families that it claims to serve. Our
students have shown growth, and the TEA
allows for us to continue to implement
our plan and do better. The TA, not what
ASD has proposed. Displacing our
students is inequitable. We should be
given the chance that the law allows and
we should be given the chance we should
be allowed to align with the core values
that AISD claims. Equity, student
well-being and achievement, diversity,
inclusion. The current proposal doesn't
do any of that. Please honor Sanchez.
Honor your values, our district's
values, and the legacy of our school by
keeping it open and our community
intact. Thank you.
Hello. Hi. Hi. I am Carla Landry, a
proud parent of a second grader and a
kindergartener at Maplewood Elementary.
I am also the PTA secretary. I'm here
today to ask you to please do not close
Maplewood when our oldest was ready for
kindergarten.
We toured seven schools, private,
charter, and public. The moment we
stepped into Maplewood, we knew this was
the only school that truly fit our
family's need. Very strong academics and
social emotional learning. Our son
needed a school that could build
confidence and help him manage his
feelings. Walking Maplewoods Halls, you
see and you feel the impact of a strong
SEAL program. Calmer children, stronger
relationships, and better academics.
SEAL reduces bullying and shapes
resilient, kind humans. Thanks to our
stellar staff like Miss Kirk, our
counselor, my children are thriving. We
are transfer students. If Maplewood
closes, we lose our home. AISD gave
Maplewood a job. Improve academics,
raise enrollment, keep the cost per
student down. Maplewood did its job.
AISD has not. We are a successful
A-rated school with dedicated staff like
Miss Dunlap and an engaged community
that embodies what schools should be.
Closing us doesn't solve district
problems. It deepens them. AISD. Listen
to your community. Protect what's
working. Keep Maplewood open. Thank you.
Hello. Uh, my name is Drew Martinez. Um,
I'm a parent of a third grader at Becker
Elementary.
The community and culture of Becker
makes us greater than the sum of our
parts. So this is data from the 2023
2024 school year that was presented in
the rubric published by AISD. One that
they did not use in their
decision-making. So Becker's operational
cost per student was 84% lower than the
district average. The uh staffing and
academic support 19% lower. Um their
average teacher tener half of what the
the district average is. All the while,
they're a B-rated school with a vibrant
culture that celebrates diversity and
heritage. It's a culture that's taken
decades to develop and is proposed to be
closed. Becker is just one of many
thriving campuses that is proposed to be
closed. So, I ask, what message does
that send to other campuses and
communities when you do everything right
and you still are proposed to get
shuttered? What trust does this allow us
to place in the district?
There is an alternative. I ask the board
to reject this plan as it stands. The
stakes are high. Let's get this right
together.
[Applause]
Thank you. Is Jordan Hartman here?
Jordan Herman's next. Thank you. And
then after Jordan, two more inerson
speakers. Kelly Ferrerero at Ashley Pam.
Hello, my name is Dr. Jordan Hartman.
I'm here with the Circle Wildflower Park
uh contingency. Uh here to uh argue
against the zoning uh reszoning from
Grazinski to Bailey. Um just want to say
this is a clear uh hardline on a map
decision, not with the organic feel of
um the neighborhood. Uh we are not by uh
geographical or road. We're not going to
be able to get over there very easily at
all. Getting to uh Bailey, it's a great
area. I my mom lived here. It's it's not
the school for our neighborhood,
unfortunately. Um and so I think this is
just a case where you got to look at the
guidelines and make a decision um just
like you would with a patient. You know,
all guidelines aren't right for all
people. And um I think Travis was kind
of building on that with his um
architecture um his background. Um this
is just going to put a lot of stress on
our community. Um and I think that's a
sentiment everyone here can agree with.
Um that that a lot of these um changes
are are made not for the people but but
but kind of um blind. Thank you.
So, our last two inerson speakers are
Kelly Ferrero and Ashley Fan.
Kelly and Ashley here. Thank you.
>> That'll make it easy.
>> Nothing.
green. Superintendent Sigoro, board of
trustees, thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak and to remind us
that we still have a democratic process.
I was beginning to wonder if we have
that anymore here. So, thank you. My
name is Kelly Ferraro. I'm a mom at
Maplewood Elementary, third grader Liam,
who's right here, and a first grader
Eie. We just got here and we love our
school. You probably know Principal
Paulino because she is a legend and she
raised our school up from a C to an A in
five years. On Zillow, if you check now,
the great schools ranking went from a
six to an eight. That is unheard of.
Nothing moves that fast. Not in public
education. She's my hero. She's why
we're here. And we're also here, we're
here for the kids. And we need to teach
them what leadership is about and what
accountability is about. Our school got
an A. The kids took their STAR tests.
They got the grades. The teachers taught
them. They got the grades. I fundraised
for the PTA. We're raising money for
math content interventionists and tutors
so the kids can do the grades. Y'all
didn't do your job. You didn't do your
half the bargain. For three years, you
broke your budget. You're outspending by
$47 million. If I did that, I'd be
fired. What are we teaching the kids?
Right. We need more time to get this
right. Give us a year, not a month, and
include the voices of the community
because we're in Austin, Texas. And if
anyone can get this right, it's Austin,
Texas. We have some of the smartest,
greatest thinkers here. I'm not afraid
to consolidate with Campbell. You know
why? This community is awesome. We will
get it right. But you got to include us.
Please slow down. Include us. Get it
right. Do your job. Thank you.
[Applause]
I'm Ashley Fawn and I've proudly served
Wedane Elementary for 10 years. Closing
Wedane is not accountability. It's
intensifying inequity in our community.
We've been labeled the exception in
AISD's proposal. Turnaround rules
require students to be reassigned to
campuses rated C or higher, but our
students will be sent to D and F-rated
campuses. Calling this an exception
sends a message that our students matter
less than others in the district. How
can anyone believe that ripping students
away from the teachers who know and love
them will lead to better outcomes. This
proposal was rushed, inequitable, and
incomplete. Our community never had a
real voice in this process. Closing
Wedane isn't reform, it's punishment.
Our children will pay the price unless
you choose differently. Fix the
inequities that exist across our
schools. Don't escalate them.
Marginalized communities like ours
should be centered in all decisions.
Fear of a TEA takeover should never
force us to betray our values as a
district. Slow down. Listen, do what's
right. Protect Wedane. Protect our kids.
[Applause]
Thank you to all of our in-person
speakers and everyone else who's here
with us. And now it's time to play our
recorded message for public comment. So,
please listen carefully.
>> Hello, my name is Paulie Lam. H O L L Y
L A N H A. And I live on Wales Drive in
the Pimton Heights neighborhood. I have
a sixth grader at O'Henry and a a ninth
grader at Austin High. and both of them
went to Cassiss Elementary. Thank you
for the opportunity to provide feedback
on this plan. I urge you to keep Pimton
Heights zoned to Cassiss Elementary. The
neighborhood has historically been zoned
to Cass. It currently is zoned to
Cassiss and it remains that way under
their draft plan.
>> Hi, are we are messages ready? We're
ready when you are. Thank you.
>> Hello, my name is Pauline Lam. H O L L Y
L A N H. and I live on Wales Drive in
the Pimton Heights neighborhood. I have
a sixth grader at O'Henry and a a ninth
grader at Austin High and both of them
went to Cassis Elementary. Thank you for
the opportunity to provide feedback on
this plan. I urge you to keep Pimton
Heights zoned to Cassiss Elementary. The
neighborhood has historically been zoned
to Cass. It currently is zoned to
Cassiss and it remains that way under
their draft plan. Maintaining the
current boundary provides consistency
and follows AISD guide guiding principle
C page 14 of your report. It minimizes
impact as the neighborhood is close to
the school. It adheres to a balanced
enrollment based on Cassis's student
population makeup and the current zoning
maintains a clear feeder pattern as well
as a long-term stability of Cassiss and
the neighborhood. I appreciate you
allowing me to share my thoughts this
evening. Thank you.
>> Good evening. My name is Bri Ralph and I
work in the special education department
for Austin ISD. I'm also a proud member
of education often. In my 10 years with
the district, I've worn many hats. From
teaching in a Southwest Austin school to
supporting students and families
experiencing homelessness. Now I work
with the families of students receiving
special education services. PA has left
our district with impossible choices.
Through their actions, our state leaders
have made it clear they want public
schools to fail. But I'm asking tonight
that AISD not go down without a fight.
Yesterday, I visited east side campuses,
some now facing closure. Staff told me
they're afraid families will lose access
to campuses not located near public
transportation, as well as vital
support. Our most vulnerable students,
including those in special education,
must be prioritized in every decision.
As we move forward, please listen to all
communities, not just the loudest ones.
Every neighborhood deserves to be heard.
Every student deserves to be valued.
>> Good afternoon and thank you for
considering the input of the community
today. My name is Lisa Bennett and I'm a
Maplewood parent. I want to speak today
on why keeping Maplewood open makes
sense. Fundamentally, we should preserve
neighborhood schools if the community's
population is big enough to support
them. Maplewood is right size for our
neighborhood. Using the district's own
rubric, Maplewood is 94% full based on
our current zoned neighborhood
population.
And unlike many schools, we are easily
walkable for most of our community,
including the 30% of economically
disadvantaged kids in our over 400 kids
strong community. Our neighborhood is
full of young families and new apartment
housing is being planned near Maplewood
in connection with I35 development,
right when the district is thinking of
taking the school away. So, Maplewood
makes sense now and is going to make
sense in the future. These values and
data should prevail, especially when we
are talking about a neighborhood school
that has just achieved its first A
rating and is serving those neighborhood
kids well. Thanks for your
consideration.
>> Hi, this is Stacy and I'm a Becker
parent. The ASB plan falsely offers to
keep Becker families together by moving
them to Sanchez, but your own numbers
show that if we actually did what you're
suggesting that Sanchez capacity would
be at 137%.
This disingenuous offer was made so that
consolidators can hide behind the
pretense of preserving a community when
in fact you have the data on where
Becker families live and know that eight
out of 10 of us would not be able to go.
If we default to our newly zoned
neighborhood schools, we sacrificed the
dual language learning the children have
worked so hard for. The Sancho's
families who endured moving to Mets and
back, waiting for their beautiful school
to be finished and the sixth grade
population to be reassigned will now be
kicked out of their school just as
teachers were finally set up to help
their children succeed. Not only are you
pitting communities against each other
who must fight for space and access to
educational programming, you are also
pitting public school supporters against
their own children's bilingual
education. Committed families will be
forced to opt out of AISD if you do not
come up with something better.
>> Hi, my name is Cecilia Zang. I'm a
parent opposing the proposed boundary
change moving East Zilker students from
Zilker Elementary to Galindo. Many
families, including mine, moved to the
South Omar area specifically to be part
of the Zilker Elementary community. This
school really is more than a building to
us. It's the heart of our neighborhood
where our kids walk or bike safely, grow
up together, and build lasting bonds.
The proposed change would force our
children to travel nearly two miles
across active train tracks with long
wait times and roads not safe for
walking or biking to attend Gindo,
contradicting AISD's own safety and
boundary guidelines. Many of us have
young children and the current plan
doesn't guarantee that siblings will
attend the same school, creating serious
logistical and emotional stress for
working families. We may not be able to
drop kids at opposing schools in the
7:15 to 740 window due to logistical
issues. Faced with this uncertainty,
many families in our neighborhood deeply
committed to public education may feel
forced to leave a AISD for more
predictable private or charter options.
That is a huge loss no one wants and
would be a step.
>> My name is Tony Toiver. I am an AISD
parent. I live in the vibrant Mueller
neighborhood. A successful public
private partnership that included AISD.
Important aspect of that success was
school zoning, promise of an AISD
school, and school choice. While Mueller
finally got a school in our
neighborhood, the Mueller residents
weren't zoned to that school. This
proposal will now allow at least a half
of the neighborhood to go to that
school. But an even bigger concern is
the reszoning in Mueller for elementary
and high schools to go from successful
AISD schools to failing and near failing
schools. The elementary school will now
be zoned to a D-rated school and this
other one a C-rated school of Northeast
High School. And there's a limit to
school choice. We will not send our kids
to failing schools. AISD will lose
successful students that it needs at
this critical time when AISD should be
focusing on the looming state takeover.
This will be a massive undertaking and
it will be chaotic. AISD should use its
limited manpower to narrow its focus to
avoid the state.
>> This is Barbara Spears Corbett, resident
of District 1 and a member of the LL
Campbell Alumni Association. Campbell
Elementary School has a rich history and
identity going back to 1939. The
Campbell community expectation is that
the proposed merger of Campbell and
Maplewood be a respectful one that shows
appreciation for the legacies of both
campuses and embraces the shared values
of a strong educational experience for
all students, not an eraser. The
Campbell Alumni Association and the
Historic Rogers Washington Holy Cross
Neighborhood Association are willing to
engage in a discussion regarding the
school's collective identity, academic
programming, campus leadership,
attendance boundaries, and campus
culture. The boundary for East Side
Early College High School should be
extended to Mayor Road to support a more
robust enrollment. The legacy enrollment
category adopted under former
superintendent Dr.
should maintain be maintained and
actively promoted. Thank you.
>> Hello, my name is Amber German and I am
a parent of the Austin ISD school
district. I have three students and this
is regarding 5.1
the school consolidation plan. I'm
calling to express that I don't like it.
I am not comfortable with it and I feel
it'll be very detrimental to our
beautiful community. If wind monaster
would consolidate with magnolia monaster
which they are neighboring schools that
it seems much more beneficial to the
monastery community but as for the
public schools are principal Diane Vejo
our parent teacher support specialist
Miss Espinosa and all the teachers and
staff at go valley we have such a
tight-knit a beautiful community and we
are educating our children and showing
them our world and how it extends much
more and our small community. We need to
not go through with this plan. We love
our school and I've been there 10 plus
years and I'd hate to see it turn into a
monastery school.
>> My name is George Reyes. I am a
caregiver of a future student at Cassiss
Elementary. I live on Mole Drive in the
Pimton Heights neighborhood. Thank you
for the opportunity to provide feedback
on this draft plan. I urge you to keep
Timon Heights zoned to Cassiss
Elementary. The neighborhood has
historically been zoned to Cassiss. It's
currently is zoned to Cassiss and it
remains that way under the draft plan.
Maintaining the current boundary
provides consistency and follows AISD's
guiding principles. It minimizes impact
as the neighborhood is close to the
school. It adheres to a balanced
enrollment based on Cassiss student
population makeup and the current zoning
maintains a clear feeder pattern as well
as the long-term stability of Cassiss
and the neighborhood. I appreciate you
for allowing me to share my thoughts.
This is very important to us. Our home
is here and we've moved here for this
school. Um, we would uh greatly
appreciate y'all's support.
>> Hi, my name is Courtney Bowling and I'm
an AISD parent and I'm calling regarding
the AISD boundary change for Gorski
Middle School in Circle C. My son's a
sixth grader at Gorski and we live in
the Grey Rock Ridge neighborhood of
Circle C. We're very concerned about the
boundary change and reassignment to
Bailey Middle School. Bailey doesn't
offer the academic program in which my
son's currently enrolled, the the
geometry track specifically for math.
And while it's close on the map, it's a
very challenging drive. It will add
time, bus time, drive time for parents
and children. Additionally, it's
impossible for a child to walk or ride
their bike to Bailey from Grey Rock
Ridge or the Avana neighborhood in
Circle C. While my son has the option to
stay at Corsicki because he's currently
enrolled there, the lack of bus service
is problematic. We rely on that service
for mornings and afternoons. So I ask
that you please vote no to for the
boundary changes and keep CircleC kids
in CircleC schools. Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Catelyn Zuniga and I am a
kindergarten parent at Zilker
Elementary. My daughter just started
kindergarten this year and we've been so
excited for our son to join her next
year. The proposed resoning would
separate them, one at Zilker and one at
Galindo. And as a working family, this
is just not realistic. We bought our
home here because of the strong
community and the stability of the
Zilker, oh Henry, and Austin High feeder
pattern. It's heartbreaking to think
that our about the loss and losing the
sense of connection we have and how to
explain that to my daughter that her
little brother won't go to school with
her. I'm also worried about safety. The
new boundary crosses an active railroad
and before moving students, we need to
know what the district's true plan is
for Glindo. What real steps are being
taken to turn that school around? Please
keep families together, prioritize
safety, and make decisions that support
students and stability. Thank you very
much for your time.
>> Hi, my name is Julian Phillips. I live
on Harris Boulevard in Pimton Heights,
and I appreciate the opportunity to
provide my input on the current draft uh
regarding consolidation. And I urge the
trustees to keep Pton Heights zone to
Cassiss Elementary. I think there are a
lot of reasons for this. Um, but it
certainly keeps with consistency and
continuity given the history of the
zoning with the neighborhood and the
school and what we're zone to now. I
think that consistency um is beneficial
in a lot of ways, but certainly for
feeder uh program going up through
middle school and high school. Um our
proximity to the school is good uh with
regards to impact on the neighborhood
since we're so close. Uh, I think it
really abides with a lot of AISD
principles, but uh, in general, I just
hope that we can keep, uh, Pimton
Heights zone to Cassiss Elementary. Uh,
thank you for your time.
>> This is Roxanne Evans, District 1
advocate, expressing concerns about East
Austin schools. Care must be given to
ensure that schools receiving students
from tap campuses such as Andrews and
Keeling receive all needed resources to
successfully integrate the new students
and ensure the stability of receiving
campuses. Additional resources will also
be needed to asssure that the influx of
new students from multiple campuses into
Marshall Middle School results in a
smooth transition. and the boundary for
East Side High School should be extended
to Mayor Road to provide a more robust
enrollment. And you must minimize the
loss of transportation to East Austin
schools. Thank you.
My name is Jenna Grryer and I live on
Moly Drive in the heart of Peton
Heights. I'm a parent of a current
Cassie student and two future Cassie
students. Thank you for the opportunity
to provide feedback. We're here
discussing lines on a map, but for the
families of Peton Heights, this line
defines home. For generations, the
children of our neighborhood have
walked, biked, and driven the short
distance to Cassif Elementary. This
isn't just a boundary. It's a historic
and present connection, one that
thankfully this draft plan has
rightfully chosen to maintain. I urge
you to preserve the current Peton
Heights zoning for Cassiss, including
Moly Drive. To shift this boundary now
would disrupt a pattern that is the very
definition of stability. Maintaining
this line aligns perfectly with AASD's
own guiding principles which you can
find on page 14 of your report. It
achieves this by minimizing disruption
because our neighborhood is close to the
school supporting a balanced enrollment
that reflects Cassiss Ciza's current
student makeup and ensuring the
long-term stability in a clean feeder
pattern that has served this community.
Good evening. My name is Julia Jonas and
I'm a parent at Sanchez Elementary. I
want to focus on one issue with the
draft consolidation plan,
transportation.
Many of our zone Sanchez students,
especially emergent bilingual families,
live outside walking distance to the
school, and these students rely on
district buses every day. For families
without cars or flexible work schedules,
walking or arranging daily rides is not
realistic. And if these buses are
removed, as the consolidation plan
currently stands, many of these students
simply won't be able to get to school at
Sanchez and would not be able to
continue to attend.
Without providing transportation, the
school will lose the very students that
the district says it wants to serve and
support with a special dual language
campus. We can't maintain strong dual
language programs or meet equity goals
if access depends on who has a car. We
also won't meet the 50% emergent
bilingual ratio goal if kids who depend
on buses can't attend if the
consolidation plan moves forward.
Transportation must be guaranteed for
all Sanchez students. Thank you.
>> Hi, I'm Ryan Raldi. I have two scholars
at Campbell Elementary School and I'd
like to speak regarding the transition
in the consolidation plan. With the
um idea that we're going to be getting
more students at our school, I'd like to
um lobby for two things to remain. One
being the school uniforms. Being a
former educator, I appreciate the
structure that the school uniforms bring
and the and the structure that Principal
Moore has brought to the school. I see
very little discipline problems in the
school and I can attribute that to
Principal Moore's structure and the uh
uniforms which helps to level the
playing field between our economically
disadvantaged scholars and our and our
other scholars. I also would like to see
our interventionists remain at the
school. I've I've seen them make
differences with our at risk scholars
and our scholars that are from
economically disadvantaged backgrounds.
I hope that we will be able to consider
these during our transition and thank
you for your time.
>> Hi, my name is Aaron Flag and I'm the
parent of a child being impacted by the
reszoning associated with Gorski Middle
School to Bailey Middle School. We
purchased our home in the Circle C
neighborhood due to the sense of
community, family oriented atmosphere,
and excellent schools. I know that you
AISD trustees firsthand understand how
special our community is and which will
be fractured and disrupted with the
proposed plan. I feel like the rug has
been pulled out from under us with the
widespread changes leading me to lose
trust in AISD. I'm reaching out to ask
you to vote no on the proposed AISB plan
or demand better, less disruptive
alternatives on behalf of our district
and specifically the Circle C Grey Rock
Ridge community. Thank you.
>> My name is Cat Reyes. I live on Mole
Drive in Pton Heights with three
children. My oldest daughter is entering
kindergarten next year and we're so
looking forward to attending Cassus
Elementary.
We're discussing lines on a map, but for
the families of Peton Heights, this line
defines home. For generations, the
children of our neighborhood have
walked, biked, driven the short
distance, ridden buses to Cassiss
Elementary. This isn't just a boundary.
It's a historic and present connection,
one that thankfully this draft plan has
rightly chosen to maintain. I urge you
to preserve the current Pimton Heights
zoning for Cassiss. To shift this
boundary now would be to disrupt a
pattern that is the very definition of
stability. Maintaining this line aligns
perfectly with AISD's own guiding
principles. It achieves this by
minimizing disruption because our
neighborhood is close to the school.
Supporting a balanced enrollment that
reflects Cass's current student makeup
and ensuring the long-term stability and
a clean feeder pattern that has served
this community for decades. Let's honor
this history, this stability, and this
consistency. Thank you so much for
listening to The Voice of Our Community.
My name is Natalie Stannifer and I live
on 1801 Moly Drive, 78703
in the Pimton Heights neighborhood.
Thank you for the opportunity to provide
feedback. We are discussing lines on a
map, but for the families of Pimton
Heights, this line defines home. For
generations, the children of our
neighborhood have walked, biked, and
driven a short distance to Cassif
Elementary. This isn't just a boundary.
It is a historic and present connection.
One that thankfully this draft plan has
rightfully chosen to maintain. I urge
you to preserve the current Tempton
Heights Molly Drive zoning force. To
shift this boundary now would be to
disrupt a pattern that is the very
definition of stability. Maintaining
this line aligns perfectly with AISC's
own guiding principles. It achieves this
by minimizing disruption because our
neighborhood is close to the school,
supporting a balanced enrollment that
reflects current student markup,
ensuring
the long-term stability and clear feeder
pattern that has served this community
for decades. Let us honor this history.
Uh hi, my name is Da Kalabar and my son
is uh at Bear Creek Elementary in uh
South Austin uh which is part of AISD
and our middle school uh which is Geski
Middle School has been reszoned from
next year to Bailey's middle school and
I wanted our representatives to vote no
for that uh because the the journey for
for our community to go to Bailey uh in
doubles instead of Griski uh also it's a
toll road so it would just add an
expense. The current middle school
Griski is within the community. It is
our community middle school and we do
not want to be reszoned to something
outside of our community. It also splits
our current community into two different
schools. Uh so I would want for our
representative to vote no and we should
stay with our current middle school
which is Geski Middle School. Thank you.
Hi, my name is Graham Brown and I live
on WTover Road in the Pimton Heights
neighborhood. Thank you for the
opportunity to provide feedback on this
draft plan. I urge you to keep Pimton
Heights zoned to Cassiss. The
neighborhood has historically been zoned
to Cassiss. It currently is zoned to
Cassiss and it remains that way under
the draft plan. Uh maintaining the
current boundary provides consistency
and follows the AISD's guiding
principles. uh it minimizes the impact
which I know is extremely important as
the neighborhood is close to the school.
It adheres to a balanced enrollment
based on Cassie student population
makeup and the current zoning maintains
a clean feeder pattern as well as the
long-term stability of Cassiss in the
neighborhood. I appreciate you allowing
me to share my thoughts this evening.
Good luck. Bye.
>> Hi, my name is Tanya Flag. I'm a parent
of a two children in the grey rockidge
community. We have been reszoned from
Geritzky Middle School to Bailey and I
have a lot of concerns with the
transportation to Bailey. There is no
easy way to get there, especially with a
bus and the Gitzky campus is much
closer. So, I'd like you all to consider
the capacity issues at Gitzky instead.
And also I do want both of my kids to be
able to go to our community school,
Geritzky, which is one of the reasons we
moved to this neighborhood to begin
with. And again, I'm have a lot of
concerns with the transportation going
to Bailey. There is not one easy road to
get there from our neighborhood. It's
much further and also a lower rated
school than what we were originally
zoned to. Thank you. Bye.
My name is Eva Rosenthal. I was a
teacher at Mets Elementary for 15 years
and have been at George I. Sanchez
Elementary for the past four. My
daughters attended Mets and Sanchez and
received a highquality education from
excellent teaching professionals.
Through neighborhood changes, school
consolidation, and programming shifts,
our community has worked continuously to
provide highquality education for our
students. Today I ask you to rethink the
reassignment of Sanchez Elementary as a
wall-to-wall non-zone DL school. Mets
was over a hundred years old when we
consolidated with Sanchez after a bitter
rivalry for limited resources. Eight
years later, we are fighting with other
schools in our city for resources that
are intended for the public good. We as
taxpayers were asked to support bond
measures to modernize facilities that
our students are now being asked to
leave. Taxpayers voted to invest in the
East Side Memorial vertical team
elementary schools and removing
transportation to Sanchez as a
modernized neighborhood school is
inequitable. We ask you to provide
Sanchez with the academic supports and
transportation so that we can continue
to grow and support George I. Sanchez's
leg.
>> My name is Laurel Co. and I live on
Harris Boulevard in Petton Heights.
Thank you for the opportunity to provide
feedback on the draft plan. I urge you
to keep Peton Heights zone to Cass
Elementary. The neighborhood has
historically been zoned to Cassiss. It
currently is zoned to Cassiss and it
remains that way under the draft plan.
Maintaining the current boundary
provides consistency and follows AISD's
guiding principles which you can find on
page 14 of your report. Equally, it
minimizes impact as the neighborhood is
close to a school. It adheres to a
balanced enrollment based on Cassis's
student population makeup and current
zoning maintains a clean feeder pattern
as well as the long-term stability of
Cassis in the neighborhood. We are here
discussing lines on a map. But for the
families of Preton Heights, this line
defines home. For generations, our
family has walked, biked, and driven the
short distance to Cass. This isn't just
a boundary. It is a historic and present
connection. One that thankfully this
draft plan has rightly chosen to
maintain. Thank you. I appreciate you
allowing me to share my thoughts with
you this evening.
>> Hello, my name is Barry McBride. I'm
calling to support LL Campbell
Elementary. Uh it is a wonderful school.
I attended there myself. Uh that school
in particular has a wonderful very
important and significant history to
Austin and to East Austin in particular.
It needs to be re it needs to continue
to remain open. Keith Moore is doing an
excellent job. I am proud to be a
graduate and its legacy needs to
continue and it needs to remain open. It
is a very successful program and will
continue to be so. Thank you very much.
Bye-bye.
Thank you to everyone. This concludes
public comment. Trustees, do we have any
questions or clarifications?
>> Trusty Hunter.
>> Thank you. Um, and thank you to everyone
who called in and also showed up. Uh,
but that's still a small number of our
district. I want to be sure uh I know
that we have um cards with space where
people can write what they want, not
just select it, but they get to select
the thing that they're writing about. I
wanted to ask if we can uh on Facebook
and YouTube either put it in the pinned
uh comments or put it in the description
so people can find it who are watching
online. And then um where else I would
like to know where else people can find
um that Google form to be able to fill
it out.
So, um, Trusty Hunter, I I I'm certain
that we can post it online on our
Facebook page, um, or link it to the the
actual, um, video for this specific, um,
board meeting. As far as online, it is
available, uh, on our website. Uh, we
push it out. We can identify the
locations to place it, uh, and, you
know, continue to either post it on
Instagram or u, Facebook, wherever. Uh,
I've also included it in several letters
to the community. uh and we will do that
as well and every letter uh
communication that goes out to community
from here until late November.
>> And then I'm going to make one more
request that I understand will be a
little bit intensive, but if we could
have a paper
that people could actually fill out
also. I don't know if we could send that
however you decide to to do that for
those folks who need that tangible piece
so they can do that. And then at
schools, um, if we can have a QR code so
parents in the car line can get it so
that we don't miss anybody that wants to
comment or wants to share with us their
story.
>> Yeah,
>> that's Trusty Hunter. That's a um a
great idea. We'll work with our
principles and the communications team
to get that um get that worked out and
distributed. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Additional clarifying
questions.
All right. Thank you very much for
everyone who came to share your comment.
Everyone who's come to be with us
tonight. We appreciate it.
Uh we will now move to public testimony
for the action item on tonight's agenda.
Members of the public wishing to
participate in the public testimony
portion of our meeting called a
dedicated AISD phone line in advance of
the meeting. But tonight we had no
callers for the public testimony and the
agenda on the action items. So we will
move on. Um, anyone can share comments
with us as well by email at
trusteesaustinisd.org.
Uh, next up is the president's report.
As part of the agreed order with the
Texas Education Agency, we are required
at the first board authorized meeting
each month to publicly report by reading
into the record the percentage of time
invested in student outcomes as defined
by TEA during the prior three-month time
period and the total time spent in
closed session during the prior month.
The July, August, and September
three-month average board meeting time
spent on Lonear governance defined
student outcomes and special education
monitoring was 74%.
We've exceeded our target of 50% for the
last month, September 2025, we were at
68%.
And the board spent 250 minutes in
executive session in September. We will
now move to our information reports and
updates. Mr. Sgura, will you please
introduce the next item?
>> Yes, President Boswell. Um, uh, the team
joining me today will share a
consolidation process update. Uh, there
going to be several, uh, team members
joining. Uh, Dr. Maxwell, assistant
superintendent of, um, academics.
Christine Seamort, uh, um, operations
officer. Uh, we have, uh, Dr. Rachel
French, director of planning, project
manager, project management. Uh, we have
Avette Gardanas, uh, director of
multilingual education. We have Dr.
Lewis uh executive director or senior
executive director of um counseling and
mental health and uh there are others
also in the team uh who will be
supporting um the conversation as we
move forward.
All right. So uh before we get going um
I think it's important that uh share a
couple thoughts and words. Um, the first
is that,
you know, I want to apologize uh to our
community for just the
disruption and just the challenges that
we're having to to navigate uh at this
time. Um, you know, someone who who
loves this organization and loves the
city, it's not lost on me how disruptive
this is for our families, for our
students. Um and this is a a draft plan.
Uh the team will continue to work and
refine. Uh there are many pressures um
and many constraints that we're
navigating. Uh so I appreciate everybody
coming out um providing their feedback.
We're going to continue to to work uh
and ultimately um you know bring
something forward that I hope uh will
move us as a district uh forward.
Uh this work is uh it is difficult and
there's is really one thing uh that
we're trying to accomplish and this is
just one step in that effort. Uh and
that is to have um strong uh
neighborhood schools but just not in
part one part of us or another but
throughout the entire city. And we talk
about this a lot, but we don't often
talk about all the things that are
required uh to be able to to have that
be a real reality for all of our
students.
And we have to do it while we're
navigating many many things. uh you know
we we are it's not lost on anybody in
this room our board certainly that the
cost of education has increased
year-over-year and we have not gotten
support from the state the federal
government the changes that we've seen
have adversely impacted us to a
significant degree with real loss in
program dollars grant funds exceeding
tens of millions of dollars yes we are
also under a TA agreed order for special
education to address
years and years of um um just just real
challenges in the system. Uh and that
work has not gone away and it won't go
away.
We also have accountability uh to
navigate. You know, I I have been clear
about our focus on ensuring that our
students improve academically, but it
needs to be done in a way that lands
with our values. And we've said over and
over and over again that our students
are more than just a letter grade. Uh we
as a team believe it. I know our board
believes it. And
and we also have to acknowledge that the
way that we are measured. The risks that
get introduced to our system are largely
dependent on those letters that are
received and not by us by the state of
Texas.
And so there has been a lot of work over
the last, you know, two and a half,
three years. Uh, and we've decided to
not do some things. Uh, we've decided
that we were going to do difficult
things when it came to refining our
budget, reducing our budget, but we were
going to protect those things that
really embodied who we were as an
organization. We retained librarians. We
retained registered nurses. Other school
districts do not have these in their
walls. We do. We made a decision over a
year ago to retain planning time
uh and and not move to a seven out of
eight um master schedule for secondary.
That was a $20 million swing.
We've decided not to increase class
sizes. And one of the things that is
often not said is that we have decided
to retain ownership of the curriculum
that we deliver to our kids every single
day. And there are school districts all
across the state who are taking
advantage of the offerings from the
state. And we are not doing that. We're
electing to invest in the curriculum.
And this is not just hundreds of
thousands of dollars. This is six,
seven, eight million dollars every other
year that we're having to pay. But we
believe in the work and we believe in
the resources and we need to retain that
responsibility. And so, yes, we are at a
a moment where these pressures have um
gotten to a point where we have to do
something, but I don't want our
community to think that we haven't been
working extremely hard for the last two
and a half years before we ever got to
this point. And much of that work was
really around academics and improving
how we serve our students.
And Dr. Maxwell is going to take us
through kind of uh the next several
slides that lay out kind of where we
are, but more importantly like the
things that we believe in and absolutely
have to be true for every school in
Austin ISD in all parts of Austin to be
strong, be vibrant, be loving, uh and
most importantly, you know, contribute
to, you know, this community uh in an
equitable way.
Thank you, Superintendent Sugura, and
good evening, board of trustees. Um, as
um, Mr. Sugura was describing, we've put
together a few of the really impactful
levers that um, are required to set up a
strong academic system. A lot of work
has been done the last couple of years
to really create this strong academic
foundation and and it's expanding and
and um, more work is being done. Uh
these five levers that we'll talk about
tonight are around the culture really
that all of this thrives in and and
setting up a a strong trustbased
culture. Um the very key factor of
having highly effective teachers in our
classroom. We absolutely could not
improve academics without highly
effective teachers. Um aligning our
curriculum and instructional materials.
So the things that we create in Austin
ISD align to the instructional materials
that teachers have in their hands every
day.
um the the instructional support and the
investment in professional learning and
just supporting our campuses through
through various ways and then uh a a
system overall in which to really um
implement all of these things that
refers to our MTSS system and that's a
system that is built to respond um to
every student's needs um throughout the
district that we've we've worked on the
past couple of years as well.
Um so this slide just really uh goes
through a little bit of um what it means
to have a highly effective teacher in
the classroom and also a little bit
about what it means to have strong
school systems that support those
teachers. So really this is talking
about the quality of the district, the
quality of the school and the quality of
the teacher and the impact that that has
on student learning. So if it's an a
average performing student performing in
the 50th percentile, that's what we're
looking at. Um on the right hand side
for reading and for math and on the left
three columns you have uh a kind of a
quality of the district, quality of the
school and quality of the teacher. And
you can see there highlighted in green
the quality of the teacher.
>> Um hi hi um so when we're talking about
teacher quality
what definition whose definition is
that? So this is a model based on a
metaanalysis of research uh for
districts that included districts,
schools, teachers. Um so it's it's
actually like multiple research studies
uh that identify just different aspects
of quality teaching in the classroom.
It's not necess
um because you know so I'm I'm a
teacher. I taught at Pierce for my first
two years. Um and that school closed. Um
then I went to Ann Richards. So there I
was considered a very highquality
teacher. Um when they were closing
Pierce, they said Pierce didn't have
highquality teachers. So I was the same
person. Um we've had HR coming to our
very dedicated veteran teachers schools
and telling them they're going to be
replaced with high quality teachers. So,
um, that terminology, um, used in
certain ways is is offensive to our
staff who are who are amazing teachers.
So, I just want to kind of like push
back on that and maybe
um, you know, if that's Yeah, I would
say that we we don't want to hear a
presentation um, with that language that
disparages our our teachers who are
working really hard.
>> So, to be clear, we are not dis I we are
not disparaging teachers. The intent of
this slide is to communicate how power
how powerful our teachers are in the
school system. Uh and and that is what
will drive the presentation. We've
committed and what we're going to show
in the next couple slides an investment
in teachers for the last many years. And
one of the things we talked about I
heard from comments was you know with
the that we're running a deficit because
we've chosen to invest in teachers. So
that is the purpose of this. I apologize
if it's if it's um comes off a certain
way, but really the intent is to show
really how important our educators are
and that we retain them and support them
and care for them the only way AISD can.
>> So we can just go to the next slide.
That's fine, Dr. Maxwell.
>> That's fine. Um
>> I'm so sorry. I actually really
appreciate this chart a lot. So I just
want to say like um this is something
that I've really been asking for. So
just thank you for really laying out the
effort that is going into developing our
teachers and investing in them. Thank
you.
>> Um so ultimately um we know that the
teacher has the most impact on students
and their outcomes and their wellness
and everything that we would hope for
student achievement um in the classroom.
Um and our investment in teachers does
matter um for that and and getting
teachers um in the classroom, investing
in teachers um is is always a goal I
think that um any one of us including
the districts and the schools that are
on that slide as well hope to be
invested in and hope to um increase our
capacity and our ability to serve
students. And so these are just a few of
the things that that we have done over
the past couple of years um to improve
uh getting teachers in the classroom and
our systems that that do that. So in our
title one schools we moved from a 66%
teacher retention to an 80 retention
from 2022 um as of uh September 1st this
year. Um you can see the staffing rate
increase from 90 to 97%.
um all teachers uh not just title one
but when you look at the all teachers
picture 72% to 85%
uh that we're able to retain and staying
in the district um and uh 12% as
non-certified teachers um and so knowing
that some of our non-certified teachers
are typically concentrated as well in
areas of schools that are hard to staff
um in the areas where we have uh dual
language uh classrooms where we have
bilingual the need for additional
bilingual certifications, um, ESL
certifications, special ed
certifications, those are the hardest to
staff and often where we find many of
our non-certified teachers. Um, and so
some of the actions to date that we've
taken on that are really those
compensation increases that the 7%
increase um that we've used the tax rate
increase to increase that compensation
for teachers as well. Um, some of the
the new funding for HB2 uh helps that
and assists that as well. Of course, we
have the teacher incentive aotment which
um really uh gives preference to and
larger payments to uh teachers who are
serving in our title one schools. Um
strategic hiring and staffing moves and
then really focusing our resources on
those that's that support and resource
index that we've created as a district
to make sure that our most um vulnerable
schools are are staffed and that we have
action plans for that.
Uh so some of the work in our aligned
curriculum curriculum and instructional
materials as well really what we want
here is just to ensure every teacher has
high quality materials. That was an area
of inconsistency in the district in the
past. Um at sometimes we only had
digital available. That's critical for
students um and in all throughout the
years to be able to have um actual
things in their hands that they're using
that they're writing that um sharing
with each other. Um and of course
aligning our curriculum documents to
those materials so that teachers really
have support and guidance in using them.
Um coupling those materials with
researchbased instructional strategies
is also a really important piece. Uh by
as of 2022 campuses were really kind of
acquiring their own u materials. Lots of
different resources being used and that
means lots of different strategies are
used with those resources. And so when
you have that that variability all
throughout the district, professional
development um monitoring effectiveness
really proves difficult to see if what
we're doing is working. Um and then of
course we had recently our focus on
early childhood uh through second grade.
Really taking that time to focus on the
grade levels that do not see the first
results in the STAR test, but they are
the foundation of all of our all of our
schools. And so an investment in those
students was really important. Some of
those actions that we've done are
developing literacy and numeracy
frameworks. Um those are um actually
vertical frameworks that go all the way
through 12th grade. Um purchasing full
sets of instructional materials. Before
we had a system where um if campuses
requested the materials of the adoption,
then they got the materials. We changed
that a couple of years and if we had an
adoption, every campus got the
materials. You just got them. They were
shipped to you. You couldn't send them
back. You we made sure that they were on
campus for you. so that you had what you
needed. Um, unless the campus had chosen
or had already had invested there are a
few instances where they don't another
high quality instructional material. Um,
and of course we invested in our math
materials um, redesigned those those
curriculum documents and a critical
purchase there were uh, K12 intervention
resources as well. So most of what we
talk about here with instructional
materials are all built for tier one.
These are tier 2 and tier three
instructional resources that we um
invested in.
And then of course instructional support
and professional learning. So um all of
this is supported with professional
learning of the district. Again, it's
hard to do that when everyone is doing
something different, which is really
what uh had been happening in the past.
Um, and it's much uh more aligned and
impactful when we're all uh moving
starting to move in the same direction
to really support teachers and support
instructional leaders um as well. And so
we restructured some of our um internal
systems to really be able to do that um
and develop um uh teachers and campus
leaders through this process. Um we
reduced some reliance that we'd had
previously on vendors for training and
started doing most of that training
inhouse. We still do use some vendors
sometimes, but um they can't quite
connect to AISD like we can and the
schools that we can and then the
documents that we write to support and
so we reduced our reliance on those and
started doing a lot of that professional
development ourselves. Um and started
developing professional learning plans
and tiered them for our schools and
support. Of course, we invested in
instructional coaches um as you know a
key part of that really valuable
learning on campuses. um and then
started providing all uh monthly
academic sessions to our campus leaders.
Again, all of this to not just establish
and do the work of building that
baseline academics but building the
people um that are doing the work every
day on campuses so that they are um even
uh more resourced to execute um the
work.
Um and then next slide. Uh this is just
an example of some of the work that
we've done. We monitored this in our
early literacy work. um some some uh our
partners that we were working with did
some several instructional monitoring
sessions three over the last year and a
half and you can see here the
foundational skills and literacy um
improved from 32%
uh effective instruction to 56%
effective instruction. You can also see
the the area that we're even where
somewhat um in place is reduced so that
when we can clearly say mostly or yes in
place when we're looking just at
instructional practices that's what this
is um for uh for foundational skills and
on the next slide we have some
comprehension skills as well. So we we
can see that over the course of since
spring 2024 to this last spring of 2025
that increase from 35% to 51%. That's
the in just instructional quality of
what we're seeing happen in in
comprehension during our literacy
instruction.
Um and then our responsive student needs
system. That's our MTSS system. There
was definitely an overhaul before that.
we really didn't have a district-wide
system that was in place and functioning
the same on all of our campuses. And so
this created that. Not without that, you
really can't have a clear um guidance on
on whether or not students are
performing on grade level. That MTSS
system makes use of every um screener
that we have and then also makes use of
every bit of data qualitative and
quantitative that you might have on a
student that tells you whether or not
they are performing on grade level. So
that MTSS system defines all of that. Um
and then of course our goals there are
to reduce the number of students needing
interventions and to provide targeted
support to students with more
significant needs. So previously without
having those systematic systematic
interventions and progress monitoring,
we uh have changed that system um and
also providing more content
interventionists um on our campuses to
be able to do that alongside teachers.
So those actions to date really are that
program development, the investment in
the tier two and tier three intervention
resources. Um Mr. Seigod mentioned
millions I think it was probably more
than six or seven million over the last
two years. Um a lot of these are are
costs that that um are things that stay
in our district and and a lot of these
are costs that are recurring annually.
Our instructional materials aotment, the
way that it used to work, what provided
a biionial, it provided millions and
millions of dollars for us to buy all of
these resources and to be able to buy
the things to support um instructional
materials and technology um as well. Um
that has drastically changed. the only
material the only money that is
available um consistently is just on the
resources a very few resources provided
by the state or approved by the state.
Um and then uh there's there is some u
money left on top of that but typically
what we find is what's left over that we
can spend it on um more flexible items
that may not not necessarily be on a
list yet. um we uh that that number has
become smaller and so it doesn't cover
full adoptions, especially not for a
district size. And so we've had to um
use money from the general fund the last
couple of years to be able to purchase
all of these materials for our teachers
and our students um and to be able to
continue to provide that. Um Katrina
Montgomery is not talking to me anymore
because I've come to her quite a few
times for the general fund for that. So
u thank you Dr. Maxwell. So as you can
see we've been doing a lot of work.
Systems have been put in place.
Resources have been deployed. We're
being hyper thoughtful about building uh
systems to understand where our students
are and ensure that the resources are
deployed. But none of that happens
without building a trustbased culture
first. Uh, I I have I know what it's
like to be in a fear-based culture and I
can tell you that what we're taking on
and what we've taken on the last two and
a half years would not be possible if we
did not believe in each other and
believe in the in in our kind of who we
are to move the work. And so there's a
lot here that we've done. Um, but I
think when it what I want to reinforce
is that each and every time we make a
decision, we're always leaning into
doing it in a in a thoughtful way,
making sure we protect those things uh
that are true to who we are. uh and that
will be the case as we move forward
through this planning process. The last
thing I'll say before we get into the
details of the plan is that this work is
already showing real evidence that the
system is responding. And you can go
back just a couple years, you know, in
2023 you had 30 F rated schools. In
2025, you have 23. 67 campuses showed
overall growth in 2025. You had three
campuses jump two letter grades. you
know, early literacy and early numeracy
numbers are essentially beating all
targets that we've set. And so I want
our community to know that we have been
working very very hard putting systems
in place to ensure that every student in
every part of Austin gets what they need
to be successful. But the reality is is
we cannot keep up without resources. We
just can't. And so this effort, all of
it is really based on freeing up
resources so that we can get to a place
after multiple steps where every student
in Austin ISD can get what they need to
be successful. And so I'm going to hand
it over to Christine uh to take us to
the next couple slides as we dive deeper
into the draft plan that was submitted
on October 3rd.
>> Thank you, Superintendent Sigura. Um I'm
going to take you to the next slide.
Just kind of where we began in this work
in the framework. Um, we started by
reviewing our long range plan. Um, this
was hundreds of hours of community
committee recommendations that went into
this plan. Um, and ensuring that we're
also looking at previous closures,
lessons learned. Um, and looking at our
equity assessment and looking at what
and how we can integrate those
recommendations from those plans into
our process.
You've seen this slide before, but I
wanted to remind everyone that our
process, our framework started with two
parts. We looked at our data rubric. We
looked at our building utilization, our
cost per student, the building
condition, the SRR(I), and then that um
was the list of schools that showed us
our misalignments.
And then part two we were really looking
at the contextual analysis which
included strategies of boundary changes,
feeder pattern alignment also um
enrollment caps and transfer policy
changes and program changes which then
um led us to this plan that we have
today.
The rubric, like I said, showed high
level misalignments, but going through
in the contextual analysis, we wanted to
weigh those findings against the rubric,
but we had to look at the whole system
as a whole and apply our guiding
principles with that.
>> This slide just really indicates that we
have a lot of issues and there are very
different issues at different areas of
our city and different grade levels. And
that is really what this is showing.
Um this is our impact uh elementary
school impact slide. Um we have our
building closures on the left and then
our nonzone zone programs. You can see
those on the map on the right. Um, we
are now opening up to a district-wide
Spanish dual language at four schools
and also a Spanish and Mandarin language
immersion school and a Monasuri
relocation.
This slide is really just looking at the
school closure and where those students
that live in that zoned boundary would
now have a new boundary. And so I just
wanted to talk through these and show
showcase that you can also see the
percentages of how much the student
population and where they would now be
zoned to.
Yeah. Real quick, Christine, before we
leave that slide, I think it's really
important. It's something that's new to
these slides. You'll see the um the TAP
uh note as part of this. Uh so this plan
address addresses um you know feeder
pattern alignments uh stable programs uh
consolidations. It also uh is responsive
to the turnaround plans that we have to
submit to the Texas education agency on
November 21st. Uh we have to develop
them for 3UA and two UA campuses. Uh and
for those who are following along that's
an ac unacceptable unacceptable rating
or count. Uh and so these um communicate
where those taps will be received and
the supports that we will provide to
those schools to ensure that we can um
kind of meet the obligations uh in the
tap are are identified here. So it's
very clear how they all come together.
>> Thank you. Superintendent,
>> I'm so sorry. Pardon me. If I may, Mr.
Superintendent, I have a request to make
and not to change anything right now,
but I just want to center us and refocus
us. So, and thank you all so far for
what what we're hearing um in our
documentation and as we move I'd like to
make a request that we move away from a
closure list to campus communities under
consideration for consolidation/closure
so that um our community understands
that this we are still listening
>> we have not voted so we need to speak
that out right so just moving away from
closure list to campus communities under
consideration for consolidation
closure. Thank you.
>> Thank you, Justine Hunter, very much.
>> Understood. Um, I'm going to pass it
over to I bet Cardinas to talk us
through the program reassignments.
>> So, good evening.
>> Thank you.
So, in keeping with the language, we'll
say that these are proposed elementary
school program uh reassignments.
Thank you. Um we do have as you can see
um ODM Elementary becoming a nonzone
program campus and students moving to
Pleasant Hill. Again, these are just
proposals. Sanchez Elementary becoming a
non-zoned uh schoolwide dual language
campus and students moving into Allison,
Zavala, and Travis Heights. Pickle
Elementary again becoming a schoolwide
dual language campus and students moving
into Hart. Wooten Elementary becoming a
schoolwide dual language campus.
Students moving into Pillow. Joselyn
becoming a Spanish Mandarin language
immersion campus. Students moving into
Cunningham and Galindo and Go Valley
becoming a monastery campus and students
moving to Zavala and Ortega. And so
these uh this proposal uh is also
dependent on home addresses and
following our updated district
boundaries.
So in the next slide, in an effort to
move to a more balanced elementary
schoolwide dual language um campuses
with ratios closer to 50% emergent
bilingual and 50% non-emergent
bilingual. Um we are looking at uh
proposing some dual language campus
moves and these locations were based on
where emergent bilingual students live,
our dual language enrollment at the new
location surrounding the schools and
proximity to previous programs. They're
all within two miles.
I want to take the opportunity to talk
about some challenges also that we've
had. So, we just talked about having um
campuses that have lower numbers of
emergent bilingual students, higher
numbers of non-emergent bilingual
student participation, but I also want
to talk about the shortage that we have
in bilingual certified teachers. And
that's a very real problem. Um we each
year, every district in Texas submits
their number of teachers who are on a
bilingual exception or an ESL waiver. A
bilingual exception would be um teachers
who are in our classroom but not yet
have their bilingual certification or
teachers that are in our classrooms and
not yet have ESL certification.
And so just to give an example, in 2425
in that school year, Austin ISD
submitted 456
bilingual exceptions and ESL waiverss.
So that's a very large number, right?
and there just simply is more demand
than there are the number of bilingual
certified teachers um in in Austin ISD.
So, moving on to uh the next slide. Uh
just want to point out this is getting a
little bit closer to that uh ratio of
50% emergent bilingual, 50% non-emergent
bilingual. Um, additionally, it these
locations would add 590 seats for
schoolwide dual language campuses. So,
this is um kind of expanding the number
of seats, but not necessarily the number
of campuses. Um, and we want to make
sure that our community also knows that
we currently have uh 59 dual language
programs. So, I know that we've been
talking about our schoolwide dual
language programs, but we do have 59
dual language programs at 57 elementary
campuses.
I now want to walk the um the trustees
and the community through one example of
the types of conversations that we would
have when making these tough
recommendations or proposed changes.
Um, this is one example from East
Austin. Um, before I dive in, I did want
to thank all those that have provided
comments and this includes tonight as
well as on the comment card. We have
gotten over 1700 comments and we are
reading everyone and the insights that
y'all are providing into our boundaries
are so helpful. And so being able to
make sure that we do account for things
that we, you know, we spent and we stand
behind and I stand behind a lot of the
decisions we make, but we're going to
miss some things. And y'all are able to
really highlight in your specific
communities how we can do how can we can
refine these boundaries and make even
better decisions. So I just want to
thank you. Um, in this example that you
see on the screen, um, and I need to
make mine bigger so I can read numbers
appropriately. Um we have space for
almost twice as many students than live
between the bolded schools. So between
Allison, Go Valley, Ortega, Norman, Sim,
Sanchez, and Zavala, twice as much space
than there are students that live in
this part of Austin.
That's tough. That is something that we
had to look at. It also is tough because
when you do look at the specific, you
know, in the rubric, what is the
misalignment at the school level and
where these schools are located related
to each other? Norman Sims, Ortega, and
Allison all had school zones that were
not giving enough students that fit the
size of their building. Even if every
student attended that school that is
zoned there, they would not be healthy
in terms of their utilization.
And so when you look at Norman Sims, it
was adjacent to Pan Springs. So we're
able to increase its zone because we had
that ability to increase the zone north.
But for and then for Allison, we were
proposing because of where it is on the
district in a very fun shape in this
part of town. The only option is really
that other area south of the river which
was reszoning the southern portion of
Sanchez students to Allison which makes
it a at a healthy utilization. Um we
then look at Ortega which can't pull
from Norman Sims because it is also too
empty the boundary. There's just not
enough students living in that part of
Austin. But you see the kind of gray
triangles. Those were reassigned
students that were originally zoned to
go valley. So when we make these changes
and again these were not always our
first starting point. We went through so
many different iterations looking at the
data and what the projections would be
and um happy to answer more questions in
our community meetings about what that
looked like. But what ends up happening
is that the area in orange now only has
enough students to fill one school and
there are three schools there. We also
know that Sanchez Go Valley are and
Norman Sims are all 20 recently
modernized from the 2017 bond. And so
instead of closing two schools, we are
proposing that to support these non-zone
programs. Um, so I just we were
committed at the beginning to minimizing
the impact in in East Austin
and while there is still an arguably
unimpact, this was our approach to make
sure that we're at least not closing
more schools in parts of town that we
did not want to close more schools. And
so this is just one example of the tough
decision making that we had to go
through when working through all of the
data and where the students live in our
city.
With that, I wanted to just go through
the remaining um proposals that we have
made. So, at the middle school level, we
are um considering Betachch Middle
School and Martin Middle School for
closure. Um it has been discussed that
to the consideration of keeping both the
buildings and allowing an opportunity to
really work with the community on
reinvisioning those in the future. Um
but at this point you will see on the
screen where the students would be
reassigned to similar to what we saw at
the elementary and the next slide
highlights that at high school we don't
have as many o extra seats at high
school. We already actually have kind of
the right number overall or close to it
but they're not in the right they're not
assigned to the right school. There's
misalignment. So if every single student
that is assigned to LBJ, for example,
attends LBJ, it would still be less than
half full. And we have other high
schools that are 126% full. So a lot of
the work at the high school level was
shifts in the boundaries. Um, and I have
another slide in a bit that'll show kind
of the end result of that. But because
clean feeder patterns was also one of
our guiding principles, we that quite
profound change at the high school level
because of how imbalanced it was is also
seen at the middle school and elementary
level because we want to maintain as
much community continuity from
elementary to middle to high school as
we're able to.
>> Absolutely.
>> Thank you. I want to ask my colleagues,
we had allocated 45 minutes to this.
It's taking a little longer. We have um
13 slides left. Do we want to rush
through those slides or just give it the
time it needs? Be conscious of the time
and take the time we need to have a
conversation.
>> Um with all due respect to the state's
guidelines for us and we'll try to get
our time back and all that, I would
absolutely want us to continue and give
this appropriate attention and time.
>> Any objections to that?
>> Thank you very much. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Thanks. All right. Um, so our next
slide is just to give everyone an idea
of where we have come from where we
started. So we have sewn this chart
throughout the process of kind of the
available extra seats we have. And so
our initial goal was to our optimal
range is 85 to 90% as a district. Um,
and you can see that we've hit that at
elementary. But you can see that even
with proposing or considering 13
campuses campus buildings to close, we
still have enough seats for 15,000 more
students. So there is still ample room
for long-term stability as well as um so
I just wanted to highlight that we we
didn't quite meet our goal, but we also
want to close as few schools as
possible. This is this is tough as we
all know. Um the next slide really is
just highlighting where we were and
where we are in terms of the
utilization. And again, I wanted to
remind everyone and we've tried to
remind um folks throughout this process
and in all the community meetings, but
we are really dealing with where people
live, not enrollment. We have to
consider enrollment. That is where folks
choose to go to school, but in terms of
our vision of having excellent
neighborhood schools, we have to
consider where people live. So that is
why all of our numbers that you see
reflected are actually based on who is
zoned to a campus, not who's choosing to
enroll in a campus. So on the left, all
of the red means these are schools that
are very empty based on who lives there.
So if everyone turned up the there's
just not enough students in its zone to
fill the school. Um whereas the dark
blue is very full. And you can see on
the right we have there we have evened
it out to where 100% of our elementary
boundaries are in that healthy
utilization range.
Sir, just to make it abundantly clear
and a quick quick question, but if I'm
understanding this correctly, just on
utilization, just on students in seats,
we would have to close more schools to
be within the optimum utilization as is
generally prescribed 85 85 to 95.
>> Yes.
>> To get to our goal of 85, yes, we would
have to close even more schools.
>> Okay. So, we are not closing all the
schools that would be required to hit
that number, just to be clear.
>> Correct.
The next is this same chart at the
middle school level. You will see we do
still have one middle school that is has
a the boundary is smaller than its size,
but this is Keeling and um as we've
stated in the deliverable, we are not
proposing any changes to the magnet
program at this time. There is also
still room at Lively for that to
continue as well. And then the final
>> one more. I don't know if you wanted to
talk about the addition of Marshall's
boundary.
>> Oh my goodness. Yes. So, we also did not
have a boundary for Marshall Middle
School. So, there were eight
elementaryaries that were um allowed to
opt into Marshall um as it's grown over
the last three years. Um we were able to
allocate five of those
elementarymentaries to be a part of its
school zone. We just simply the building
cannot fit all eight of those
boundaries. Um and so we go into that
more in the deliverable as well into
those specific campuses. And then
finally, this is representing that high
school. So you see as I mentioned
earlier LBJ at only 46%
utilization based on the population now
is much healthier at 73
>> 73%.
Um we are limited and this is where um
we can dive deeper at a later date to or
I'm happy any time to answer questions
about why some of some things we could
change and some things we couldn't right
and again we will continue to refine the
specific boundaries with the community.
And the last slide it that I'll be
presenting is showing the clean feed the
impact of our feeder pattern effort. So
I know this was a huge goal was to keep
as many communities together as possible
as they metriculate through AISD. If you
were to stack every elementary, middle
school, and high school boundary on top
of one another, that's what you'd see on
the left. Lots of overlaps, lots of
little pockets. Every little pocket you
see is a pocket of students that are
disconnected from their peers at some
point on their educational journey. On
the right is what the proposed plan
would have in terms of feeder patterns.
There are still splits. They are much
healthier splits and so every, you know,
much larger
communities being able to stay together
from elementary to middle to high
school.
>> Thank you, Dr. French. Uh the next
couple slides uh are just a deeper dive
into uh some of the budget um reductions
that we'll see as part of this draft
plan. And I do want to emphasize it is
draft. It will change I suspect. Um this
is a slide that we've presented
previously and what it just shows is the
cost on average for two campuses. And
you can see that there are many things
that are that are fixed or or don't move
very much. An example of that would be
utilities, um you know, operational
costs, uh that are that are just fixed
because we have a school. And then there
are others that are distributed over the
entire student, uh students, um
including administrative costs like
principles, assistant principles, and
other staff. But we certainly recognize
that every student will be supported by
an educator. Uh and in the on the bottom
you'll see what it looks like when you
combine the two schools that have
similar sized um uh student populations.
And so 250 250 and then bringing them
together at 500. This is just modeling
just to be clear. We do have examples of
this u but for modeling purposes you can
see here that the net savings and this
is an annual savings is $1.3 million. I
do want to uh state that um we are
committed uh to ensuring uh to the best
of our abilities that every educator,
every staff person in Austin ISTD that
chooses to stay with Austin ISTD through
this process will have um a a place in
Austin ISD. Uh in one of the documents
that is uploaded uh on board docs, uh it
includes our transition plan for staff.
We hire almost 700 teachers every single
year. And so I've heard over and over
again that this is a a plan that is
going to fire staff. That is not the
case. Uh you we are not breaking
contracts. We've never even considered
that. So just to be clear, our plan uh
honors those educators who have been
with us. Uh and I am very committed to
make sure that we have transition plans
that are thoughtful. Uh and we're going
to start with understanding what our
educators and what our staff want by way
of a survey. When you as you go to the
next slide, what this all means as a
total estimated savings, it's about
$25.6 million. I do want to point out
that, you know, we are we do believe
that we're conservative in this
estimate. Um it does include uh all the
elements that are within the plan
existing. Uh I've heard different
numbers around the percent of the total
budget. Uh when I often hear those
numbers, I think they're including the
um recapture payment of $700 million. So
yes, our overall budget is 1.6 to $ 1.9
billion on, you know, typical year, but
we give 700 to $900 million a year to
the state. So our operating budget is
much less than that. It's about $960
million. Um so uh the other thing that
is not included um are uh any offsets
for future revenue streams. Uh this is
truly just what we would expect to to
see as a reduction in cost. Um, I also
want to acknowledge that there are
investments that we're going to be
making as part of our turnaround plans.
We would make those investments
regardless if these closures occurred or
not, but they would just be an
additional cost that would impact our
deficit. So, just to be clear, like
those will occur. They have to occur in
order for us to be um ultimately
successful. Um, I'll now hand it back
over to Christina to take us through the
remainder of the slides.
>> Thank you, Superintendent Sigura. So,
next I'm really going to be talking
about our transition planning and what
does that mean when I talk about
transition planning. It's really what's
next. What's next for our staff? What's
next for our students, our campus
cultures, all those things that we're
thinking about in this proposal. And so,
we want to make sure that we guide all
of these folks with care and support and
a clear plan so that we can support our
student, our staff, and our families.
So, starting with staffing, um you might
have seen this in the document that we
had for the draft proposal, but these
are really our staffing guides. And if
you click that here, it will bring you
into the proposal and talk through what
the talent strategy team has developed
for not only regular um for tap campuses
with a tap or campuses without a tap.
And so, it'll go into a flowchart of
what staffing can look like there. I
want to also state that Talent Strategy
has begun making campus visits to speak
with staff. They have done so this week,
next week, and the following week.
They're prioritizing those um priority
campuses first, but we often know that
we have some some campuses that will
also need support. And so that has been
very intentional about those supports
needed. Um I wanted to mention that all
current staff would receive a
preliminary preference survey in
November of 2025. And then uh principles
for the campuses would be selected in
December of 2025. And then those
staffing allocations would be made in
January of 2026.
And then um the staff who have not been
placed in a position, there's going to
be multiple internal match fairs both in
February and March of 2026. I also want
to take a moment to talk about not only
our teachers, but our staff, our
custodians, and our food service staff.
They are also being connected with by
those leaders and ensuring that we can
offer them intention surveys and what
they would like in their preference as
well.
I want to work through um the draft
transfer policies that we have in the
proposal. So um affected families have
three choices. Number one, they could
enroll in their new zone school for
school year 2627.
they could stay at their current school
or move uh with the program or three
apply for a new program or general
transfer. So um want to be clear with
this everyone will still need to
reregister and enroll Austin for the
2627 school year. Um we we want to get a
better really indication of what the
family's intentions will do and we can
speak to that a little bit more. Um my
colleague is here as well if we can um
get clarifying questions too. But
grandfather transfers would be
automatically approved. So talking
through um I know that's very important
from our families and our communities.
We've heard grandfathering and staying
in that current campus that they're in
is very important. So I just wanted to
highlight that. Um and then we have some
bullets here a little bit about more
about the transfer policies and what is
being proposed.
I want to move forward to um the student
support and campus culture and we have
here to speak about that and how those
supports will happen.
>> Yeah, thank you Christine. Um thank you
for so much for focusing on um the who
we've talked a lot about the what's
going to happen. We talked about the
schools that are closing.
>> So you are
>> oh I'm sorry. My name is Landa Lewis. I
am the executive director of student
support services. Thank you. Um, so we
talked a lot about the what, but we want
to make sure that we don't lose the
focus on the who, our students, our
staff, and our families. And so because
of that, we have put together a
transition plan. We've had a group of
stakeholders working for the last couple
of months to really think through what
does this process look like for our
students, our staff, and our families.
And so we want to make sure that we're
providing a bridge for our our our
families, our community so that we
transition them in a place to a place
that is healthy and vibrant for them
that helps them to um maintain the
culture of the campuses that they're
moving from, but also honors where they
are moving to. And so we have put
together a list of activities and
resources that we're going to be
providing to our campuses and working
with our families and our communities
through over the course of the next few
months as well as through next school
year so that that transition process for
them is as smooth as possible. Um we
know that there's our comment cards that
are out there and so we encourage our
families to fill out those comment cards
because we want that feedback from them.
We want that um we want information from
them what will help you to um make that
transition. So, please fill out your
comment cards and when you do that,
select that transition process and give
us comments and feedback on how we can
support you as we move.
>> Thank you, Dr. Lewis. I I also wanted to
talk through the draft plan that we have
with those transition plans and that is
really merely a starting point. We are
working um very diligently on thinking
about what those proposed changes could
be and how we can really ensure that we
are looking at everything and ensuring
that we can backwards plan to be able to
support schools and have frameworks and
processes and connections set up so that
people know where to go to when when and
if this is this is proposed. I wanted to
go to the next slide. You've seen the
timeline. We are in our final phase. Um
we are presenting the draft.
>> Excuse me, chair. We're at 50 minutes.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. Trustees, do we want to continue?
Do we want to just what's our consensus
here?
>> Our leave time for questions from
trustees from the community.
>> Yeah. And and I think Josh, we are okay
on time. Correct.
>> Yeah. So when we had estimated two hours
for the entire um we're about four
minutes from finishing this presentation
which will leave an hour and
>> if we go a little longer than an hour
and six minutes we're okay.
>> This deserves a lot of time. Okay. Thank
you.
>> Thank you.
>> We're almost done.
>> Okay. And then of course the final board
vote on November 20th. Um I want to draw
our attention to the community
engagement and green are upcoming
opportunities that we have to talk
through our current proposal. um are
October 14th, 16th, 25th, and November
8th. Um again, with that comment card, I
know we've discussed that a lot tonight.
That is very important. We have teams
set up to make sure that we are looking
at these several times a week. We are
being responsive and developing
processes so that we can communicate
effectively to those stakeholders who
are providing their feedback. So, thank
you. We are watching it. Please
continue. I wanted to also draw your
attention to the web page. Everything is
on our web page. most anything that um
somebody is looking for is likely on
there. So, I just wanted to point that
out as well. And then um this is our QR
code for that comment card as well. I
know Trusty Hunter, you were asking
about that earlier tonight. So, that's
there as well. And we can get the
principles this QR code so that they can
share that drive up, pickup lines, etc.
Um and
>> thank you, Christine. Uh so I just want
to kind of close out the presentation um
and open it to Q&A but before I do just
want to talk about um kind of alignment
uh in the work and and really what we're
up against. Uh yes we are tackling um
you know some a a complicated process
that involves multiple things. We have
pressure in our budget. We have pressure
from the state and how we manage
accountability. We have pressure in how
we support uh our students who've been
historically underserved across our
entire district. We want to provide time
for plan families to plan. Uh we're
trying to kind of weave a solution
together that addresses all of this at
once. Um I will say that any one of
these things in isolation would look
very very different. And and in fact, as
I think Rachel just mentioned, you know,
probably would yield more closures in
certain parts of town than others. And
so I strongly believe that um we need to
move forward with a plan. I certainly
recognize as a draft deliverable.
There'll be refinement. We're going to
engage continue to engage. Um but we
cannot continue on the status quo uh
without introducing significant risk to
this organization. Um and so with that,
I'll open it up to the trustees for any
questions they may have. The team is
here to answer alongside me.
>> Thank you all very much. Trusty Foster.
Uh so I guess first I I really need to
offer a uh a note of gratitude. I know
I'm not alone as a trustee who is
basically spending every free night and
not free night to create space to uh
just meet with folk and hear from folk
and talk to folk. So I've had uh
absolutely more conversations than I can
count. um have heard a range of
perspectives, have heard some
perspectives consolidate into something
clear, but then have heard contradictory
perspectives. But in all cases, what
I've encountered over and over again is
two things. And that is that Austinites
are really sharp and smart and dialed in
and have great insights for us. and also
that folks have been uh incredibly
gracious and uh have been willing to sit
down and talk even across uh points of
disagreement. So I I really have a lot
of gratitude. I have a lot of gratitude
of course almost can go without saying
for all that called in but I'm also
really grateful for those who are here
still now and I don't know if there's
still folks in the hall but one thing
that's really important to me is that
whether folks agree or disagree with
where we end up going um and I think we
have a bones of a plan and I think some
things will shift but if you're here or
if you're online watching now What
you're getting is the direct information
from the administration and you'll hear
directly from the trustees the questions
that we have and quite frankly you'll
probably hear your voices lifted up in
the questions that we ask because they
reflect what what you've brought uh to
us.
I want to pivot from that to be clear
and this would count as sort of a point
of privilege. I want to be clear on my
values and um this might unsettle some
and it might um be affirming to others.
Um I have a clear north star about
equity and excellence and anyone who
knows me knows this. Anyone who's been
one of my students knows this. Um
hopefully folks on the board in the
administration know this. Um and hearing
from community here is where I am. I am
going to be an active and gracious
listener. Overwhelmingly, people are
nice about it, but even when people are
mean about it, I'm going to be a
gracious listener and really listen
hard. The other side of the ledger,
though, is that part of what I'm
listening for is what is going to serve
the greatest good for the most students.
And there will be things that I'm not
super sympathetic to. And I probably
should name them. Um, if somebody says,
"I was zoned to this school or our
family or where we're located. We were
zoned to this school and we're zoned to
another and I don't understand how the
academic alignment is there. I don't
understand how where we're going to be
in this new setting has what we need."
And please show me that. And I will then
look to the administration when I hear
that and I will say yes administration
where is the academic plan? What is the
academic vision? And what are the
material resources that are going to be
invested to ensure that we serve all
kids well in a new setting?
If someone says to me, I bought in this
community
because we were zoned here. I get the
pain. I get the family investment, but I
am not an amenity resource. I'm not a
property value upholder. And that that
might be harsh, but my fidelity is to
the strength of the system. And it is
not to property values. And that's just
where I am. If you want to take a
historic look at it, you got to go all
the way back to the New Deal legislation
and the starting of the FHA and
redlinining practices and blockbusting
and understand the history of
segregation in our nation, which was
grounded in assigning property values in
a certain way in order to facilitate and
separate folks and gain higher property
values in some communities while uh
diminishing the property values in other
communities. There's a deep, rich,
painful history associated with this.
And I don't think anyone's trying to
live into that painful history, but the
elements still linger with us. I'm not a
respector of property values as a basis
for how we assign boundaries. Every
trustee has to make their own judgments.
And what I know about my fellow trustees
is they have clarity of vision, clarity
of values, and I bet they would speak to
theirs as well. So, I'm committing to be
a listener, but I'm committing to
listening for equity and excellence. and
where I hear things that aren't grounded
in that but are grounded in something
that has to do with sort of individual
family uh properties or something like
that, we hopefully still part friends,
but we'll part in terms of where I'm
going to fall on an issue. So, I I just
offer that as an example. Um,
I'll also so from that all I'll do is
offer just a couple of questions that I
have or things that I hope get raised up
in this conversation. Um, one for me,
uh, nonzoneed schools,
uh, while
potentially awesome
have a historic Achilles heel around
continuity of equity, which is to say,
when we set up a school for a specific
balance, over time, what we absolutely
know is that we lose that balance once
something gets named as excellent. and
named as awesome and named as exciting.
Those with greater resources
are able to flock to it and with no ill
intent end up accidentally crowding out
others who for whom it's harder to get
to. So if we go nonzoneed for me, we
have to build a transportation equity
fund or a transportation fund and say
something like if you are an English
language learner, if you are low on free
and reduced lunch or if you are in a
neighborhood and now suddenly your
school is non-zoned,
you should be able to continue to have
transportation so that all of a sudden
you're not zoned out of the very school
that you just went to last year and
you're like, "Yeah, I would like to go,
but I'm 2.1 miles away and the bus is
gone." So, I would love to see uh
continued guidelines and and at when
they've been building these out and
other places, we've built these out
where we say, "Here are the guidelines
of what we want enrollment to look like.
Here's what the balance looks like.
Now, here are the guard rails to guard
it and here's the material investment to
ensure that we can produce it down the
line." So non uh so transportation for
non-zone schools would be very important
to me.
This boundary stuff is like blowing my
mind. Again, there is a histo there is a
history around boundaries. There is a
reason why our boundaries are such a
mess in certain sections of the city and
it unfortunately has to do with folks
kind of wielding a little influence and
wielding a little power and saying,
"Well, what about this street and what
about that street?" And all of a sudden,
little by little, it's like Congressman
Dogget's congressional districts over
the year. They just get so wonky and
weird and don't make sense. So if we
have natural and built environment lines
as our sort of theory of action for
boundaries, I would ask for consistency
on that and I would ask for like sort of
a double check.
Do the boundaries follow the natural and
built environment? And by the way, if
people want to question that as a theory
of action, they should question it. I'm
kind of okay with it at this point, but
I'm also open to to something else. But
if that is our theory of action, I want
to see consistency. And where there's
not consistency, where it's all of a
sudden this one little thing, this one
little neighborhood doesn't follow the
built environment like everything else
does. Tell me why.
And sometimes you guys are pretty darn
smart. You'll go, "This is why." And
I'll go, "Oh, okay. then I'm gonna have
to be a good communicator and
communicate that I understand your why
and I'm with you. But I might fall on
the other side of the ledger, too, and
go, I'm sorry, this continues to not
make sense to me and and so I'm I'm kind
of a no. So, I'm going to look for
consistency in things like our
boundaries, which like I said are sort
of mind-blowing because it's a big thing
you all are dealing with in terms of all
these little nooks and crannies.
Um,
I love when I love Campbell. And by the
way, I'm also like hecka appreciate
appreciative of like the spirit of
Campbell families that called in. Um, I
kind of want to shout out my Ridge
there's so many people I want to shout
out for just their graciousness and the
way they've come to this. I've talked
I've got a letter from what 167 Ridgtop
families orund I don't know a whole
bunch of over 100 folks saying wow we're
here at ridgetop
we want to keep our schoolwide dual
language we want to keep our leadership
team and we understand that to achieve
the balance that we by the way don't
have
low ecois numbers tiny the 50/50 we're
trying to achieve in terms of emerging
uh in English language learners versus
those for whom English is a primary
language and they're learning Spanish.
We're out of whack. And the Ridgetop
families want the balance. They want the
schoolwide and they want uh a solid
leadership team and program.
And what I said, well, what happens if
you have to move?
They were hurt and they were sad and
they were tears. But at the end of the
day, they said, "This is Austin and we
can do this." And Pickle's a pretty cool
historic community in the heart of St.
John's and we can make that move. I'm
I'm like trying not to like choke up at
just how beautiful my D3 families and
communities and schools are. And I could
go down the list of all these schools,
how amazing they are.
So there's an alignment, right? But then
when I look at Monasuri,
this is probably going to get me in a
lot of hot water with a lot of people.
Monasuri
is multi-age
in the same setting. Monasuri is
self-paced.
Monasuri is not grounded in benchmarks
and testing and hitting this particular
mark at this particular moment. it is
attuned to the needs of the individual
child.
Dual language has historically had a lot
of the same challenges where what we're
doing with dual language doesn't map
really nicely and tightly to a state
accountability system. But when we get
dual language right, it works out. When
we get Monasuri right, it works out. But
gosh, it's a hard lift to do the triple
bind of the monastery principles, which
are awesome principles, the dual
language principles, which are awesome
principles, and the reality of a
punitive state accountability system
that demands you hit this mark at this
moment all the way up the line. I need
the administration to help me see how we
can actually do monasuri and monatory
and dual language and monatory and dual
language in the state accountability
system. I'm I'm right now I'm on the
side of I don't think we can do it.
And Monasuri is something that once
we're out of this multiple FS trap, it's
something we could lean into. Or once we
or we take Monasuri and we say Montory,
Monasuri is a strand that is available
to families in a space in a school. But
the schoolwide Monasuri uh I I'll just
claim agnosticism at this point. I need
to be I need to have it explained to me.
And again, I'm not a monastery expert. I
know a little bit about education. I'm
not a dual language expert. I know a
little about education. So, I I think I
can be educated, but I'll make up, you
know, at the end of the day, of course,
I'll make up my own fill in the blank
mind. Um,
I have questions about why uh single
gender schools aren't part of the
conversation. I'm going to get in
trouble on this one, too. Um, we have
three, which is a interesting number.
And um I'm wondering for instance about
the underenrollment
at the single gender middle schools and
how that fits into our picture. Are we
kind of like conveniently not talking
about that one or is there a really good
reason to not talk about it or is there
an opportunity to say Anne Richards has
a $10 million foundation and endowment.
Let's raise some money and get Gus
Garcia a similar endowment and then
let's make a decision about B the
Saddler meets. I'm not making a
suggestion. I'm just kind of wondering
um out loud. I'm super excited to hear
about transition plans. Super excited
when I think of
a caller said it. We got uniforms at
Campbell and Maplewood. That's a
historic place with its own special
vibe. And those are two wonderful,
beautiful vibes. How are they brought
together? And at Norman Sims, I remember
when there was a march from one campus
to the other with all the kids together
to kind of build community and that kind
of journey of like getting it right
through being really thoughtful. I need
to see and I'm hearing about and I'm
excited. I just want to aloud the
investment in the transition piece. I
think it's
excuse me um super super uh critical my
mouth is dry. Um, and the last thing
I'll say is that like enrolls has got to
be tight tight tight tight tight tight
when we come into the next round. And we
need to make it as easy easy as possible
for folks to understand their options
and get on board especially where
there's new configurations especially
where we have English language learners
and folks who may or may not be
conversant with the technology. So, with
those last two, it's kind of like a glad
to hear it and leaning in and let's
let's go on that. Um,
I uh heard a lot of people talk about
uh kind of ill intent or and and I don't
see the ill intent. I'm actually
grateful. And, you know, I was one of
the nine people that helped hire this
guy and I watched this guy build his
team. Uh, this guy being the
superintendent, excuse me.
And um I believe in the effort.
I've seen a lot of closure efforts over
the years. U typically I've been over
there on the podium, you know, kind of
on on a different side of this. And this
one has better documentation. It has
more documentation. It has clarity in
the why. and it has space for what
absolutely needs to happen now, which is
community weighing in and questioning
and pushing and challenging. I can't
really speak for everybody, even though
I kind of think I know their beautiful
hearts. I can speak for me and say at
this point I see the bones. I see things
that I think could be tweaked and built
upon and maybe even in some areas paths
changed. But my north star as I listen
to community is going to be to keep
listening to community but make my
independent assessment and be guarding
equity and excellence everywhere along
the way. I think you all have done
amazing work. I know a lot of the
community will park company with me on
this, but I've been watching. I've been
paying attention. I'm deeply grateful
and I'm ready for the next steps even if
it means I'm going to have to put my
reputation on the line because I believe
in you guys. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Uh questions or comments?
>> Question,
>> Trusty Hunter.
Um, one was about academics and I will
submit that in the tracker as a general
question as it really doesn't pertain.
Sorry. Go ahead.
>> Academic vision. Oh my god, how did I
not lead with that? Oh my god. We need
to be This is an opera. Trusty Hunter's
going to punch me when we get off the
diet. Um this is this is a beautiful
operations document and I absolutely
need need need in each and every place
and overall
so much greater depth in articulation of
what you is already in the minds but not
yet on paper which is the
all-encompassing academic vision and
then especially in the places of change
clarity with specificity in the academic
vision given the new particularities.
And now I promise Trustee Hunter that
I'll be quiet
>> and I will just ask my ask my question
anyway and you take it and y'all answer
it later. Not to be answered now, but um
uh Dr. Maxwell, you mentioned that um we
have when it comes to academics, we were
trying to have sort of a centralized to
make sure that all students are learning
the same thing, especially in areas like
D1 where there's a lot of mobility. And
it's nothing like showing up to a new
school and you're either two weeks
behind, two weeks ahead, or you never
heard this information. So, I appreciate
that. Um, thank you, Dr. Lewis. I wanted
you to introduce yourself because you're
important and a lot of people don't know
who you are, even though you move and
you move a lot of people. Um, student
services when our campuses experience
something traumatic, you marshall and
mobilize and deploy people to surround
those students with care. This is
traumatic
and we understand that. So I'm glad that
that you're in the conversation. Um but
Dr. Maxwell you had mentioned so my
question is and I again I'll post it is
what progress is being made to phase out
campuses opting out of district adopted
HQIM and how is that shifting the
instructional impact? So that's that one
for um our operations and uh Dr. French.
Um,
I have the privilege of sitting as part
of my responsibility as a board member
sitting on the city of Austin planning
commission and I see our city and I
remember when I first sat here I was
like lots of apartments, lots of kids,
not when you build studio in one
bedrooms and so though we see buildings
coming up, it's really strange for
people because I know it was strange for
me to understand because I have kids and
I'm a renter. More apartments does not
mean more students and unfortunately in
the areas that we are talking about. So
my question is what actions is the
district taking in response to
demographic data indicating uh continued
student population decline to ensure
resources remain aligned and we're not
back here in 5 years seven years and I
know that you can't guarantee that but
what are we thinking about?
>> I can start and then pass it off to Dr.
French. So during this work and the work
with our demographer of course as we
gone as we went through this hours and
hours and hours every week um we not
only looked at the boundaries and
everything else but our demographers
worked with the city and the city of
Austin and the permit office and the
developers and actually spoke to
developers and visited sites and our
projections are 10 years out. So, that
is something that is pretty typical when
you look at demographers reports, but
what we're really focusing on is the
five-year, right? We're looking because
that can be mostly uh zeroed honed in on
during this process because we know in
10 years things can change. Anything
else you'd like to add? No, you touched
on all of it. And if someone want anyone
wants to dive deeper into the specific
complexes that we have accounted for in
our 25 or 2425 demographic report, it
lists specific residences and apartments
that are in the ground being built. It
also has a chart that's really helpful
that like here's the ones that we're not
including because they're either, you
know, the sign might be up on the side
of the road, but there's actually not a
contract and there it's it could be 10
years out. And um there's been ones that
different community members have brought
to our attention and we've just double
checked and they weren't accounted for
but it was we were able to at least say
we're predicting maybe 12 students or
whatever it might be for that community.
So happy to answer any of those specific
questions to from the community if
there's specific units you want to know.
It's in our report.
>> Any information like that that we can
provide to the public? Let's just throw
it up on the site for like just
miscellaneous or whatever. So people
that really want to dig in, they have
that there and then they can account for
it. And then um finally um I want to
center us again around language. So the
term grandfather, I've already spoken to
you guys about that. Um I am very
interested in deep legacy for our
families so that if you have a
kindergartenner, you're not broken,
right? You get to continue on. Um I've
shared that also with the
superintendent. So, as we um look at
transition plans and as we look at
Enroll Austin and we talk about those uh
that legacy of allowing students to
continue where they are because I think
some of the starkness for families is is
they think that next year their kid is
in ninth grade or 10th grade and then
they're going to have to go to a
completely different school next year.
And so that means we're not
communicating well when people have
those big feelings around that because
that's something that's not even true.
They're like stressed out for something
that's not real, right? Um, so let's um
make sure that we um have the proposed
legacy plan for people to be able to see
it and maybe somebody will have like
some some ideas to help us shift. Um and
uh then again be sure that we're
communicating that this is not like it's
not a turn, right? There's some time for
that legacy to peter out. Thank you.
>> Uh yes, Trusty Hunter. Um absolutely.
And that is one clarification that uh we
continue to hear about that we need to
make stronger. Uh if you're in
kindergarten, you go all the way through
fifth. I mean that that is a commitment
we're making. Um I also want to talk
about the grandfathering deep legacy. We
are we are going to be changing the
language on it. We just have to do
communication around it because
grandfathering has been is known and
many people understand what it means and
so we didn't want to make a shift kind
of mid document. So I just we want to be
responsive but I also didn't want to
create confusion by having two terms
that meant the same thing out at the
same time. Um but we are going to be
doing that work to transition.
>> Thank you sir.
Thank you, Trusty Singh.
>> Thank you so much for all the hard work.
I want to echo a lot of what I heard
from um Trusty Foster. This is really an
amazing job. I can't believe it. This is
the second time I'm sitting on this DAS
and having to go through this and um
2019 was vastly different from what I'm
seeing this time. You guys are doing
what Dr. Holly said, which was you're
showing your work and um and I truly
appreciate that. and you are also
looking at um systemic changes. You
can't just do consolidations without
looking at boundaries and vertical
alignments. And um I salute all of you
for taking this on. I do have a few um
things that have top of- mind um
priorities that I would like to get
addressed over the coming weeks. Um one
is um related to budget. That is after
all a big reason we're doing all of
this. and I appreciate the pie charts
that you showed. Um, I'm going to
request even more information and and
more detail and I know you're planning
on that, but I really want to see
transportation addressed. Um, so any
changes in transportation costs, whether
they go up or down or stay the same, I
would like to know that. Also,
enrollment impacts. Um, overall
enrollment, like are we planning to
increase enrollment, decrease
enrollment? Is it are we thinking it's
going to be leveled off? Um, also the
cost of all the transition work that
we're doing, which is substantial and
I'm really happy to see all the work
that's going into it, but we need to
make sure that's funded well. And I know
that the figure that you gave, the 25
million.
Um, so it's I noticed that the net
savings went up from the 13 million
that's in the document. Is that correct?
>> The 13 included the offsets for taps,
which we're gonna have to and for all
the investments we're gonna have to make
as part of the comprehensive plan.
>> Okay. Okay. And so I wanted to be really
clear. We're going to have to make that
expense regardless.
>> So that's true.
>> So I just I I get
>> I get worried when we begin to combine
things when one is already going to be
fixed
>> like because this is a savings. We're
going to have other expenses that are
not even in here that we don't even know
about that are going to introduce
themselves.
>> Got it.
>> And so I wanted to keep them separate.
No,
>> that's fine. And I'm cool with that.
Okay. So like the 25 um million does not
include the $800,000 precampus taps
investment.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. So that's helpful and that's fine.
Um but there are things that that are
happening with this plan that are unique
which is like you know the
transportation costs enrollment impacts
the transition costs and um investments
in growing certain programs like the
Montasauri language and um and you
didn't really put a number next to the
real estate monetization but I think it
would be helpful to see like different
scenarios like you know like what it
could look like just so we can get a
picture of like a really conservative um
budget forecast versus a less
conservative budget forecast would be um
would be really helpful for me. I'm also
not letting go of the the HQ um
conversation. I think I think we just
need to explain it and and understand
the rationale um for um whatever we
might plan to do with HQ because that is
still continuing to be um top of mind
for me for academics. Um thank you so
much Dr. Maxwell. I did ask for a lot
more detail on there and you provided
it. So, thank you. Um, that helps me and
I hope it helps the public see that we
are investing. We're creating this whole
system around the individual classroom
teacher and the child and um and what a
heavy lift that is and um and all the
the progress that has been made. I think
it's really I really appreciate that
slide that shows the wins that we've had
so far and they are significant. We have
more a schools than we've had you know
in the last few years. We have fewer F
schools. Um we have increases in um like
two of our high schools LB was it LBJ
and um and Northeast have gone up two
letter grades in the last two years. I
mean it's it's really strong work. It's
not happening fast enough because we
don't have the money and hopefully we
will be able to get some out of this. So
anyway, just I wanted to make sure I
address the academics and looking
forward to seeing more detail around
that um academic planning um prior to
the vote. Okay, so here's some now like
more specific I guess tactical things um
that have come up from the community
that I think are important for us to
address is what changes in coursework
and programming will occur at schools
that will will be receiving students
from higher rated campuses. Um, so I
just want to make sure that we, you
know, there's evidence and a campus
bycampus review of proposed changes and
offerings. And likewise, I want to see
what changes in coursework and
programming will occur at schools that
will be receiving students from lower
rated campuses. And those are TEA's
lower rating. It doesn't mean that they
are worse campuses or the kids that are
worse. This is just tea's um you know
arbitrary judgment based on one test on
one day but it is what it is and those
are the terms and unfortunately grade
schools
we need to get rid of grade schools
because it's so it's it's horrible it's
doing terrible things to our to our
communities um that that website but
anyway um
I I think right and we got to do
something really fast too because there
there are families who are scared and
they're saying I don't want to send my
kid to you know we're going to a B
school I don't want to send them to a D
school and I understand that but they
don't understand really what necessarily
that means like win Montasauri has a
huge waiting list and that's a school
with that's had three Fs in a row
there's re like there's still great
value in our schools and so I just want
to make sure that we are really
like right now reaching out to to
families who are possibly even making
other plans Um
the other couple very specific things I
wanted to raise up
um there is a concern about Sanchez
students being displaced from their
neighborhood school and being reszoned
um to older campuses and campuses that
are further away. And that doesn't quite
I mean I understand the rationale. I
really do. Um, but I would like the
staff to
think about
a way that we could, you know, keep, you
know, change that situation. I don't
want anyone to feel displaced. Um,
especially if they are in a in a
neighborhood that has historically been
underserved. Uh, and I know you all
don't want to do that either, but so one
idea, um, could we make Sanchez an optin
wallto-wall dual language like you're
planning to, but prioritize enrollment
of current Sanchez students instead of
the Becker students and continue
providing transportation to current
Sanchez students to Sanchez as well as
their new zoned school?
I don't know if TA will let us do that,
but that do you have any sense of that
would be allowable? Uh so we we have
flexibility in how we um
support the transition. Uh so I think
that's something that we could work out.
I I want to be really clear that
whatever we do at Sanchez I I want to
make sure because I I think the question
will then be you know what about pickle
or what about Wooten,
>> right? And so so then so then I need to
kind of think through the different
elements associated with that. And also
um you know Sanchez is a 3F I mean
there's immense pressure from the state
to produce a turnaround plan that will
be accepted.
>> Uh that is primarily a function of the
assignment of students.
>> Um and so I when you say workable you
know we have to put a plan together that
we believe will be accepted.
>> Um but I think that that is something we
can explore the way that you described
it. I wouldn't respond and say that I
can do it. I just want to I think
there's enough there that we can
>> I've just got to lift that up and I
appreciate your your willingness to to
listen to that one. And then the other
one um Go Valley similarly the feeling
that
um
students you know in that neighborhood
are are feeling families in that
neighborhood are feeling displaced from
their neighborhood school even though
they're allowed to continue there. Um
but they are also being reszoned to
older campuses that are further away. Um
so question there is so this is very
specific. Could we and you don't have to
answer right now but could we merge
Ortega say with Go Valley at Go Valley
and then perhaps consider closing Ortega
and then keep Go Valley as a
neighborhood school. Um and you might
wonder what happens to Win Montasauri. I
don't know. It's for real. Like I just
don't know. But I right now I'm
centering Go Valley because I was there
last night and and you know it these
questions kind of came up in my mind. Um
another one another potential option
would be could we make Go Valley an
opt-in Montasauri school but prioritize
enrollment of current Go Valley students
over the wind students and continue
providing transportation to current Go
Valley students to Go Valley as well as
their new zoned school. Um, and I don't
even know if that even makes any sense,
but it's just another
>> that that that makes sense. Okay. The
>> the Ortega that that because of Ortega's
location in the district far at the
boundary at the edge.
>> Um, I' I'd really need to work with the
team to like think through that. I Okay.
>> I have I think I know
>> I just don't
>> You get what I'm saying? Can I I'm so
sorry. We need to be super careful with
the way this is going right now. We are
traumatizing other people. So, I really
I really need us to be
>> I don't have the word for for what it
is.
>> I know.
>> But is there going to be a workshop? Is
there some place we can we can like
>> This is their work. I I don't know. No,
there No, we can't. Um I mean like like
out here like a workshop. I didn't mean
like back there like a workshop. Like in
here like a workshop. But I'm just
saying,
>> yeah,
>> providing those suggestions to the
superintendent so that they can do the
work and then bring that back to us,
>> I think, is a better way to do this
because we've already mentioned three
different schools that are not on this
list of proposed consolidations or
closures
and now
I mean I don't I think we need to be
careful.
>> That's what I'm saying.
>> Well, those are the only two that I had.
>> Okay. So,
>> but it's a long line of people. I know.
I know. I get that. I get that. And so I
just I wasn't sure what the if we were
if if
>> Okay.
>> So I expect to take feedback and then we
will provide a response um go through
that. You know, we will we will do the
work.
>> However you want to I am interested in
hearing like what other trustees are
hearing specifically from their
community. Um because we don't have
opportunities to do that
>> outside of
>> like I really do want to hear specifics
and I don't know if there's are we I
don't know if we're going to have
another forum to do that. So anyway, but
I don't have any more schools that I'm
naming. So, and apologies to anybody if
anyone feels if I've increased the
stress, but I don't know how else to get
this to folks. Um,
I also there was a concern about are
there sufficient numbers of non um
emergent bilingual families to um fill
wall-to-wall DL programs if they are
moved? And I don't know if that's
something
>> she can if they can answer that.
Thank you. So, one of the things that we
really looked at when we were going
through scenarios was having enough
seats, right, in Austin ISD uh within
those four proposed campuses for
non-emergent bilingual families. So,
we've seen the the numbers, right? We've
seen the document. And so, at three
campuses, again, hearing from the
community early on, they prefer to maybe
stay together as a community. not
speaking for all of the families, but
>> um we really looked at that too. So for
three of the campuses that works. You've
seen the numbers. For one of the
campuses, it does go a little bit over
that, but um but we are talking about
kind of a priority structure. Would
families be able to also look into
another campus? Right. For some
families, I'm also seeing comments that
it may be closer to their home actually.
So, it kind of looks like that's going
to work out right now. We'll we'll
continue to monitor that.
>> Plus, we um also are including that
immersion program, which is different
and new. And so, for some non-emergent
bilingual families, that's an experience
that they would want as well, right? So,
we wanted to make sure to have that
option for them to make sure that we
have enough seats for our non-emergent
bilingual families to participate.
>> I appreciate that. Thank you. Um I do
another concern that I want to lift up
that I've been hearing from um the
community is
element if there are any
middle schools or there are any
elementary middle schools that are
feeding into three or more middle or
high schools. Um, I know that is
something that we had talked about
earlier in cleaning up the feeder and
patterns, but and you don't have to
answer this right now, but I think that
that is something that um I I know of at
least one that does split more, but I
you know, I just wanted to see if that
could be
>> So, um, yes, we're going to continue to
to refine. Um when we had the work
session and I think it was on
August 8th. Um when we had that work
session, we talked about the fact that
we have middle schools now that split to
five high schools, four high schools,
three high schools. And I think it was
Trusty Foster who said, you know, I want
you to get down to two. My my goal, what
I thought was possible was no more than
three.
>> We pushed and pushed and pushed and got
almost all of them down to two. We think
we're still going to work on it. We're
we recognize that there is one break at
middle school where it goes to three and
then we also have a challenge at one of
the couple elementaryaries. So, we're
going to continue to work on it and
refine it, but um the bar was high to
get to two. It was very very high. Um
and I think in that conversation I said
three was what I felt comfortable. We we
attempted to. We're very very close.
There's still work to be done.
>> Um so, we are going to look at that and
try to get it
>> to align a little bit better.
>> I appreciate that. And then could you
also help me? And that oh I did want to
kind of lift up again um what I heard
Trusty I think it was Trusty Hunter
talking about um
when we are merging two communities
together that are very different um like
yeah like I I want to make sure that
campuses that are receiving like we
really do honor the programs that
they've developed there over time and um
I just have to give a shout out to the
the media program at at Campbell is
really really wrong. Um, so anyway, but
can I just get a better a sense of the
process since maybe I kind of messed up
by naming too many schools by name, but
like what is the process for the
trustees to be able to talk about
specifics? Is there going to be another
opportunity? And I know all of our
meetings have to be public, but I am
extremely interested in hearing what my
colleagues are hearing down to the
specific school because we're getting
hundreds of emails and and I really want
to like I'm relying on Trusty Boswell to
inform me about D5 schools. I'm relying
on Trusty Kintana to tell me about her,
you know, like it's it's really hard
for,
you know, to deliberate about this
without naming specific schools. So, How
how do we do that?
>> This is the form. I mean, I don't I
mean, we we I think hope you've seen us.
We will we will come back as many times
as we need to. We are constrained on
time. Um we will take the feedback.
We'll make adjustments, provide
responses to our trustees. Um you know,
I'll have to work with the board
officers to see what opportunities may
exist as we move forward um to to go
through that. Um, we also have also have
meet with each of y'all and as I have in
the past to get feedback directly, but
it sounds like what you want is maybe
conversations with the with the whole.
It's just anytime you name a school, I'm
going to have to
>> My objection is not to talking about
schools. My objection is moving chess
pieces because they've done work and
that work is contingent on piece one.
And if you say, "No, no, don't move
piece one. Move piece two." Well, now
they've got to go back and move all of
that. So, that's my objection to us
suggesting why not this, why not that?
Because I've asked parents and it's a
really hard thing to do. When they say
don't close my school, my question is
okay, then what school gets closed? And
I have not to a parent, not one of them
has said a school. I get silence because
that is a hard decision to make. And as
we begin to talk about it here, there is
a reason like this wasn't arbitrary to
pick these schools. There are reasons.
They're not happy reasons. They're not
feel-good reasons, but there was a
reason. Suggesting another school, we
need to go back and look and see if
that's the reason, right? There's work
that has been done. So, that's what I'm
saying. If that's a conversation we want
to have, we're buying time, right, to to
to have these and we we are having an
opportunity, correct, Lynn, to come
back.
We we have to have opportunities.
>> We have to have opportunities to come
back and we're doing
>> and we will manage our time so that we
do that. I think that is one of the um
one of the flaws in the system that we
are forced to under operate under with
the stringency with which we are
supposed to operate under it as we are
trying to make decisions that free up
the funds to serve our students well to
be thoughtful to our community to build
strong and sustainable schools. and we
will do what we need to do within the
system we must operate in for now to
make sure we give it the time it needs.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. And I just want to clarify, I
wasn't and I know it probably sounded
like I was suggesting or or requesting
that we make the changes. I I'm just
lifting up um things that I thought were
worth answering.
>> Yeah. I mean, y'all are in the community
getting ideas and we need to hear them
so we can improve and refine the plan.
Um, you know, so that's that's how we're
going to
>> and if it's a, you know, and if things I
lift up are a no, like you can explain
why. That's it.
>> Yeah. I just I'm never going to say no
without the data and going through the
analysis. So I
>> or like if there's a reason. Yeah.
>> If a trustee has a response wants a
response now, it's hard to give it like
on the fly. I I really need to think
through all the different pieces as
trusty Hunter said
>> and trustee to your question earlier. We
will have a trustee feedback form. So if
you want to channel those things through
that way, we also have that as well.
Thank you. Um, Trusty Kinton.
>> Yeah, I just want to comment on this
conversation really quickly because I
understand both sides here and um, you
know, realizing that this is a very
carefully constructed kind of Jenga like
tower. Um, and like pulling any one
piece just might, you know, tear it all
to the ground. Um, but you know, when
we're going to our schools and
communities to ask them what their input
is and and and what their feedback is, a
lot of times they are um having these
very technical questions. Um, a lot of
our families have been here for
generations. A lot of our teachers have
taught here for uh 10 or 15 or 20 or 35
years. Um, and so I would consider them
to be experts. Um and that's why they
are are asking these very technical
detailed type of questions. Um but I
also agree that we don't want to make
anyone stress
um or have you know any heart putations
unnecessarily. Um but
I mean a lot of the questions that I
have are from students and teachers and
parents who are asking these you know
why not this why not that. And so, um,
yeah, I would just love clarification, I
guess, on the forum, but I also want my
community to know, too, that like I'm
prepared to ask these questions, but I
do want to be respectful of the process
and the forum um, in which to do that.
So,
>> yeah, I I think ask the questions and
and and just know that some of the
responses will require, you know, us to
actually look into the how to respond
appropriately, but if we can answer them
now, we will. And then what we can do is
produce a form that gets uploaded to
board docs that's responsive to the
questions that we heard off the dis and
then over the course of the next many
weeks continue to get feedback through
our trustees and I'll work with the
officers to see if there's another
opportunity that we need to come
together. Um so I think ask I think you
should feel comfortable asking the
questions. It will help us refine the
plan. We just may not have the ability
to answer every one of them um at this
moment.
>> Should I do that now? President Boswell.
Uh, I think that's that makes sense.
>> What we know? Go.
>> I think that makes sense.
>> Um, let's start with um Sanchez and the
buses. I think that's been pretty much
covered. Um, I just really want to make
sure that um, you know, we're getting
our kids like we're not just saying that
they can go, but we're actually making
it possible. Um, and do they have to
apply
and go through some sort of lottery
process in order to stay at Sanchez?
Victoria, would you like to come kind of
walk through that process so it's very
clear?
>> Hi everyone. uh Victoria O'Neal,
executive director of campus family
engagement and I um one of the teams
that I support is the enrollment team.
Um
so the process um hinges on um all
families engaging with re-registration
in the spring semester and so we are
planning a full campaign of um
information and support to make that
possible. And then um for your specific
question about uh Sanchez and the
transition plan there for the students
um the goal is for the program to be you
know 50/50 um emerging bilingual and
non-emergent bilingual um and um uh we
are working really closely with um Ivet
and the Met team to develop the rubric
that will be used for the campuswide
dual language programs. Um so I think
while there are still refinements to be
made the answer um is yes um that there
will be um an application process that
we will support all of the families
through. Um round one will be the the
campus based programs if um in the
proposal and um but there will be a
rubric developed um and publicized and
shared with everybody that uh clearly
lines out like how those decisions are
going to be made.
And just to to further clarify, we
selected, as y'all have alluded to,
these schools for a reason. Sanchez
already has the highest dual language
enrollment in that area of three schools
that we were kind of talking through.
And the we would absolutely want those
students to stay. And so while they
might have to apply, all of our numbers
are based on them staying. and we hear
loud and clear that we also need to
enable them to do so. But I just want to
make it very clear that that was
intentional in the selection of these
four campuses is making sure that the
existing emergent bilingual students or
existing students enrolled in dual
language at those campuses have a seat.
>> Okay. Um, I've also heard a lot of uh
feedback around the construction on 35
that's happening just in front of
Sanchez. I'm not sure if y'all have
heard anything about that or have a
response to that, but I just wanted to
put that on your radar as far as noise
pollution. I don't know. I just thought
I would bring it up because I've been
getting a lot of emails about that.
>> Uh, yes, Trusty Canthana. I will provide
a comprehensive response. We saw this in
2017, well 2019 when Sanchez was
completed. Uh we have um we we under
aware of the studies um we will provide
a complete response but the I35
expansion was planned even prior to
Sanchez being constructed um and went
through the process and and got
assurances from a overall quality
quality perspective um that the school
would be supported you know for
generations to come. Um we probably just
kind of update that reinforce it um but
yeah we are aware of the projects at 35
expansion.
>> Thank you. Um
>> and and just to be clear, we have Travis
Early College High School. I mean,
they're not there are other schools that
are on I35 for everybody that's, you
know, listening in. So, we we are very
aware of kind of all the things that are
happening.
>> Thank you. um forgo valley. Um
I think I heard um a lot of responses
about um they're nervous about a
monastery school being there that um has
not on paper performed well um in their
current place. Um, and so I guess I
would uh just like to kind of piggyback
on what Trusty Foster was talking about.
Um, and just making sure well just
asking I guess um if we feel like you
know a monatory school is conducive to a
you know A throughF accountability state
ranking system
um because there was a lot of concerns
about that and I think they're very
valid. Um, and that's not something that
I have the answer to. Again, I don't
need the answer right now, but our
community would definitely love to know
um if um
what the what the answer is there. Um,
additionally, there was um a suggestion
to put the monastery at Picon Springs. I
know that they are right now on the same
campus, right? because peon springs was
getting renovated or
>> they're swinging on the same site as
when but they are a separate entity at
operating as a separate school but yes
>> right
>> okay um so I mean I know would just love
to kind of pull one of those drinkes out
there and and put that out there for
y'all um
>> so trusty Kthana um regarding Pan
Springs I think one of the things that
we're going to have to be really
thoughtful of is That's one that's also
going to require a tap to the state
agency.
>> Um and uh unfortunately there are going
to be some requirements because they are
3UA. Um so I I I I don't know how far
that conversation got as far as you know
relocating Win Monasur to Pakan Springs
like long term. U we kind of shied away
from that because of what the agency
will will likely want to expect. Okay.
So I just want to make that that clear
like that's why it didn't progress it.
>> That's helpful. Thank you. Um,
and then I also want to just clarify for
everyone that Magnolia is not one of our
schools in the district and so we can't
like emerge because it's not that's not
us.
>> Correct. Magnolia Monator is not an
Austin ISD school.
>> Yeah, thank you. Um, and then for
Widane, um, I know that we are wanting
to send some students to Rodriguez. Is
that, and that is also an F-rated
school. So, I'm just wondering,
>> so, um, this is where, so two years ago,
they were a B, then they turned into,
and then they've moved to a D. Um, and I
and that's whenever you tackle a a large
system like we have with the number of
FS unfortunately that we're having to
navigate in response to the agency for
the turnaround plans.
There has to be um you're limited in the
options that you have, right? There's
there's reassignment, there's restart,
there's charter, there there's there's
these things. And and what we've heard
time and time again is, you know,
keeping the students in Austin ISD, um
if we have to go through a reassignment,
you know, we we have to be very
thoughtful of the resources we're
deploying at the receiving school given
that Rodriguez has historically has in
the past been a higher performing
school. We feel like that um would be
acceptable with the right um supports at
Rodriguez. Um and then Houston, uh it's
the minority of the students as far as
percentwise. uh that being a modernized
campus um that'll deliver here within
the year coupled with the new leadership
and supports that Houston is that's been
deployed at Houston uh we feel like that
would be an acceptable um turnaround
plan but but that is why I just want to
be clear like it's not that they've had
three D's or they were a B just last
year
>> okay
>> the year before last 2024
>> um and I just want to be cognizant of
time I know we have still other trustes
who need to go um but uh lastly with
Martin um I know that you mentioned kind
of having this like re-envisioning of of
what it could be and so I would just
like to know when those conversations
would start.
>> Yeah. Uh we would start them in the
spring um and we would want to get to
the at least initial part of the
transitioning for the students at Martin
to um Keeling and there's another move
as well but we'd want to have that
fairly well um developed uh because it's
going to be the same community that
we're engaging with. Uh and so we we're
also mindful of kind of how we're
engaging them about transitioning the
school while we're asking them to to
work with us to support the students in
the movement. So I would expect um kind
of mid-spring before Thanksgiving break,
we probably have the first series of
meetings. Uh you know, we would be on an
expedited timeline um when you think
about the cycle and when you would have
to, you know, hire a principal if you
were going to move forward with a new
program, kind of when that would occur.
So there's a lot of work that would have
to occur in a relatively short period of
time. So we'd want to get going in the
spring semester.
>> Okay. I have other questions that
they're more general, so I'll just put
them in the tracker. And
>> thank you. And
>> what I can do is anything that's in a
tracker that's tied to this meeting
date, what I can do is bring them into a
document and just uploaded them and kind
of say this is one of the things I was
going to ask and I'll respond as though
it happened at this meeting.
>> Okay, that would be excellent. Thank
you. Um, Trusty Dost.
>> Uh, well, thank you everybody to all the
work. It's a lot. Um, in I guess
consideration of the time, I'm going to
efficiently uh try and spread some heart
palpitations across. Um,
you know, the clock's rolled over and
and we haven't talked about special
education at all in this massive
undertaking that we're doing. Um, I
don't think there's enough time to get
into the depth of conversation on
special education that the community
would want and and deserve really. think
um
maybe the briefest way I would put it is
the amount that we've talked about dual
education or dual language education um
which is certainly warranted almost
everything that was said about that
should be talked about for special
education as well staffing ratios the
quality or you know the experience of
teachers how it's spread across the
district you know who's getting the most
equitable service um transitions that
those families are going to have to Uh
on top of that, you know, for placement
options, I mean, there's there's going
to be enormous amount of IEP meetings,
arts that are going to have to happen to
address that. You know, what is the plan
for getting those through uh in the
spring? Um, I mean that that's a huge
lift and I know our special education
department has already been, you know,
so occupied with the TEA order and
that's this is going to be a lot of work
to get through in a way that is going to
instill any confidence to those
families. Um, and so, you know, I I I
don't expect that to be addressed
immediately. Uh, but I do expect it to
be addressed in advance of what's going
to happen in the draft plan. It's it's
it's very, you know, preliminary. we're
going to do these things, but those
families need to know how we're going to
do that. And uh I think it's um
certainly an untenable ask for them to
trust that that's going to come after
the plan comes out. They need to know
what's going to happen if you know
they're going to support the plan. And
and I think that community in particular
is is one that's spread all across the
district. So being that this plan is
affecting the entire district, um it's
it's affecting that entire community.
Um, so I I I want to see that part. Um,
kind of to the staff in general, again,
like I I really appreciate uh, you know,
what we're doing here. Um,
my personal opinion is if this task that
we're undertaking u doesn't succeed,
it's largely going to be a communication
failure. Um, you know, historically,
communicating with the district is a
problem. This is so complicated. There's
so much going on. I know it's a huge ask
on the admin. Everybody's everybody's
working on it. Um, you know, our
messaging I I think has improved some.
It needs to improve more and more and
rapidly because of how complex this is.
We're getting engagement for the
community and uh to the community
members that spoke out and you know the
documents we're getting uh you know,
excellent job. You know, you guys are
not uh tasked to be communicating the
type of stuff that you are. um we are
the admin is and it's it's a hard task
but I I really believe that is going to
be a make or break on this thing and
just to give an example and this is the
heart attack for the superintendent is
when they say you know one year not one
month you know there's there's a
communication element there what do we
trade if we wait a year why are we doing
it this fast we have all talked about
this the admins talked about this the
fact that the community doesn't
understand why this question is coming
up for a November nomber 20th vote is a
failure on our part. And I I'm just
owning it. I'm not criticizing
everybody. I'm saying that is an area
that we haven't improved enough on fast
enough because there are reasons why
we're doing this this fast. There's
reasons why we're trying to do this now.
And there's reasons why we're trying to
do this much all at once. And the fact
that the community doesn't understand it
disempowers them to engage in the
decision that we're making. you know,
they need to be able to have fair
communication with us so that they can
inform the trustees votes. And my
concern is that they the community at
large is not going to understand the
magnitude of the the vote that we're
going to have. And I'm not trying to
oversell the vote, but I mean, you know,
it's an important thing. We could vote
no. We could delay. We could replan, but
I don't believe that the community at
large really has a firm grasp on why
we're trying to do it November 20th. And
so that's just to highlight the
complexity you had on some of these
slides, you know, the turnaround plan,
but then as we discuss it, we're only
talking about consolidation and those
things are completely intertwined in our
discussion. And it's really complicated
to navigate those two pieces. And there
are more than those two pieces in this
total package that we're talking about.
Today was just the consolidation part.
So, um, you know, I'm I'm just
highlighting that issue for everyone
because there's a lot of education that
needs to go on through this process and
we are the educators. You know, this is
this is the school district. Um, so I
just want to highlight that part uh to
acknowledge the work that's being done
and highlight what we're trying to get
done in a in a rapid amount of time. Um,
you know, this process did start
earlier. You know, maybe we have a
little more than a month now, but it's
not a one-mon process. we've been
working at this for a while and it is
unfortunate that we're in a position
where so many people don't understand
how much work has already gone into
this. Um but that is a responsibility
that we all have and so you know I I
hope that we address that moving
forward. Um and then you know for the
community part maybe not a heart attack
but um you know I was really struck
someone said the metaphor of you don't
trim healthy branches from the tree or
you don't prune healthy branches from
the tree. This isn't a tree. This is a
farm. This is a garden. And things are
not growing equitably across the
geography that we're looking at. And the
issue is that we have to have the entire
farm producing. And we don't have enough
water for the way we're doing it now.
So, we're having to transplant some
things. We're having to make some
changes. And at the end, we still have
to water the garden every day. And
that's a community community effort. the
admin is going to do the best. They're
going to, you know, get watering cans in
everybody's hands. It's not going to be
just the school that succeeds because
we're not in that type of situation.
Double our budget and the school
district will do it all for you. But
that's that's not the situation we're
in. And I get it. It's a lot to ask of
the community and I don't expect anybody
to get on board without enough
information. So, I hope we get to that
point before November 20th so we can
have a vote that's fully informed.
Thank you.
>> Okay, trusty com.
>> Okay, thank you again for um the plan. I
am impressed by the technical nature of
the plan and how detailed and um all the
different pieces fit together with the
the various components regarding both
the um boundary changes and the school
consolidations and the the taps and
everything else. So, it's a it's a
amazing technical document. Um, it has a
lot of brains in it and I just really
want to make sure, you know, that we're
communicating the heart that's in it so
that we know that that we're really
addressing student needs through that.
Um, and I believe that we can do both.
But, um, I'm just going to zip through
some questions that I'll put in writing
after the meeting as well. Um, so I want
to know and be ensured that community
input was sincerely considered in
developing the plan. So, I'd like to see
some specific examples of changes from
early drafts that changed based on the
community feedback that you received
previously. Um, I you mentioned a
process for reading feedback and
communicating with those people who
provide it. Um, but I would like to know
the process to actually incorporate
community feedback into the revisions of
this proposal prior to a vote on
November 20. Right? So, not just
communicating back that we got your we
heard you, but I want to know what's,
you know, what's the process for
actually making changes because I heard
some I've gotten there are some that
seem like no-brainers in terms of
sections of communities that were
clipped in a way that may not support
the overall mission. So, I'd really like
to know um you know that those things
will be addressed. Um my first question
about closures months ago was about cost
savings and I want to go back to that. I
want to I would like you to show us um
based on evidence from other districts
and our own cost structures how the
district's projected savings from
closing 13 schools account for the full
range of real costs such as transition
expenses, transportation costs, staffing
reassignments, enrollment loss so that
we can be confident that the net fiscal
benefit will actually materialize and
not just shift costs elsewhere in the
system. Uh I would like to request more
data on the projected cost savings. Um I
know that the questions asked prior to
the meeting by trustees were referred to
it's in the plan. Um but the plan is not
very detailed in terms of where those
cost savings come from. And so one
specific question I have is where the
projected reduction of five of 754 FTEES
come from. Um if there are 754 FTEES cut
across 13 campuses that averages to 58
positions per campus. and the model that
you showed us, you know, it's I know
it's just an example, but it showed 15
FTEEs saved for one campus. So, I'm
really trying to make sense of if we're
moving kids and we have teachers moving
with them to account for increased
enrollment at other schools, where do
754 FTEES come from? So, that's the type
of detail I'd like to see regarding the
budget projected savings or help me
understand what I'm missing. I would
like to know what the projections are of
the number of students who will claim
the grandfather or legacy options. Um
how you know what are what are the
assumptions in terms of how many kids
are going to accept those? And I want to
know whether those projections that you
made differ based on the economic
resources of families especially given
the transportation. How many families do
you anticipate will actually stay in
their school? And how many do you
anticipate might want to stay in their
school but not be able to because of
transportation?
Um, I want to echo trustees Foster and
Singh's questions about transportation
specifically for legacy students and for
students whose schools no longer have an
enrollment zone. That was a very
important line of questioning we had
earlier. Um, and just to note that
school choice is not true choice for
students who do not have the resources
to provide their own transportation.
Uh, I'd like to know what your
projections are for the number of
students that we might lose as a direct
result of these changes. I know people
will say if we only go to this district
because of this school. Um, sometimes,
you know, those
um, you know, whatever, sometimes that
materializes, sometimes it doesn't, but
we I I assume that we will lose some
families who choose to opt out to
charter schools or to private schools or
to a neighboring district. I would just
like to know what our projections are
for that and how that factors into the
planning. Um, I'm curious whether a
reduction of more than 10% of our school
campuses would allow for further
reductions of district level staffing or
do we feel like we've already picked all
the berries off that tree? Or do you
feel like if we have 10% fewer campuses,
could we have find more savings
centrally since we have fewer campuses
to support?
I'd like to echo some of the cons
questions about the academic vision and
plan. Um, specifically, I'd like to echo
Trusty Singh's comment about the
families who are asking whether the
school they would be zoned for would
have the same course offerings. They
could extend that to extracurriculars
that their current school has. Um, I
think that's actually that question
actually highlights one of the most
important elements of this effort, which
is when someone says, "I don't want my
child to go to that school because they
don't have the same offerings that I
have at this school." Exactly. Right.
That's the problem we're facing is we
have different resources and
opportunities available for kids based
on different schools. So I'd like a
clearer public um explanation of how
this can lead us to having higher level
and great opportunities at every school.
So a family doesn't have to say I don't
want to go to that school because they
don't have this. I'd like them to say
I'll happily go to that school because
they'll have the same things I have
here. Um, but I know that there'll be a
balance of that because some things will
not be fundable at every single school.
There will be some things that have to
be different, but that's part of the
baseline that I would like to see more
clearly defined for our families because
that's a very real question about
whether they'll have the same
opportunities at another campus.
Two more. Um, in creating the schoolwide
dual language programs, we phased out
the English only track one grade at a
time so that we wouldn't displace the
neighborhood students kind of suddenly.
Um, as long as there was a critical mass
in each of the remaining grade levels.
I'm curious whether um an option could
be considered to phase out the zoned
school at Sanchez and potentially at ODM
and Pickle and Wooten also rather than
ripping that bandit off in one year. So,
for example, could we place the
schoolwide program and still maintain an
English only track for the legacy
students so that they wouldn't the
current students there wouldn't have to.
That would also give the neighborhood
students all the opportunity to attend
the school because any student in
English or Spanish could enter into the
school at prek or kindergarten through
the application process. So, I just like
to know whether that's I I suspect that
would increase costs, but I would be
curious whether that could be considered
a phase in. So just a clarification,
would you want us to model that as an
assignment within it? So they retain an
attendance boundary or providing them
that option because the the attendance
boundary is going to define the tap. Um
and so it sounds like an optin but
maintain kind of two offerings.
>> I'm a school trustee. I'm that's not the
operational details are not for me to
give you any advice on, sir.
>> Well played. Well played.
>> Okay.
Uh I just want to think about the
options available for students to stay
in their school rather than the fourth
and fifth graders immed rather than
treating it as a closed local school
where they are immediately bounced to
another school. I don't know about all
the boundary pieces that's I just really
want to think about the individual.
Okay. And finally, the section on
special education on page 57 of the plan
starts with students will still get the
services listed in their IEPs. And then
if your child needs to attend a
different school for services, an AR
meeting will be held before the school
year ends to make that decision. So the
implicit message is that no significant
changes will happen to our special
education services. Your services that
you're receiving now will continue as
they are. I want us to be responsive to
the community voices that are calling
for clarity regarding the continuum of
services offered at each campus. We're
asking for more equity around what
offerings are at each campus and if
we're calling for more consistent
highquality programming for students in
special education. So I would really
like to know as part of the academic
vision specifically what are some
expectations that our families can have
for improving the services that we
provide for special education not just
continuing them. Again thank you for all
the work and um I will submit these in
writing.
Thank you. Additional questions. Trusty
Willy Chu. And
>> so my questions are financial and about
TEA accountability.
So if we have staff that
>> I don't have questions about uh I yeah I
don't have any questions about the
facilities. Lisha, do you want to maybe
to come up for
>> I would say Angel and Jennifer just be
on deck.
>> Okay.
>> Most likely Maxwell and Elisha.
>> All right. Um, so my concern is that
this plan is conflating the Austin ISD
budget deficit with the risk of TEA
takeover because of some schools
academic ratings.
Okay. So with finances and saving $20
million cutting that from the budget, we
have lots of choices
with TEA accountability risks. we have
we have fewer um so where where does the
November 20th or 21st deadline come
from?
>> So the November 20th um timeline uh is
founded in the turnaround plans
requirement to the agency which is on
the 21st of November. So uh so that is
the legal obligation to respond to the
taps
to submit the taps on the 21st that
Friday.
But resolving our 2019 million budget
deficit is not that plane is not due
the same day.
>> So we have for the beginning talked
about having a deadline of November
primarily to address the disruption that
occurs
in in this fall late fall and then into
the spring. So, if we were going to um
look for reductions, the budget process
is starting. It's underway. Um we, you
know, have to make decisions to create a
recovery plan to address the 15% fund
balance. And so, if we're going to make
changes that impact our operating costs,
then we would want to take them in 2627.
Um if not, then you would wait and take
them in 2728. So, it's really a function
of a year.
>> Okay. So, we have how many schools that
need immediate plans that were due on
that day?
>> Turnaround plans uh between 2 UA and 3
UA is 22 24.
>> Okay.
>> 24.
>> And so this is the financial plan and
the two are are merged together. So
that's causing a lot of confusion in the
community.
So, we're we are tackling four or five
five things really all at once. Um, I
would say that um
there are opportunities in this plan
that might not exist if you did only one
or the other. Um, an example that I
would use is is probably wind monator.
the wind monatory program being that
it's a 3UA the solution we have would
not find its way in the same it wouldn't
be the same way because go valley would
not be part of the solution so the plan
for the 3UA at win would look very
different um so the idea here was to
kind of recognize that all these
together created maybe different
opportunities that we had otherwise if
we looked at them in isolation um so yes
they're not um required to together. Um,
but we did it together because of how
connected our entire system is.
>> Um, so what what other alternatives are
there to to cutting
what other ways are there to cut $19
million from the budget?
>> I mean, we we've well, we've I can tell
you the ones we haven't done. We haven't
gotten rid We haven't reduced our
librarians. We haven't gotten rid of
registered nurses, protected planning
time. Uh we've reduced central office
staff. Um we've limited overtime. We've
we've cut over hund00 million in the
last two years. Um
there aren't lots of other options
unless we're wanting to go back and and
maybe explore things that we otherwise
said we wouldn't explore. Um, one of the
ones that was alluded to by Dr. Maxwell
that we obviously haven't done is, you
know, we still acquire curriculum, you
know, $6 to 8 million, uh, it adds up.
Um, there are different strategies we
could deploy, but I don't think anybody
would want to go down that path. So,
there's nothing that is like one thing,
I guess, is what I would say. It would
be lots of lots and lots of other things
like what we did in this last spring
semester, which didn't yield ultimately
enough to get above our 20% fund
balance.
So, you mentioned a lot of things that
people don't want, but so I would like
to hear about central office further
central office cuts. So, we have 132
um six figure salaries that add up with
benefits to over $20 million.
So, that's about the same amount of
savings. So, not saying that those are
the the only cuts, but there there's a
you know, are there zero cuts that could
be made to central office? It needs to
all be school closures.
>> I I we took significant cuts in central
office. Um we we wanted to do that
before we took this on. I think to trust
Kaufman's comment earlier as you move
through and have um a few a smaller
system you would see an impact you know
regarding the supports needed at central
office. We're not at a point I mean we
we are operating
it is things are very difficult as it is
and we do have lots of vacancies. I know
people can probably pull up our org
chart and see that there are lots of
positions we've decided not to hire and
and and the work is extreme at the
moment and it's creating issues with us
delivering on all these plans and all
the work. Um so I don't think there's an
opportunity to revisit that until we
understand what the new system is going
to look like. But I think that moving
forward, I'm going to always look for
opportunities to reduce costs, period.
Um, I can't say for certain what that
number is. I I can tell you that all
those salaries, I don't know, the system
wouldn't be viable. I don't know how you
would operate it with all those people
gone in central office. Um, that's just
a it's a larger conversation that I
don't um
know how to respond to without really
kind of expanding that question. just
because just taking the salaries of
executive directors and assistant
superintendent and you know I just I
don't
it's they they're needed to do the work
too. I mean I think at the end of the
day like it's it's both. Um and that's
just what it takes to run a system. But
yeah, we can continue to refine and we
will.
And so talking about our our TAP plans
um like how much how many of our our
students whose schools are proposed to
be closed or to be reassigned um how
many of those schools
will be moved uh like will all the
students be moved to a campus that is
academically acceptable?
um
you want to
>> she's talking about kind of a Bington of
>> the nine the nine student the nine
schools um that have movements
um so of those nine schools how many
schools will 100% of the students go to
a school that's academically
unacceptable academically acceptable
under this plan
>> no they won't um we have really limited
options as far as our turnaround plan
strategies. So you can reassign them or
you can restart them. So in order to
restart them, you have to restart them
with a leader that has successfully
turned around a campus. And I'm using
all terminology
as part of TAP's ENT language. So I want
to preface with that. So if to restart a
campus, you have to restart it with a
principal that has successfully turned
around a campus or they have served a
similar population
successfully. So you could have led a
campus of um for our purposes, we're
talking about students that um attend
Title One schools. So you could have led
one of those schools and never let your
accountability um drop below acceptable
and again or you could um have restarted
a campus in the past. Um, you also have
to staff that campus with a certain
number of again TA language highly
qualified teachers and in full
transparency we do not have enough staff
that meet that criteria to restart every
campus that is through UA.
So in some cases we are going to have to
consolidate a couple of campuses again
if approved so that we are able to
maximize the staff that we have um that
are able to meet that criteria.
I say we have um so of the closure
reassigned campuses we have eight
campuses that are being move being moved
to 19 different campuses. So those
students are being the eight are being
campuses are being chopped up into 19
and 14 of the campuses that they are
moving to are also academically
unacceptable. So my question is um how
does this
prevent
um you know what the what the plan the
plan is being
sold to everyone as something that will
prevent TA takeover. So how will that
prevent that?
>> So I I I wouldn't I don't believe that
we're selling the plan. What we have put
together is a plan
that um
that creates
the TA required turnaround plans to be
thoughtful to move students academically
but in a way that protects our values
and what I say when I say that what I
want to say is yes an example that
you're probably referring to is Grow
Thompson and Wildridge where Grow
Thompson is a academically acceptable
school in Wridge doesn't have that same
history. But from our perspective and
from what I've heard from trustees in
the past is when you accept 100% of a
school and and knowing that the students
have additional needs and the student
population is coming together, you could
overwhelm and impact the school and and
not ultimately be able to move academics
um and be successful in in executing the
tap. Um, so lots of things kind of
informed these splits. Some of it was,
you know, whether the schools are going
to be in a modern students are going to
be in a modernized facility, what the
split was, how much space was at the
receiving campus. Um so I believe um
strongly that this these solutions would
be accepted by the agency but and this
is the big butt. We have to develop
thoughtful turnaround plans and not just
what TA needs. What they need is
something very is is kind of distilled
down. What we're producing is something
very thoughtful. Uh it's longterm. It
considers transitions. It's lots of
resource allocations. um that are
actually in the backup. Um so it is a
comprehensive plan. So uh we don't have
enough high performing schools to meet
the I guess 100% and the space to a
receiving school. We just don't have
that ability um in our current
configuration especially with the number
of schools that we have to produce taps
for. Um
and I would say that TEA identifies
acceptable as A or B. Um, you know, we
know just as an example with Rodriguez,
they were
>> there's been a revision state.
>> Um, yeah, that was a recent revision as
of like three weeks ago. It's it's
pretty it's pretty recent
>> statewide,
>> huh?
>> Statewide.
>> Uh, yeah, it's statewide.
>> Yeah.
>> And this consolid this this plan closes
six of those that we don't have enough
of high performing schools.
It closes the schools that are listed
that this part of the consolidation
process.
>> And so I'm going to I'm going give the
one of the pieces of feedback I gave to
our um consultant auditors when they
proposed school closures. Um and they
did a really they showed this will save
money. Um, and I asked, was that
assuming that people are widgets and
they move wherever you put them and no
one
goes anywhere? No one leaves.
We don't lose any enrollment.
>> Um, well, I think one of the things Chu
that I would say is um,
AIC's enrollment is declining. It will
continue to decline. it it as a as we
other urbans other school districts in
central Texas there they are declining
um and so I I when I get asked about
assume a certain percent that will stay
or go there will be an impact I I want
to acknowledge that there will be an
impact which is why we're desperately
you know trying to put together
thoughtful plans that welcome students
and keep students in Austin ISD um and
so students are not widgets by any means
Uh but we can't operate the way that
we're operating and continue to to have
the ability to support all of our
students everywhere in Austin. It's just
not possible. So something has to give.
Either the state blesses us with a lot
more money than we've ever gotten, um
which we know is not going to happen. We
go back and look at things that were
previously unacceptable to be um
challenged. Um, but I I want y'all to
know that we are very thoughtful in in
the cuts that we take into so with it's
going for central office again or if
it's looking at other resources or real
estate revenue whatever is available we
have explored it and we'll continue to
explore it. Um
so uh yeah there will be an impact um
and that's why these plans have to be
very thoughtful to limit it
>> and I I do I do believe that's true
that's been very very thoughtful. Um
I do not I think our community doesn't
feel like it has been very collaborative
and our community has a lot of ideas.
they have their values. Um and this
feels really apart and separate from
from us um from parents of young kids.
Um so you know we I heard every you know
or many people on the dis um talking
about well this is better than in 2019.
Um in 2019 some of us were nursing
babies. We weren't a part of that
process and so this feels very much like
this is being done to us. So the next
year we were in a pandemic, very
isolated and now this we are in
elementary school where we have
communities, we have support, we have
friends, we have other families that
that mean everything to us and we're in
the busiest time of our lives. So we're
we're working full-time jobs. We're
taking care of small kids. Some of us
have older parents that we're taking
care of, too. So, um, a lot of folks
aren't watching all the board meetings
and then all of a sudden they hear that
they're this wonderful place, um, that
means the world to them is is closing
and it's over. Um, so this is a this is
a big hit. Um, and so seeing like these
numbers where like we're talking about
our buildings and utilization like none
of us that's not our priority at all.
and then having, you know, staff coming
in and saying, "Well, we we we're not
going to listen to you. You know, even
if you come out and you yell and scream,
like we don't really care." Um, like
we're being told that.
And it it you know, we don't there most
of us like, you know, I'm, you know,
I've been around uh I taught in this
district for a long time, so you know,
I've been around and followed it a
little bit. Um but you know people don't
feel respected or that they're getting
um empathy and that they are just
getting getting jerked around and it
doesn't feel good um to be told well
November 20th um like when will we get
the new draft that we're going to vote
on plan to vote on November 20th.
So um so the plan right now is to take
feed we're taking feedback we are
looking at all of it to trust Kaufman's
comment there's conflicting feedback too
uh so you know I we can't incorporate
every aspect because multiple there are
times when there are things that we hear
and receive that are opposite of one
another just I want to be really really
clear that's what happens um we're
taking that feedback we're making
refinements we're adjusting uh the the
20th was that date was that months and
months and months ago. Uh we're going to
be annotating the report so that uh
anytime you know a committee member
wants to say see like hey this is the
part of section that impacts my
community or my family they can see how
the feedback that we received changed
did not change refined improved took
away whatever. Um and it's really really
clear. So we're going to be linking that
um throughout the the entire process.
Um, as far as the uh the draft
deliverable, you know, it's going to be
progressing. So, you should the
community should be able to see this is
something that the administration
supports or should change or is
recommending changing. Um, we haven't um
thought about an interim deliverable
prior to the deliverable that gets
uploaded for information session. The
information session then provides the
time between that and the voting
session. Um, but we will be have we will
have um kind of the annotations and
changes and feedback tracked along the
way. Um and so I can talk to the team
about kind of what we can share um and
at what point along the way that says
okay this is what we heard from the
trustees in the first two weeks of
cards. This is what we can we feel like
we can support and and consider. These
are things that we can at this time. Um
so so that's one of the pieces in
between that we we need to kind of um
provide some some detail on because the
next formal draft um we were
anticipating being um the week of the
information session the week prior the
five days prior to the or I guess a week
and a day from prior to the what was the
date
>> November 6 and so um yeah so that's the
current draft.
>> See that's that's just a very very short
short timeline. Uh I would I would like
to urge the administration to to focus
on the real deadline that is taps school
or schools that need punish call them
punishment plans that TEA imposes on us.
Engage with communities that have those
requirements because we have shown we
the administration does not have the
ability to meaningfully engage and
communicate with everyone affected by
this. So focus there with financial we
have time to collaborate with people. Um
conflating this together
um makes this a process where um an up
or down vote is putting the district at
at great risk. Um and that feels
um that feels heavy-handed to me.
Thank you, Trusty Gonzalez.
>> Yeah, thank you. Um, I have heard a lot
about the long-term financial impact of
fin families leaving the district and I
think that that is a real consideration.
I would be interested to see how the
district is forecasting for what they
project that number to be. And I will
also say that what we're going through
right now is the long-term financial
impact of families leaving this
district. My family went through the
Eastside vertical team. They went to
Zavala, they went to Mets, they went to
Martin, they went to Johnston, and they
went to Allen Junior High. Four out of
those three campuses don't operate in
this district anymore because past
iterations of this body chose to invest
otherwise outside of those communities.
And there are still 15 20,000 students
that live in Austin that do not choose
to go to Austin ISD. And that leaves
$und00 million on the table that we
otherwise could be operating with. Um,
but we chose to invest in other things
and not in that vertical team and not in
those communities. And so I hear the
concerns and the the threat of that, but
we're already living those and I cannot
just sit on my hands and wait for that
to get worse. Um,
in relation to the plan and that
comment, um,
Martin Middle School and Bedc Middle
School seem to be question marks as I
read them in the plan as to what's going
to happen with the future of those
campuses. I will say that given my
personal connection to both of those
communities, my families that I'm
related to that attended and attend
those schools and the people that I
represent that go to those places, I am
unwilling to accept that the future of
those campuses being a question mark
because I there's no other way for me to
read that other than a permanent
disinvestment from that community from
the Martin vertical team. Um, Betachch
also I will say from talking with those
communities since we're talking about
what we've heard um there is a profound
sense of unfairness that campus was a
B-rated school right before Stark 2.0
and before they received communities
from a neighboring middle school and it
feels so unfair that after successfully
operating with many alumni from that
community including myself that they
would just be summarily closed after
three years. Um I am also concerned and
have heard concerns from the Betach
community that they are slated to be
split between four different campuses
literally to the four different
directions to Lively to Mendes to
Covington and to Parles. Um I don't know
what the answer is for that but that's a
concern that I've heard. I have another
um long list of small boundary
adjustments that have been brought to me
that I would like to discuss but I don't
feel that getting into the minutiae in
that way is helpful here. The second to
last thing that I'll bring up is Trusty
Deios and Trusty Foster both talked
about um middle school and uneasiness
around middle school and around special
education. Uh and we had a conversation
about dual language. I don't see um
anything addressing in this plan and
maybe it's outside of it. the the
students that are at the intersection of
those two populations, special education
and bilingual. The state just approved
EPS to offer a certification beginning
in 2027 or 2028. I think it would be
smart for us to preempt that requirement
coming um and for it to be built into
this plan in some way. Uh because that
as we have heard from the audit
committee, the way that our dual
language and services provided to
emerging bilingual students are just
they're not functioning. they're we're
continually failing to meet the needs of
those students. Um
the last Yeah, never mind. I'm going to
stop there. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Additional questions.
>> Just a a point of clarification about um
central office and cuts at central
office because that was also a very
pointed comment or two that was made. Um
and my understanding is that what we've
cut so far from central office is 20
million and that we've cut from outside
contracting is an an additional 14
million and many of the outside
contracted services are now provided
inhouse and so you know one of the
wonderful things about this das is that
there's kind of a diversity of
perspectives very heartfelt um but I I
want to make sure that we
some clarity on just some pieces of the
puzzle because I have an alternative
concern which I've voiced from the disin
in past meetings which is that as we cut
central office and we had to we had 83
3,000 students what 20 years ago we've
we dropped to 72. So, we had expanded
central office and now we absolutely
kind of had to make the cuts to central
office, but the cuts were substantial
and I have concerns about the capacity
of central office to serve the local
campuses and to have our executive
directors on campuses doing the work
they need to do as we've cut positions,
purposefully not filled vacancies, and
then also taken on additional
work because of the outside contracting
not done. So I guess I'd like some
clarity. That's kind of my read on the
situation, but I might be slightly
inaccurate or wildly inaccurate. So what
have we done with central office? Has
there been cuts?
>> So um and
so when I said $10 million, that was
just this last July cut. Um the that was
the June um 26th through uh August 1st.
Um but you are right. There were
previous um reorganizations that
occurred uh in the 25 and 24 fiscal
year. Um I'm not sure if it's quite $20
million, but I can I can get the number.
Uh so that that last 10 million was a
concerted effort to kind of restructure
and do a
um almost kind of a blank slate built
from the ground up uh based on the
number of students who were serving at
that time. Uh every effort prior to that
was uh making adjustments around the
edges, right? But those did add up to
staff. Uh so I don't know it was quite
$20 million, but it was certainly more
than 10. Um I maybe guess six 1617
million in that range. Um we did bring
in house uh other um uh staff. You know
we there were lots of divisions that
that did grow uh special education being
one of them uh where previously we
didn't have staff and we had to make
adjustments not only to address the
issues that we had um and the work
around the TA agreed order um but just
you know the fact that we would we
didn't have the staff in place to meet
our student needs. Um, so there's been a
combination of those things. Uh, Trusty
Foster, um, you know, I I want you to
know like we are very thoughtful.
Anytime we approve a position, we freeze
positions. You've seen me do that now
twice. Um, every position that we
release, um, executive director above
comes to me for approval. Um, we're
we're very very thoughtful. We we we do
not want to waste resources. Um, but
these people here as well as many in the
building like they're here to support
the schools and they do support the
schools. Many people are are at the
schools all the time. Um, and so yeah,
it's a combination of those things.
Trusty Foster.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, Trusty Hunter.
>> I apologize for expending more time and
I've already expressed my frustration,
but Mr. Superintendent, when I stay up
till 1:00 in the morning sending
questions in, I expect them to show up
in the backup. And I read my backup. I
did not look again until just now and
saw that my questions were not in the
backup. I represent the largest district
in this city, 28 schools. They need to
know that I am thinking about them and
not just for performance sake. They need
to know that I am thinking and
considering and bringing back the
feedback. I had a meeting last Tuesday.
Those questions were based on that
meeting. Um, so now I'm going to read
them into the record and and move our
clock up, but they're in the backup. If
the administration doesn't have an
answer, my expectation is that the
question is placed in there and the
administration says we don't have an
answer, but the question needs to be in
there. Um, the first question is um was
about the uh
what Dr. Kaufman asked about. Um, and I
didn't see it. If I And if it's in there
and it's just somewhere I can't find it,
please let me know. I apologize. Um but
it was four um 6.1 and it was uh it says
uh please provide the board with an
estimated cost savings summary expected
from school closures direct operational
savings staffing reduction in
campusbased administrative positions
principles APS office staff
consolidation of instructional staff if
enrollment is absorbed at other campuses
facilities utilities electricity water
HVAC custodial maintenance and repairs
deferred maintenance avoidance
transportation potential increase or
decrease depending depending on new
student assignment but may stabilize
long term. Two, one-time cost offsets
the savings, relocation of students and
staff, moving expenses, furniture,
technology and classroom materials.
People want to know the answer to that
and we need to have an answer for them.
The second was about um it says, "Our
community has asked for clarity on what
every student at every campus can expect
academically, the non-negotiable basics
that will be in place across all schools
while still allowing campuses
flexibility to meet the unique needs of
their students. Please provide this
update on the Please provide an update
on these plans. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Uh trust
>> and I apologize. Just one one clarifying
question and and I do mean this kind of
genuinely. I'm I'm trying to spread out
um I guess the areas we're addressing,
but to really put it bluntly for for the
public. Um Mr. Superintendent, why do
you think this is the right plan to
propose? I know we're still going to
modify things. We're going to adjust and
stuff. Um you know, you're coming to us
with this plan. Like why do you think
this is the way to go?
So, um
I believe that Austin ISD for
generations has never um developed a
comprehensive plan and actually executed
it to inform generational change. Um I
look at the you know amalgam
amalgamation and boundary changes over
the 144 years and I can't even tell you
how some of them came to be. I go back
to early 70s and see how the high
schools how we had students north of MLK
going to Crockett and then you know like
um different you know areas that just
kind of stayed and then new schools got
cut in and and so I think about the fact
that we have a genuine opportunity to
align feeder patterns. So that's that's
one thing. So to me, a plan that
incorporates that is is going to be a
gamecher when you think about 20 years
from now. Like why do certain schools in
West Austin have that alignment and and
certain schools in East Austin don't? We
would never ever take that on ever
unless it was something part of a larger
effort. We know how painful these
boundary changes are and I don't think
that we would ever take that on. I just
that's my honest opinion. Uh I think too
the taps are very harmful
um as far as uh implementation given the
scale that we have to to do. Um we have
to implement 24 of them uh in a school
district with 116 schools. Um and so
that is a huge lift. Uh we're limited in
the options that we have and what I've
heard from our community is we want to
maintain the lo the we we a don't want
charter partners if we can avoid it. We
would like to do that. Uh two, uh we
want um to retain uh geographically a
footprint wherever we can. We heard that
in Doby burnin web is why we made the
adjustments that we did at the time. And
if we don't um incorporate the tap work
in this larger effort, then
opportunities will be lost. Um so we did
notate the taps here, but I mean the
wind solution uh for the tap like would
not exist in the same way. Sanchez it
would look different and many others
would look different as well. So I I
want to be really clear like that is an
opportunity that I think we have because
we're doing it all together. I think
three um program stability. Um we did
spend a lot of time talking about um
wall-to-wall programs because a they've
been around. We know that they're um
great programs. We also know that what
we've seen in the last several years is
a decline in the number of students who
the program was meant to serve
initially. Well, what does it look like
two years from now, three years from
now, are we going to support a wall to
wall to language program if it's 8%
emerging bilingual students or five, you
know, where does that line end up being?
And so for us, you know, one of the
things that I think this plan affords us
the opportunity to stabilize the
programs in a place that gives access to
students who the program was originally
intended for. Um now we have to work
through the details and make sure that
access is protected but that's one of
the things that wouldn't ex that if we
did it in isolation we wouldn't have a
home like a home program to go to um
because we're doing it all together that
now is can be considered. I think the
other thing I would say is um when you
think about u overall reductions uh in
cost consolidations just to be blunt
about what it we're talking about um I
I've gone through this process in 2019
I've looked at other processes around
the state and what I've heard loud and
clear is do not um
uh
um overburden one community over
another. um, East Austin, North Austin,
West Austin, you just, you know, don't
do that. Um, and I I agree with that.
Uh, I I agree with that, especially when
it impacts historically serve students
to, you know, adversely to a greater
extent. So,
if we didn't have these programmatic
moves and we weren't addressing the taps
in this way, you would see, if the $30
million mark was the goal, more
consolidations in the Eastern Crescent.
Because the programmatic moves occurred
in the way that they do, they don't
occur in that way. Um and I would say
lastly, uh transfer policies is
something that uh you know we've been
talking about doing for quite some time.
Uh right now there many of them are most
of them are managed locally and that's
created some imbalances within our
system. Uh and and we are breaking some
that have been in place for a very long
time. Um but I don't know that you can
introduce that without um kind of having
the reset as a whole. um which is
something that I I've heard over the
last three years with this board and
with you know in the LRP and and other
so to me it's really uh the
multi-layering that created new
opportunities that we wouldn't have
otherwise found if they weren't done all
together um you know I think if you did
consolidations it would look different
if you did taps alone it would look
different if you did program moves it
would look different so that's why all
those have to get done which is why a
plan that considers all of them is is
one that I think works Not saying this
is the final version. I think it's
draft. There's lots of refinement to it.
But that's why I would say that this
approach is the approach. Um I I also
want to regarding timeline.
I have been here when changes are made
to campuses uh in the spring semester
when sixth grade got ripped out of
Mendes and Martin that occurred in
April. We did not recover as a school
system. We were scrambling to move
instruments. We were scrambling to move
uh staff. The schools barely recovered
by winter of the of the next year and I
would argue some of them did never
recovered. That happened in the spring
semester. Our families didn't have time
to plan. Our stu we we did not have time
to to actually support our staff. Um
same thing is true when international
got ripped out of uh East Side Early
College High School, right? They had
planned to build that school with East
Side Early College High School and then
they moved to Northeast Early College
High School at the same time, spring
2022.
Um, and so I I'm really wanting to if
we're going to make a change, it needs
to be done with enough time for our
families and staff to plan for us to put
the systems in place to support them.
Which is why if we don't hit November,
that's that is the board's direction,
but you're the disruption that'll be
caused in a spring semester means that
you're going to wait essentially a whole
year, right? and and that means that
some of the things that we're trying to
address would just be one year delayed,
which means the budget constraints would
be exacerbated by one year. So that that
is really what I'm wanting to avoid. Um
and the and I think that also kind of
ties into just our enrollment system.
You know, all these changes are going to
have to have modifications to our
enrollment system. As one of the
trustees over here said, it has to be
tight. Um you know, that enrollment
process starts in November. So we're
already going to be up against the
timeline right when applicationbased
programs start in January and February.
I mean that that is already going for
next year. Um so so it is a very it's a
it's a complex system. I the the the
document deliverable is very complex and
um and layered because it is just a a
unique system. So that's what I that's
what I would say. I don't know if that
was helpful but
>> thank you.
>> Thank you. Okay. I have a few questions
and I'll try to make them quick and I
don't need answers to all of them here,
but I want to share them and I I will
also send some in writing. Um I would
love for each of our campuses that has
had um any kind of academically
unacceptable rating in its proposed
form. I would love for our data
department to look at statewide data for
other districts. look at emergent
bilingual status, economic um
disadvantaged status, mobility, all you
the percentage of special education
students. We know that where there are
charters nearby that have 16,000
students zone that are educating 16,000
students zone to Austini ISD, we have a
much higher percentage of students who
need special education services because
they are disproportionately generally
not at the charter. I would love to look
at all of our data and look at how many
campuses statewide with similar
demographic populations are successful
under this A3F accountability system.
Are we building schools that
statistically when we look across our
state have a reasonable likelihood of
being successful? We are playing a very
high stakes game and I think that's just
a basic understanding we need to have
about the populations that we're pulling
together as we also think about this.
Um, second is when we're talking about
academics, I appreciate the slide that
shows our systems are responding all of
this. That slide was really completely
about a through accountability system
star and things related to that on our
scorecard. And I want to be sure when
our families
um are worried about going to a lower
lower rated school, they're not worried
about that letter grade. They're worried
about all the other things that we're
not doing for students at that campus
because we are so focused on that letter
grade. They are worried about
opportunities people have to have be
collaborative learn critical thinking.
Um things we know great things are
happening in every single one of our
schools and we know we are not offering
a a fair spectrum, an equitable
spectrum. And when we talk about
academics, I hope we will lean into the
great things we do. Um, we do so much
more than teach kids to read and do math
and and earn a rating for their campus.
Um, we want to teach our kids to be
thinkers and dreamers and doers. We want
them to be curious and exciting. Our
schools are doing that. We need to talk
about that and we need to lean into with
our academic plan. What will that look
like where we're not doing that yet? I
just want to echo that. Um and and when
I look at the timeline that has been put
into the very large document um and
thank you for this is very thoroughly
documented in many ways and I appreciate
all the work that's gone into trying you
know and working to get as much
information as possible out to our
community. But when we look at the
timeline for that um and planning will
happen in summer that means there won't
be that rich academic opportunity at
that campus in the fall. um that means
that we're inviting people to go to a
campus to transfer from a higher rated
campus to a lower rated campus where
we're telling them we'll get around to
that later and that's a big ask for
families and it's really not fair to our
students who are already in schools that
are not yet getting what they need. um
with the financial savings um would
really I echo my colleagues questions
about we need more detail about what
this is where the savings come from um
campus by campus including the
transition plans the transportation the
expanded special education services to
make those transitions um not only legal
but meaningful and we need to look at it
really thoroughly
um we also need to understand both
realistically what can we learn from
enrollment loss and other communities
that have gone through a big disruptive
closure process and we know that there
is enrollment loss to charters up and
down the economic spectrum. There's
enrollment loss to charters to privates
to people who move. We need to have a
realistic understanding. And that is why
we need to do this as thoughtfully and
well as we possibly can because every
encounter, every engagement, every time
we change a boundary that we zone
someone somewhere else, we're giving
them an off-ramp. And we need to be sure
that we're inviting them to stay on. And
we also need to be leaning into
recruitment. And I know we don't have
money, but we don't have enough money
not to be recruiting.
The charters are
We don't have enough money not to be
inviting families back while we are
doing a process that is really intended
to give them a good reason to come back.
Now is the time for that. Now is the
moment for that. Um
I also want to just speak to the
importance as we're working to build
equity into our system and to better
serve students we aren't to continue
serving the students we are. we are a
rare thing that we are an urban district
that continues to serve our full
economic spectrum. Um that is not just
about students that's about our whole
city and being a city where people
choose public schools shapes us deeply
and is well worth fighting for. And I
don't think that's that means, you know,
bending to privilege or any of the
worries, but just making sure that we're
taking care of what's working while we
fix what's not. taking care of who it's
working for while we fix what's not and
making sure that we're learning from
what's working and adapting it um to
every community in our city. And um you
know, people are about to have more
choices with vouchers. People are about
to have a lot. And again, that comes
down to listening, collaborating, and
being as thoughtful as we can about the
changes we are making, which are very,
very hard. Um,
looking at and and I know, you know, we
have the most recent data I have that
this year's numbers are probably
different. We take all of our funding,
it's about 13,800
per student. We lose 72 students, we
lose a million dollars. We lose just
under a thousand students, we eat up all
that $13 million. And I think that's
really important to understand that we
have to hang on to everyone we can and
we need to invite new people in. I don't
think that means we don't have to go
through closures. I don't think that
means we don't have to go through this
really painful process. I just mean we
need to be aware and thoughtful and
deliberate and and relational
um and human about it. Um
with that I I just want to talk
generally um transfers
uh I expect that we will have a final
transfer policy from our committee uh in
collabor collaboration with our
administration. I hope um with input
from our community to vote on when we
vote on on the closures and the
consolidations. I hope that all happens
on the same meeting. I I think it's a
big ask to not have that when when we're
saying and we don't really know what
your policy is going to be. I think we
need the same about transportation. If
we're talking about our legacy schools
that that are proposed to become
unzoned, you know, some of the things
that our community is telling us are
disruptive. I I would like to have a
transportation policy updated at the
same time to consider what we're
proposing. um
transfers transfers into schools that
are closing. Um I am hearing a lot of
pain from the Breerwoods community
specifically
which is a very high transfer community
that if they close and transfers cannot
go with them
that that is shattering their community,
you know, kind of twice over and in a
really deep way for the kids who get
scattered. Um, and I I want to be really
thoughtful about thinking about what we
can do about that and being really aware
um about that. Siblings, I think the
same. I think anyone who says a sibling
won't be able to attend a school that an
older sibling is at um has never had two
kids going in two different directions.
That is we will lose families. We will
absolutely lose families.
>> Um my brother lives in a city where it's
all lottery. your children don't have a
guarantee to go to the same school. He
lived next door to a public school. He
chose private because he couldn't get
that promise and it wasn't going to work
with work and and travel and all of
that. Um, and I want to be really really
thoughtful about that too. Um, I think
when we talked about minimizing
disruption, those were some of the kinds
of things I had in mind when I talked
about minimize disruption. And I also
want to talk about um I am hearing in my
district um and from some other people a
lot of things about moving one group of
students out to make room to move
another group of students in when it
could be done with a whole lot less
disruption. The the utilization might be
a little less elegant and a little less
close, but it would be so much better
for people. And I really want to be sure
we're listening to our community. I know
um you have already reacted to some of
that and listened to that, but I am
hearing that over and over and over and
over. And if we don't have to disrupt
people and our 85% is more like an 81, I
would so much rather have some orange on
the map um and a a process on paper that
is a little less perfect but is much
better for our people. Um I think that
is immensely immensely important. Um,
I also want to lean into talking about
recruitment, talking about dual language
recruitment, the people who built the
programs at Becker, at Rididge, at our
other dual language programs 20 plus
years ago. Families from those
communities who believed in dual
language, who fought for for dual
language in the city went and recruited
families, Spanish-sp speakaking families
to bring their kids to those schools.
They knocked on doors. It was an immense
amount of work. I would like to have
that baked into our the funding. If
we're moving into the neighborhoods, how
are we going to invite those families?
What does that look like? That has a
cost. It also needs to be a plan. Um
I do have a school in my district that
is splitting to three high schools. That
seems unjust. If that was what we were
trying to get away from, I'd like to
have that conversation. And um I
have some campus specific questions that
I will put in um the tracker in the
interest of time because I know we have
blown way past what we allotted and I
know there can be a consequence to us
for that and I want to move on with the
rest of the meeting. So, thank you for
all of that. Anything else before we
move on? Okay. Thank you all very much.
Let me unberry script. Um and thank you
for all of that. Um
okay we will
now move on to uh 6.1 student
achievement our scorecard goal scorecard
goal two third grade numeracy.
Um thank you. Oh and before we begin our
presentation we need to confirm that our
monitoring report is complete. The
following questions help us determine if
the monitoring report is effective or
not. Does it clearly show the specific
goal being monitored? Does it moni and
the interim goal? Does it show data for
their three previous reporting periods,
preferably on a line graph? Does the
monitoring report clearly show the
current reporting period? Does the
report clearly show the target reporting
periods, annual and deadline targets?
Does it clearly show the
superintendent's current view of system
performance relative to the goal? Does
the monitoring report clearly show
supporting documentation
uh for the superintendent's
understanding of performance? And if it
if the system is not at meeting the
target
uh and the superintendent's
understanding implements uh indicates
implement implementation is not on
track. Does the report clearly describe
systemic root causes, strategic
responses, and any needed next steps?
Does anyone have evidence that the
elements of an effective report are not
present before we move on? All right.
Thank you very much and thank you all
for being with us.
>> Thank you, President Boswell.
>> Thank you, Dr. Maxwell, for being back.
>> Uh the team and I will present on the
board monitoring report. I have joining
me Jennifer Pace, assistant
superintendent of elementary schools,
Dr. Maryanne Maxwell, assistant
superintendent of academics, and
Jennifer Jones, director of elementary
STEM. Uh so this is uh goal two third
grade numer uh numeracy. Uh the goal
states the percent of third grade
students earning meets grade level or
above on the star mathematics assessment
in English or Spanish will increase from
39% in June 2024 to 55% by June of 2029.
The goal progress measure that was
selected by the trustees uh states um
the percent of second grade students
scoring in the recommended for
intervention level on the NWEA MAP
mathematics achievement score
proficiency indicator which is below
30th percentile in English and Spanish
will decrease from 37% in June 2024 to
29% by June 2029. Uh this does align
with our um district initiative uh
foundation first and uh the evaluation
of progress uh determined by me uh
states that there's evidence that the
district is on track to meet the third
grade numeracy goal. Uh 42% of third
grade students earn meets grade level or
above on the star mathematics assessment
an increase from 39% in 2023 24 data
meets the current year targets and
suggest the district inputs and work
around improving numeracy is positively
impacting student outcomes. Next steps
include continuing to focus on high
quality materials and instruction,
increasing professional learning for
staff, and expanding coaching
opportunities around observation and
feedback. Uh we do expect to see
continued growth uh in math outcomes. Um
and one of the things I I think is worth
pointing out is uh this um summit of
data uh um does uh correlate to the goal
progress measure that we use throughout
the year. Uh it's one of the things
we're always trekking for you know did
the goal progress measure that was
selected um actually uh you know uh
indicate that we were going to be on
track or exceed and in this case uh they
were correlated. Uh so with that I'll
hand it over to Dr. Maxwell um to take
us through the remainder of the report.
Thank you, Superintendent Zuura. Um, I'm
excited to bring this tonight with uh
our my colleagues um and talk about some
of the the math work that has been done
uh and some of the early outcomes that
we're seeing. And um let's talk about
math for a while. We're going to let
Miss Jones loose so she can talk all she
wants about math and and and add some
minutes um and we'll give some examples
from campuses and um talk through some
things that we've seen. Uh so uh we're
excited here that the district really
has uh improved the number of students
scoring at the ME's grade level or above
on the STAR math assessment and and and
in fact exceeding our target for 24 um
25. We really do feel that this is early
evidence um as we've seen really in a
few different areas that some of the
strategies that we're using are starting
to work that uh really um leaning into
our numerousy framework and starting to
build the systems around that that would
create that kind of success for our
kids. Um we're we're beginning to see
the fruits of that that labor really
districtwide. Um and so as Mr. Siga
mentioned, these are some of the next
steps targeted professional learning for
teachers and instructional leaders on
math. you know how much we did this for
literacy last year. We're very excited
that we've already started this with
math this year with teachers and with
instructional leaders. Um and really
maintain that focus on district-wide
implementation of high quality
instructional math uh math materials. Um
I know we talk about instructional
materials a lot um and and it kind of
sounds like well let's just hand
everybody the materials and math will
happen magically. Um, and there's so
much more that goes into it than that.
Uh, professional learning is really a
key piece of that and and being in
classrooms and seeing what's happening
and knowing how we can pivot so that we
can support our campuses with the
implementation.
Um, but the instructional materials
themselves um matter very much. Um,
we've talked a little bit before about
math not being as quite the same at the
same comfort level for many of all many
of us, including all of our teaching and
instructional leadership staff. Um, and
the materials are a huge help with that
when you know they're high quality
materials. I'm going to give some really
specific examples of this. You you all
and we all learned math kind of usually
likely a very different way than the way
most of our students are learning math
right now. We learned a lot of
procedural math. Um, so we were we put
numbers together and we had steps for
those numbers and there were steps that
you followed and there was a right
answer at the end of it and that's how
we learned math and we memorized that
process those those procedures for math.
Um, and we kind of think of it a lot
that way. And when we're talking about
rigor in the math classroom now we're
talking about yes procedural matters and
really fluent procedure like procedural
math is important but we're also asking
our students to learn conceptual math
which is much more difficult. It's not
um and it's higher level thinking. It is
that critical thinking in math. It is
flexible thinking in math and it's
learning how to you uh make
representations of numbers in different
ways not just the written number itself
and so you learn how to actually
complete math and do math in in and
understand all of the concepts behind
it. Um and then we're also asking for
application of the math as well. That's
where you see a lot of the real world
examples where kids can make connections
to not just completing the algorithm,
but applying that in a real world
situation that actually means something.
Um, and it makes sense to them and they
can begin to see how math really applies
to the real world. The reason I'm
talking about these things together with
instructional materials is that there
are a lot more math materials out there
that do not have these three things that
would make it rigorous math instruction.
um more so in in in my opinion and
probably your opinion as well, Miss
Jones. Um that uh more so in math than
in in literacy because there's just been
more literacy out there. There's been
more research. There's been more um
discussion around how to teach literacy
and best practices. And so lots of math
resources and math things exist out
there that just don't have that. when we
know our teachers are just starting with
high quality instructional materials, we
can guarantee those three three things
exist in those materials. So that's it's
the perfect starting place. Now teachers
make that come alive. Teachers know
their kids. Teachers make adjustments to
these materials. Um teachers make the
the magic happen in the classroom to
engage students and make sure that math
is actually being learned and not just
being taught. Right? Those those are two
different things. Um and so that's why
uh the other things are really focused
on this this expanded coaching model of
our instruction leaders and expanded
coaching model of our teachers so that
we can really be in the classrooms and
be in implementation with them and
support that actual delivery. Um kind of
an example I would say of using
instructional materials and I'll I'll
pull these from recent walks in
classroom. Um, in a in a we all know if
you write the number five and you add
the number three to it, it equals eight.
And we're probably all picturing that
algorithm in our mind right now. The
written number five, the written number
three, the equal plus sign, the equal
sign, the addition sign, the equal sign,
and then the number eight. Um, for a
kindergartener, the conceptual piece of
that is to know that when you have five
units or five unifix cubes, though I'm
talking about manipulatives here, and
then you have three and you pull them
together, when you count them all
together, that's eight. That's just the
simple conceptual understanding behind
that. Um and so compare pairing that um
with the actual teaching of the numbers
is really important as early as our kids
start coming to us. Um what we would see
in a fifth grade classroom when you are
multiplying decimals
you um this is an example I'm pulling
from a fifth grade classroom um from
earlier this week actually. you're multi
multiplying decimals actually have 100
cubes in front of them because they're
multiplying 2/10 by 3/10. And you can
see the tiny piece of the cube actually
equals 6 hundreds and how that
represents the 6 hundreds is that's how
you come up with that answer. That's
what it actually looks like within 100.
And so they begin to see that that is
just six small pieces out of 100. And so
that's the conceptual understanding of
what it looks like for comps when you
start getting into multiplying fractions
which is a very difficult difficult
thing to teach in fifth grade or
multiplying decimals. I mean once you
get into decimals it get gets pretty
tough. Um today I was in Dolby and so
incredible lessons happening at Doby. It
was it was a wonderful uh opportunity to
walk through some classrooms. In an
eighth grade classroom the students were
um just doing the the the math. They had
been instruction. They were in um
groups. They were working through math
problems together because they were
using stem scopes materials. They worked
through a conceptual problem first. It
didn't have numbers. It just had
representations of numbers and they had
to solve the problem that way. They had
a few more problems that were actually
real world scenarios. So they had to
solve the problems that way as well and
apply it to real world. And so we can
when we have that kind of vertical
alignment using high quality
instructional materials, we can start to
ensure that our students are actually
really learning math and they have this
un unleashed potential um for math and
to be mathematicians that um many of us
didn't get to experience because so many
of us feel like we're stronger in lead
in reading than we are in math. Um and
this is changing that that experience
for them. So, I just wanted to say that
um as far as instructional materials, it
just sounds like we're handing books to
people or we're saying, you know, here
follow these the these steps or do these
things, but it's much more in depth than
that. There's a real purpose behind high
quality instructional materials and why
we have adopted the materials in the
district that we have and why it's
important that we're we're spending so
much time on that. Um, okay. So, uh,
getting to the data itself for third
grade numeracy. Our goal is third grade
star math assessment. Um, uh, it
definitely aligns with our early, uh,
learning initiative because we've spent
so much time on K2. Obviously, this all
this past year was on K2. Um, these are
third grade results from last year. We
did not focus on third through fifth
grade um, at the elementary level. that
was intentional um so that we could
build that strong foundation. But we
already did begin to see um because
school systems work together um we
already did begin to see some
improvement in those math scores. So
previously as you can see on the left
hand side um that has been the variable
results that we have seen in math over
the past several years. Um this is the
percentage of students that are scoring
at meets grade level or above. Um, and
we've seen that too as we've talked
about our goal progress measures. Uh,
Superintendent Sigoda mentioned a
correlation between them. When you're
looking at the goal progress measure and
we're talking about second grade map
achievement percentiles, we see the same
thing. There are years where it goes up,
there are years where it goes down.
There are some populations where it
works better than others and we then
some populations where we're seeing um
some um decreases and increases. So,
it's a lot of variability. So we see
that also with our um our star
assessment as well. Um but we have
overall seen that correlation these um
this year that as we've seen a decrease
in the number of students a percentage
of students who are qualifying for
interventions based on our math
screener. We um have seen an increase
here uh in the percentage of students
who are scoring at meetats grade level
or above. So um again here we've we've
started to see that correlation and so
it gives us a little more confidence
that we are using a goal progress
measure that is um correlated to the
actual goal itself. Um of course what we
want in future years when you look at
that yearly target is not the up and
down anymore but we just steady
improvement in percentage over time. We
were at uh 39% of students last year.
Our goal was 40% this year. uh we
actually exceeded that goal by uh 2% and
scored 42% at meets grade level um and
above. It was actually a little more
than we expected um at the we thought we
would see a little slower improvement
with math since we did focus on
literacy, but I think just some of the
overall strategies that we've done just
to provide campuses with um and what we
have been able to do in in the math area
um has have shown some early results.
and then I'll hand it over to our
elementary STEM director, Miss Jennifer
Jones, to talk about a little more
analysis of the data and some root
causes.
>> Thank you so much. I usually don't get
to talk about this part, so it's
actually really exciting. Usually,
Maxwell is all of our numbers. Um, so if
you are able to see the data table
that's up here, I'm sure it's in front
of you because I know it looks really
small otherwise. Um, this is actually
showing historical meets grade level or
above on third grade math star. And then
that orange column in the middle is
going to be our current. So that's what
we were at for this year. And then on
the um right hand side, you're going to
see the yearly targets that we've set as
our goal um across our scorecard um and
what we're hoping to see across all of
our student groups that are represented
down below that. Um so some of the big
kind of takeaways, just high level
takeaways. So um Dr. Dr. Maxwell already
mentioned it, but we did actually exceed
the goal for the 2425 school year. Um,
not by a ton, but at least by more than
we even thought, you know, we were going
to get to, which is actually really
great to see. Um, we all know that we
haven't poured as much into math across
our district like we would um, want to
be doing this year. We have already
started doing and then hope to continue
that path forward. But there are
practices that are a part of both
literacy and math in any good
instruction whether that be science,
social studies, any content area that
are transferable. And so it really
already has started to have a small
impact and we hope that that will
continue to grow over time. Um some of
the trends that are here that you see.
So if you look at all students, which is
that top row, you'll see that we had 42%
of students um scoring at the meets
grade level or above, which is great.
And if you look um below that, you'll
see that actually across our student
groups um we had growth. And the only
place that we fell short of um meeting
our actual goal was on our white student
group. Um they fell short of our goal
that we had set for them by 1%. Um but
they did stay consistent with the
previous year. So we didn't decline in
our amount of meats um for our white
student group, which is another thing to
take note of. So when you look at the
orange column, if you look at the left
hand side of that column, you can make a
comparison between last year and well
two years ago and last year. And then if
you go to the right, then you can
actually see how far above the goals we
set are. So just two different ways of
looking at that data. Um, one of the
things to point out of that is if you're
comparing back to the 2324 school year,
um, we do have our groups all grew by at
least 3% or more again, except for our
white student group. So, there's also
consistent growth happening. Um, but it
wasn't like, you know, some population
saw extreme growth and then we had a
major gap from others. So, that is
interesting to see because sometimes
that's not always what we see. So, we
really are seeing improvement across all
of our student groups. Um, we just have
a lot further to go to close gaps for
many of our student groups. Um, another
thing to keep in mind is that the
greatest gains that we saw um were with
our Asian population, we had an increase
of 5%. And then in our African-American
and Hispanic populations, each were 4%
and our special education students was
4%. And that was actually higher than
the other groups which saw 3% again
except for our white student group. Um
it's nice when we see our marginalized
groups have more growth than our other
students. But again, not to be fooled
because we also have a lot further to go
to close the gaps for those students. Um
basically all of this to say that math
is still a major need in our district.
Um it it is it is right here on paper,
right? Another thing for you to know is
there's a gap between our literacy
performance for third graders, which
you'll hear about next month, and our
math. Um, and so we have a duty to our
students to not only close that gap
between subject areas, but also to
actually make sure that we're pouring
into our student groups and start to
really um disproportionately in a good
way impact that growth so that we can
start to close the achievement gaps for
our students. Um last thing that I'll
say about the data here is that when we
really look across um the student
populations knowing that if we compare
back to like that 2021 and we kind of
follow there's some inconsistencies in
the data right we all know the pandemic
happened we know that certain year
students didn't take star so you only
have certain students represented in
that data um and then you also had a
change of the assessment and the types
of items so you've really only had a
couple of years of um comparable data
when take all of that into account. But
one thing to note is that um there's
definitely a clear area with our
students um of the gap being there
between like our white students, which
would be a large group of our students
and our Hispanic and African-American
students. And um you've you've probably
seen us talk about this. it. We talk
about it in literacy, we talk about it
in math, we talk about the goals, we
talk about the GPMs and we see similar
data that we have major gaps for some of
our most marginalized students. Um so in
comparison of those with um our Asian,
our white, and our two or more race
groups actually having
over 60% scoring at meets grade level,
which is over half of that student
population. Again, meets means at grade
level according to the state, right?
they're at grade level or above. Um, you
know, our African-American students, for
example, we only have 17% of our
African-American students that are
scoring at grade level or above if
that's how we think about meats. And
that's not okay. Um, so it's our duty
again with things that we're trying to
do that we have to show that we're
closing the gaps for our students. We
owe it to them and they deserve to have
a future where they can apply
mathematics, they can see themselves as
mathematicians, they can go into STEM
fields, anything is you know possible
there. So that is our duty to do. Um the
next part of that and I kind of talked
about a couple of these out of order but
the root cause analysis of this data and
what we're seeing. Um, we do see slow
improvement like we said based on some
strategies that we've put into place,
but we really haven't poured as heavily
into math until this school year. So,
it'll be interesting to see if we see a
bigger jump um this school year knowing
that there's been a lot of focus poured
into our instructional leaders with um
math professional learning. um we're
getting in a lot more math classrooms
and really seeing what's happening and
also partnering really closely with our
highest need schools to try to pour into
them and their um teachers and their
leaders to to really try to see what we
can do to impact um what's happening in
math there. And so the shifts have been
positive, but we can't necessarily say
that um everything that we've done has
has determined that shift, right?
because we haven't put as many resources
into math um in the past. The other
thing to keep in mind is that those gaps
are there. You you know, I would talk
about this all day long if I could. Um
so, we really have to focus resources
and support. And that example I gave of
us really trying to partner with our top
campuses and our school improvement
campuses to do things a little bit
differently and offer more support and
show that we're doing that is really
intentional so that we can show that at
the district level we have a duty to
serve all of our campuses, but also to
show that we're really trying to impact
where our marginalized
students um are sitting in the
classrooms and are part of that
instruction. Um, I'm just going to
remind everybody that mathematics
performance is actually a predictor of
future success, actually more so than
literacy. So, I'm just going to remind
us that when we talk about this goal and
also the GPM that's associated with it,
um when we look at that data, this is
why this is so meaningful because every
single child that is sitting in our
buildings that is potentially on their
way to our buildings um that haven't
even been born yet has um is deserves
the right to be able to um have a future
where those possibilities are endless.
They can go into any field they want.
They can be confident. they can, you
know, know how to manage their money.
They can know how to look at different
documents and and have a function and
know that somewhere back in there
actually math helped them to be able to
approach those problems. So, um that is
our charge and that is what we hope to
do. And with that, I will turn it over
to Jennifer Face.
Thank you. Good evening, trustees. Uh, I
have the pleasure tonight to highlight
some of our band one and two campuses
that performed above the district
average um andor showed significant
growth.
>> Excuse me.
>> Bless you. Thank you.
>> The success isn't accidental. The
campuses have put structures in place to
address the challenges and this includes
consistent use of district adopted
materials making datadriven decisions
um for instruction and intervention and
PLC's focused on instruction and
outcomes. So I'd first like to talk
about Galindo Elementary. It's a band
one campus and they made remarkable
gains in math from 30% at meets or above
in 2024 to 59% at meets or above in
2025. Well above the district average of
42%.
Galino serves a diverse student
population. Uh 86% Hispanic, 6% white,
90% of their students are economically
disadvantaged, and nearly 40% of their
students are receiving special education
services.
And Galindo really improved math
instruction through a monthly vertical
team meeting and focused on inroving the
math block at all grade levels. They
also worked hard on weekly PLC's with a
focus on student engagement in tier one
instruction.
And the key drivers to success for them
again were fidelity to high quality
instructional materials and tight
collaboration between general education
teachers and special education teachers.
Blackshere Elementary, a band 2 campus,
also serves a diverse population. 22%
African-American, 10% two or more races,
40% Hispanic, 26% white, and 52% of
their students are economically
disadvantaged,
22% are receiving special education
services. Their third grade math scores
rose from 24% at meets or above to 49 in
2024 and to 49% at meets or above in
2025 again um exceeding the district
average of 42%.
And as Dr. Maxwell mentioned earlier
this evening, teachers have the greatest
impact. This improvement was due in
large part to a dedicated third grade
math teacher who was really only in her
second year of teaching math, but she
really built positive relationships and
created a safe space and an environment
where students can make mistakes and
learn from them. Um, it's just really
fun to be in that classroom. Blackshere
maintains an intentional focus on STEM
scopes implementation for core
instruction and also um on imagine
learning for their online individualized
um learning work. And they work in a
small groupoup station rotation format
and even create competitions um just to
increase student engagement.
Campbell Elementary, a band two campus,
has shown steady and consistent growth.
In fact, in 2023, 24% of their students
were at meets or above. That increased
to 33% in 2024 and to 45%
in 2025, above our district average. And
Campbell also serves a diverse student
population. 41% African-American, 6% two
or more races, 27% Hispanic, 19% white,
and 74% of their students are
economically disadvantaged, and 22% are
receiving special education services.
And their success stems from
instructional consistency and staffing
consistency. They've been able to
maintain their teachers and have
consistent grade level teams across
multiple years and um provide strong
coaching cycles that ensure lesson
internalization
and um alignment of high quality
instructional materials.
They also have daily intervention and
enrichment blocks that are focused
really to address both struggling
students and advanced learners. um
intentionally pushing all students
forward.
And while we did not include these in
the report, I just can't help but take a
point of pride. I won't list too many
campuses. I know I did too many last
time, but I have to name these. Um Palm
Elementary is band two campus. They had
31% of their students at meets or above
in 2024 and 49% at meets or above in
2025.
Zavala Elementary, also a band two
campus, had 20% of their students at
meets or above in 2024. That increased
to 44% at meets or above in 2025. Both
campuses focused on consistent use of
the district curriculum, just increasing
observation and feedback cycles, and
improving lesson preparation and data
analysis in PLC's.
So this is the type of growth and
excellence that we want to replicate
across Austin ISD. We want to learn from
our positive outlier campuses and seek
to extend their pra practices. Uh when
we build strong instructional systems
and support our teachers and believe in
every child's potential, then outcomes
change. And just want to pause and see
if there's any additional thoughts from
my team up here before we move on to
next steps.
so proud because I know we've seen those
campuses. So to see those leaders and
the growth that they've really made at
their campus with real intentionality is
exciting. Uh, I think so. I was had an
opportunity to visit Black Share earlier
this week as well and um just the
conversations that they that they were
having after um our classroom
walkthroughs and the things that um
they're doing and the the focus on their
the prof their own level of professional
development for their teachers um that
they're providing and some systems
they're putting in place for that has
really been great. um they got a got
lots they got some some great lighthouse
stuff last year um as well and they've
they've really taken that um to heart
and had a very good understanding of
what was happening in their classrooms
and some really wonderful responses um
and I know um Campbell too it it it
really is the model for um I just
student engagement and you know a
culture walking in and um small groupoup
instruction very very intentional
small group instruction so that they
know where every student is and they
have a very intentional plan um to
support them where they need it.
>> That's great. And and I would be remiss
to not brag a little bit on a a campus
that I visited this morning. It was
Wooten Elementary. They're in a swing
space. Um so it's kind of a portable
city out there. Um but visited a fourth
grade math class. I wished you were with
us because you know an ear intervention
group was happening. Students were
working collaboratively on stem scopes
activities and games. Um there was just
a teacher was really working hard to
assess um students. When one student
would finish she's like okay start the
next. It just worked like a welloiled
machine. So it's exciting.
>> All right. um we can move on to the next
steps. What are we going to do now? Um
and really kind of revolves around five
items just clear expectations,
professional learning, investing in
campus leadership,
uh leadership coaching
and prioritizing high needs campuses. So
we must provide clear expectations for
all campuses and this includes ensuring
clarity around our instructional
components and the resources used for
each of those components and ensuring
that every classroom provides rigorous
grade level math instruction using our
district adopted materials and not just
using them haphazardly but using them as
intended and using them in rigorous
ways. And we must provide scaffolds and
supports so all students can access
grade level content which could look
like small groupoup station rotation and
access to those hands-on materials to
make some of the abstract concepts more
concrete.
Additionally, we must provide meaningful
focused professional learning for
teachers and instructional leaders. One
way we'll do this is through consistent
observation and feedback cycles for
teachers adjusting the frequency um to
support teacher need.
Teachers will also uh strengthen content
knowledge and pedigogy through planning
PLC's focused on really internalizing
the curriculum kind of moving into that
using the curriculum as intended and in
rigorous ways.
um we'll provide support for data use in
PLC's to identify needed instructional
adjustments and to support um teachers
in making intervention decisions.
We must invest in campus leadership. So,
we'll expand our lighthouse schools
model to strengthen instructional
leadership and this would include
expanding our instructional focus to
math in addition to literacy.
Um, and increasing lighthouse campuses
to have six lighthouse campuses that are
receiving intensive coaching support for
teachers as well as campus leadership.
And then each of those lighouses will
host a cohort of six to seven campuses.
ultimately supporting 37 campus
leadership teams that come together
monthly for professional learning and
hands-on application and practice.
This work is designed to build
leadership capacity in consistent
coaching, observation and feedback
cycles and observing and coaching
alongside curriculum as well as
effective PLC's and leadership team
calibration.
We also must strengthen leadership
coaching supports. We will continue our
monthly professional learning um for
campus leadership teams as well as
executive directors to strengthen
content knowledge and contentbased
coaching.
Executive directors and campus
leadership teams will then apply those
skills by conducting instructional
rounds together um to align expectations
and to improve coaching for our campus
leaders and teachers.
And finally, we must prioritize high
needs campuses.
We are continuing to target resources to
priority uh to our priority support and
resource index campuses to support
instruction intervention and coaching
such as by providing um an instructional
coach providing a a content
interventionist and maintaining smaller
class sizes.
Additionally, we'll conduct root cause
analysis for student groups in campuses
not making progress. And one way we're
doing that is through the placement of
our lighthouse schools at campuses with
larger percentages of students of with
African-American
students and historically marginalized
students. And additionally, we're
collecting observational data around
student engagement and participation and
teacher feedback and interaction.
And finally, we're differentiating the
way um professional learning is provided
at our high needs campuses. And I'll
pause here and let Dr. Maxwell talk a
little bit about some of the
differentiation of our professional
learning.
>> Right. So um the way that we uh we
provide levels of professional learning
to all the campuses, but we definitely
tar
um that professional learning and then
the frequency of it as well. Um so part
of it even just walks and coaching and
everything that that definitely is
prioritized on our school improvement
campuses and these 37 that are going
through um lighthouse and learning lab
process. Um it's definitely a part of
our um improvement plans um for all of
these campuses as well. Um additionally,
so job alike at the beginning of the
year was a good example of this um
knowing that we can't get to um 79
campuses in in one day. Um what we did
was um grouped campuses together. We
started with our school improvement
campuses on the first couple of days so
that when we grouped them, we did group
them, but they were smaller groups
rather than trying to fit huge numbers
um all together. It wasn't per campus,
but we had a few campuses together um
and we were able to deliver sort of
rolling sessions, a couple of rolling
days of in-person professional learning
um for them. Um we did provide the same
professional learning to all campuses
but um if you weren't a school
improvement campus then it happened in a
virtual session so that those were
larger sessions uh more teachers so that
more teachers could attend um but they
didn't get in person. So same
information for all campuses but uh uh
more um personalized support uh for
school improvement campuses. So that's
according to our support and resource
index of course and the the band one and
band two campuses. Um another uh thing
that we're we uh also do is um offer
more frequent coaching visits uh
frequent campus support visits to uh
band one and band two campuses. Um, and
then throughout the rest of this year,
we're designing some sessions where
again, we'll provide information and
learning for the entire district. But
personal in-person sessions that are
more targeted to the campus needs that
we've seen as we visit campuses um will
be in-person delivery or um not
necessarily just pulling everyone
together in a room, but that may happen
um at some after school sessions that
could happen in PLC's during the day. Um
we're working with campus leaders right
now to get some ideas on the best way to
implement that. Um there's never one
best way to do it. Um because you know
teachers time is precious and valuable
and um you know the best way to use that
time um across campuses always looks a
little bit different and so we're just
sort of differentiating our support with
that. Um, additionally, we we have just
recently talked about and we're starting
to plan for
we we are working with our partner right
now for lighthouse schools and learning
labs. Um, and so lighthouse schools get
an increased level of um very targeted
coaching and support with everything
that we're doing. Um, and they get it
very regularly. Learning lab campuses
visit lighthouse schools and so they do
that work regularly with them. But it's
they're visiting the other school. Why
they do it? they learn some things and
they go back to their campus. What our
um academics team or partnering with um
school leadership and what our academics
team um has talked about starting to do
so that we can um replicate that work
and sustain it within district um for
long term because that's always the
goal, right? What are we doing in
district? how can we sustain the work
long term with just us um is replicating
that coaching for our other um 31
campuses that are not lighthouse
schools. So them getting the benefit of
academics team, you know, someone like
uh Miss Jones walking through a math
class with them and saying, "What are
you seeing? What um what do we want to
see? H how can is the math aligned to um
the rigor and the instruction that we're
looking for?" Um you know, how can we
support this teacher? What are the
amazing things? We did see that we can
give glow on all of that. Um and that
really is the professional learning for
the campus leader. um teachers benefit
from that. But um the ultimate goal
there, so ultimate goal there of course
that teachers benefit and students
benefit. But that's actually through the
instructional leader so that when we're
not there and as a regular practice on
their parts, they feel more and more and
more confident every time they walk into
a classroom and they're observing math
instruction or they walk into a
classroom and they're observing any kind
of instruction really. It's a process
that we're we're replicating um that
we'll be providing to um campuses with
highest needs.
I think that wrapped up our next step.
So, I'm open to questions.
Okay. Questions?
>> My questions are in the truck uh in the
thing,
>> the attachment. Yeah.
>> Yeah, they're there. You answered them.
Thank you.
>> Do we have additional questions?
>> Trusty Coffman.
>> No, I have no further questions. very
thorough and addressed all the issues.
Um, I will note just as I walked away, I
was always listening in the other room.
So, I heard the heard the entire thing.
Thank you.
>> Thank you. It was it was a long session
before this, so everyone probably needed
a break.
>> Yeah.
>> Questions.
I I just have one kind of concept I
guess broad broadly based question but
considering the conversation that we had
earlier um you know on your next steps
you know the last few bullet points
ongoing investment in c campus leaders
and instructional leaders ongoing
investment district school leadership
instructional leaders um providing
increased support you know for all these
pieces you know considering the
conversation that we had about um
central office and the cuts that we've
had before and the increased lifts And
this is obviously one of the increased
lifts. And so I'm just wondering what
we're anticipating since those cuts,
some of them were over the summer and
we're just now getting into this piece,
how how that's changing the work that
we're doing on, you know, this one
specifically, but you know, I think this
kind of speaks to the changes across um
all the endeavors that we're
undertaking. So I don't know if you can
speak to that um you know as far as what
we can consider for the future and you
know what the trustees can be thinking
about it as we're navigating other
things that will also affect you know
these type of lifts that we're that
we're engaged in.
Um,
so I I think the investments that we've
made so far have been um really
significant um on on the district's part
and and all of our parts. And um I think
that as a district we have done a very
intentional job of protecting um
teaching and learning and um making sure
that we are still continuing to make
those investments. um that we do still
have support um and and intentional and
have intentionally built teams across
academics and school leadership that can
do this work together. Um I mean any any
reduction in any of this work I I I I
definitely would have an impact on
student outcomes. um ultimately which is
always and and I I there are are all
lots of adults adults involved with that
but ultimately student outcomes um over
over time would suffer and I think the
variability that's happened in the
system previous to the last couple of
years have um have shown that in student
outcomes. We've seen ups, we've seen
downs, we've seen hirings, we've seen
lots of firings um and kind of um uh big
reductions in in um in staff previous to
I think some more much more intentional,
thoughtful reductions. Um I any any
reduction um would definitely affect the
ability to support campuses um with
consolidations and kind of the moves we
we've been making in the background to
make sure every campus is equipped for
this work with the materials that they
have with the support that we give them
with the support that they they they are
having themselves um as they as they're
learning um to do some things
differently together. um that that's
kind of the background of the steadiness
that we've been trying to create so that
when a student moves from one campus to
another um it is not a a vastly
different experience. Um as a matter of
fact it it should be a very similar
experience and and that that that speaks
from campus to campus but it also speaks
vertically. When you leave fourth grade
and go into fifth grade you should have
a similar experience. When you leave
fifth grade and go into sixth grade you
should have a similar experience.
um because you know that that that
matters to to kids and to families and
it matters to their success. Um the some
of the work to I think the strengthen
the academic programming here yes is so
that we can continue to make those
investments. Um and we always will still
continue to look for ways where we can
get things done inhouse. Um not that we
don't benefit from great learning from
partners and from um people that we have
partnered with. Um but the ultimate
intention is to be able to do that
ourselves. Um as you're as you are
bringing campuses together, thinking
through all of the programs and um um uh
things that we've built um and and
bringing them together. I think that
consistency across the campuses makes a
big difference for that.
Well, I I was just going to say um to be
really clear like one really good
example that Dr. Maxwell um I think
maybe could offer is you know we took in
professional development uh in 2024. Uh
it was something that we used lots of
partners to do uh to execute and uh it
was costly and so under Dr. Dr.
Maxwell's leadership we've been able to
kind of restructure ourselves. you know,
it did include, you know, kind of moving
folks around, um, kind of reassigning
roles and responsibilities and in some
cases an investment in in staff, but now
we have that, um, hyper respponsiveness,
right? There was an example where a
couple weeks ago we identified a
misalignment in the system. Dr. Maxwell
and her team were very, very quickly
able to bring um, the group that needed
the support together, provide that that
support within, you know, week and a
half notice. that that type of
responsiveness did not exist. And so
that there's an expense to that, but we
have kind of transferred it from an
external expense that was higher to an
internal expense, but it's still an
expense. Uh, and if you compare that,
you know, kind of department versus
where it was four years ago, you would
see, okay, well, it increased, but
there's a reason that it did. Um, so I
just want to kind of reinforce that
these sorts of things have been very
intentional. Um and as we move forward
if we do see reductions by way of
consolidations or otherwise you know we
we have to kind of recognize that
there's going to be an impact in the
opposite direction too in some cases
like performance-wise.
So then I think my last part of that
still kind of within that same question
is that you know within the the larger
strategy that we're applying for
improving these outcomes. Um you know I
guess my understanding of like how we're
using lighthouse schools and and kind of
expanding this you know how much of this
are we expecting it that the lift trying
to think how to how to phrase this. you
know, that we're that we're pulling up
as as as opposed to pushing. Like how
much does this ability trickle down, you
know, into the campuses for those
professional learning communities? Like
I mean, I think that's my understanding
of of how this approach starts to
spread. Um, but if if we could clarify
that just a little bit, I would
appreciate that. How how
>> I think Dr. Maxwell, the way to kind of
respond to that is just the fact that
Lighthouse model um is not it's not in
perpetuity, right? It's meant to kind of
educate our system in how to serve our
students and staff. Um, and so we're
we're using it. We're building on it.
It's not every school initially. We've
we've expanded it now to be responsive
to the work that is coming, but it's
not, you know, a partner that we're
relying on. We're relying on them to
help us become better so that we can
self-perform that type of support
between our schools. Um, so that's a
great I mean maybe one example that I
would say I don't know, Dr. Maxwell, you
want to add anything to that?
>> No, that's a perfect example. That's
what um so um as we go out so we do a
lot of this work with them so that we we
are learning as well um how to become
better leaders of this work um and so as
we learn that then we the expectation on
our teams is we turn around and our
teams think okay what do we do now how
do we replicate this in our own system
so that you know ultimately it is it is
just us performing that work um I think
it's always good and healthy to you know
have some some outside opinions and
that's why we do audits and things like
that. Um so you always learn from those
things. Um like we're learning from this
partnership as well, but ultimately the
goal just like an audit is that we learn
from the things and then we inhouse um
can replicate that work um and and make
it sustainable within the district.
>> Okay. Thanks. Yeah, I appreciate it. I'm
trying to, you know, crystallize that as
as much as we're talking about all these
other pieces like how much are we
internalizing and and in integrating,
you know, as part of that path forward
because I think we've we're talking so
much about the issues that we're trying
to address. Um, and I I'm trying to
start framing things more about how that
connects to that path forward. So, I
appreciate the clarification on how
we're integrating this into where we're
headed.
>> Thank you, Trusty Kintana. anything?
>> Uh, no. My questions have been asked and
answered. Thank you.
>> Thank you. I have just a couple of
questions. Um, within the bands, there's
real variability
on the percentage of students who are
hitting this level. What do you and what
do you know about the differences within
each band and why we're seeing
um such variability?
Um yeah, I can I can start that and then
um these two uh would I'm sure happy to
to join in. I think the when you look at
the bands of schools, even though
they're all in one band together, they
all um as they should have a different
level of operations within it, right?
They have different communities. They
have different resources. Not the ones
we provide, but you know, the the ones
that they have grown inhouse and that
they um support and that their community
supports. So I think execution always
looks just a little bit different on all
of these campuses even though they're in
the same band. So it's hard to narrow
that down. Um one or two things that
would I think describe that answer. Um,
I will say in general when we're looking
at um, im improvement over time, which
is actually one of the things that we
looked at this time, um, historically
where where were the students and where
was that campus and and took some
examples of ones that aren't just, you
know, uh, scoring above the district
average now, but where were they last
year, where were they two years ago. um
the ones that we're seeing trends and
improvement even if the numbers aren't
quite where we all want them to be are
the ones that are putting these systems
into place on campuses. You mentioned
PLC's. That's how that that's where that
lives ultimately in a campus with their
own teachers and with their own leaders.
Um and and what what's happening in in
in the context of that campus. Um and so
like that's a system that um many many
times we have said and the campuses have
told us as we reach out to them and as
we see those practices in place those
systems are getting stronger and
stronger and stronger so that um
everything that they are have at their
fingertips now they're finding the
better and better ways to execute them.
Um, I mean, I ultimately I I think we
there's there's a large amount of
control that we have as a district over
student outcomes. There are some things
we don't have control over for student
outcomes. Um, and so we do, I think, the
best job we can focusing on those things
that are within our control. Um, and
making sure that they are absolutely the
highest quality that that we can get
them. Um, and I do know that there's
there will always be though some
variability with campuses and with
outcomes and student populations that
are not always within our control.
I don't know if y'all want to add
anything.
>> Yes. And I would just go back to two
there's variance var variances in size
and just I talked about Campbell for
example or black shear rather there are
two teachers on third grade team and
they're departmentalized so literally
it's one teacher having that significant
impact and then just teacher
certification and vacancies. I've been
watching and tracking and just looking
at impact and there's so many factors um
testing language if they've changed
testing language for the first time and
JJ you could probably add
>> I think even too just uh reminding
everybody that with the curriculum
itself while you know our outliers note
the use of that last year was like their
big push to really use the curriculum
and and get comfortable and start
leaning into STEM scopes, which is the
district approved. Um, and so this year,
like I mean, we probably could put like
a rough number on we how much we see it
in the classrooms that we're visiting,
and it's pretty much every classroom.
You know, there's there's a few that
aren't, but for the most part, it's, you
know, upward of over 90% of the
classrooms that we're seeing. And so
that's huge. So now that we know
campuses who did that early push into it
and used it with fidelity saw some
growth, we hope that others who this
would be kind of their big year one of
true implementation of it would maybe
see some of those same increases in
gains.
>> Thank you. And then I just have one
other um question which is can you just
share a little bit more about the
lighthouse model and how it works with
math? I've had the chance to visit one
for literacy, but I would just love for
our community to know and I would love
to know a little bit more about kind of
what it looks like to be that school and
what it looks like to be supported to
have the ch opportunity to learn from
that school.
Uh so the actual six lighthouse schools
get teacher coaching um on a two-eek
cycle. They'll come in and uh coach,
observe and provide feedback and then
they give them a week to implement. Um
and then the leadership team
additionally gets coaching and feedback.
Um, additionally, um, they are bringing
in six to seven campuses once a month to
those, uh, six lighthouse schools and
working on a variety of things
including, um, using the curriculum to
be prepared to go in and observe
instruction and calibrate on what did we
see, what is our highest leverage action
step that we could give that teacher
that that teacher could turn around and
implement. Um so learning together and
actually going and doing the walks
together and coming out and sharing
feedback. Some other things that are
happening happening in those monthly
sessions are like working on P effective
PLC's. What is a lesson internalization
protocol look like and how can you coach
a PLC through that as well as data
analysis PLC's. Um I mentioned the
highest leverage action step doing
instructional rounds as a leadership
team and then talking about what are the
trends we see not just the highest
leverage action step that we're giving a
teacher but what trends are we seeing
across the campus that can inform the
work that we're doing in PLC's um and
that can um filter into our
instructional leadership team
conversations and how we're going to
interact with our coaching case load. Um
what else am I leaving out?
>> Um I think I just uh and you know
walking through um lighthouse classrooms
also uh with you last year and some of
the things that we saw there's a real
difference um when uh teachers and and
leaders receive that personalized
coaching based on what they're doing
right there in the moment. um versus um
you know some of the more general
professional learning sessions that uh
we give that is good information for all
teachers but going back and executing
that implementing in the classroom could
be there could be disconnects in between
there. Um when that coaching happens
right there on the campus um with the
teacher with the instructional leader it
it's just very personalized feedback for
what you're doing in that moment and
then you instantly can learn and grow
from that. That's that piece that we're
replicating as an academics team on
campuses that aren't lighthouse
campuses. So that we are right there in
that moment saying, "Okay, what are you
seeing?" Um, uh, it's it's hard to
describe, I think, the load on on campus
leaders sometimes. Um, because being
able to know and be responsible for what
every classroom is doing at any given
moment in your campus is a wonderful
weight. And it is also a weight. like it
is a it's a large responsibility. And so
the amount that you have to learn and be
good at is is pretty incredible. And so
having someone with you that is a
partner that coaches you in that moment
um is incredibly helpful rather than um
trying to get all of that done on your
own. Um I think Trusty Foster mentioned
reading reports that and it laid into
the hours. Um that's what you know u
many many of our leaders are doing right
now reading into um uh standards and
documents and you know understanding
where teachers are in their teaching so
that they can give them really good
feedback which is the number one thing
um that uh you know moves that work. We
know teachers have the highest impact on
student outcomes and um principles have
the second highest impact. And so that
that that investment in them as kind of
lighthouse campuses and then sort of
proxy lighthouse campuses as we begin to
replicate that work um we think will
have a great impact.
>> Thank you. Any other questions? Trusty
Hunter. I asked all my questions, but
now I I have a curiosity and I just want
to know about HLPS. So, we talked about
centralizing curriculum and we talked
about um uh spreading those practices.
When you say you're saying high leverage
action steps are these um because you
know you got teaching works, you got to
get better faster. What is the district
because I would really love to know like
the district has said these are the
seven, eight, 12 high leverage practices
that we know will move outcomes. I I
would I think I would like to know that.
>> I love that question. Um that is
actually some of the work that we
started last year and that we're
continuing to do this year um to build
what would be part of that overall
picture of the academic framework and
instructional model. Um lots of times
and I know our uh PPFT system works this
way as well. you'll get evaluation
systems and sort of walkthrough forms
and some instructional models that are
just uh content agnostic and they'll go
um you know just be general
instructional strategies. We see that a
lot happening actually when we go
through classrooms and we're debriefing
outside. Um people are very comfortable
with um instructional strategies and not
nearly as comfortable with a very
content specific what's happening in the
classroom and how to give teachers
feedback on that. That is exactly what
we're working towards right now. Um to
so that they are content specific. Um we
we only have a few that are content
specific right now. Um we're excited
about building some more actually. Uh
science and and social studies in
particular are on our minds. Um so that
it it does increase that level of
feedback and the instructional strategy
that should be used within that content
at that time. There will always be some
content agnostic things and there should
be um so that will be part of it as well
but we're actually building that right
now.
>> Awesome. Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> Great. Any other questions?
>> All right. Um so now we must vote on
whether we will accept the monitoring
report. Uh we are voting to accept this
report as a formal acknowledgement that
we had a satisfactory conversation with
the superintendent and have a deeper
understanding about how the current
reality for students lines up with the
vision. And at this point I will
entertain a motion for the acceptance of
the monitoring report.
>> I move to accept the monitoring report.
>> Thank you. Do we have a second?
>> Second. Okay. Any discussion?
All right. Having a motion by trustee
Kintana and a second by Trustee Hunter
to approve the monitoring report. Um
please raise your hand if you vote to
approve. All in favor? Okay. And none
opposed. Motion passes by all on the
dis. And thank you all very much. Really
appreciate it.
>> Thank you.
>> And JJ, it's really fun to see how
excited you get about math teaching.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you all.
All right. So, this ends our section on
the information reports from the
administration and now we will move into
a preview of agenda items that will be
considered for a vote at the next
regular board meeting on October 30th
and staff are available to answer
questions on tonight's pre preview.
We're going to start with agenda item
number eight uh preview for upcoming
academics and curricular items. Any
questions about this?
All right.
>> Oh, yep. Okay. Trusty uh Kaufman's
getting organized. I can use this moment
to get organized. I have a lot of paper
with me tonight.
>> We're on um eight. Agenda preview number
eight.
>> Yes. Good on eight. All right. Um agenda
nine is business and finance. Anything
on this?
Um, I have one on the um the budget
amendment and thank you for the
narrative. I always appreciate that. I
see um
$250,000
for school improvement.
I see $175,000
for redistributed to correct funding for
TEA special education.
Um and then 1.5 million for the
university instructor content would just
have a quick rundown about what that is
>> and I don't mean need much just yeah
thank you
>> good evening h good evening everyone um
I'll start with the uh the 1.5 on on
university instructors. This is our
teacher pipeline.
>> So these are our teacher resident
programs. So this is wraparound supports
for them. They have built-in
instructional coaching etc. So thank
you. Yay.
>> Okay.
>> And the school improvement and tea
compliance.
It's those two that I'm curious about.
the 175 for TEA compliance for special
education and $100,000 for uh sorry and
the $250 for the school improvement
work.
>> Hello.
Sorry. Hello. Okay.
Okay. For the um 21 the 175 I do believe
that is for the monitors and what was
the other one? Um, President B,
>> the other one was the $250,000 for the
school improvement.
>> The school improvement.
>> Okay. We you can just let us know by in
writing.
>> Okay.
>> So, the $175,000 is for the ongoing cost
of the contours.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> I do have two.
>> Oh, Trusty Coffman has question.
>> Yeah. So, I just want to commend the
administration again on making sure that
the budget is real and that you make
these budget adjustments to reflect what
the real spending is. I know that's a
commitment that you made earlier. So, I
appreciate that. Um, I have a question
on 9.3
on the extension of the parent support
program. I just want to ensure that I'm
understanding correctly that this is
renewing it. It's a um
extending and renewing a commitment from
the city of Austin to provide funding
for to support our parent engagement
program. Is that correct?
>> We're accepting money through this.
>> Yes, that is correct. Um it is an
extension. So each time that we've been
granted funds from the city, they're on
I think a five-year cycle. So it's just
renewing that cycle.
>> And this is money coming from the city.
>> It's money coming from the city.
Correct.
>> Okay. So, I just want I know that's
something people bring up a lot is can
the city of Austin contribute to the
work that we're doing. Um, and this is
one, you know, million-doll plus way
that they are contributing and I
appreciate that.
>> 5.4
>> over the course of the five years.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> And and they also have a budget deficit.
>> Just
>> we very much appreciate them.
>> Thank you. Okay. Moving on to item 10,
facilities. Any questions or comments?
Okay, moving on to number 11, talent
strategy.
>> Yes,
>> Trusty Coffman
>> on 11.1 on the approval of the HP 3372
administrative personal services
contracts. When will we see those
administrator personal services
contracts? When will those be provided
to us?
Um, we will have it ready for the board
preview ahead of the voting meeting.
>> Okay. So, they'll be in the board
preview for the next vote meeting. Okay.
>> And we wanted to give folks um as much
time as possible to submit their
applications.
>> Okay. And just to be clear, the agenda
item says that the contracts were
submitted to the senior leaders and that
they have verified. Will the contracts
themselves be provided in the board?
>> It'll be the executive contract.
>> Okay, good. Thank you.
>> Thank you. All right. Um, okay. Next is
number 12, policy.
Um, any questions about this? Trusty
Kaufman
>> on 12.2, which is the determination
requiring a period of prayer and reading
of the Bible. Um there are several
whereases talking about how students and
faculty and everyone is free to there's
no restrictions on people praying in
school now. Um but there's no kind of
whereas
um stating that students
and we have no restrictions on reading
the Bible in school right now. Right.
So, this resolution covers prayer and
Bible, but all the kind of where's re
reiterate the um the right that students
already have to prayer. I'm curious
whether it would be important to include
in there clarification that students
have the right to bring a Bible and read
it during school if they want to.
>> Uh yes, thank you for the question,
Trusty Coffman, and good evening. Um, I
think what we tried to capture here is
that though the board was not electing
to create a policy to in consistent with
the recent state law is to recognize
that there still is rights for students
under Texas law and under the US
Constitution under the free exercise
clause. Um, and so I think you're
correct. We wanted to spell out prayer,
but we didn't recognize a Bible. But
under free exercise, if a student did
choose to read the Bible during their
personal time, during uninstructional
time, consistent with what they are
legally permitted to do as a right that
they have, they can certainly do that.
So though it may not be reflected here,
that right still exists.
>> Okay? And it it's not important to put
it in there.
>> I don't think it will have any bearing
on a student's right whether or not to
do it. But if I mean, we can amend the
resolution to add that language if if
that was the desire of the board. I'm
only asking because if I mean I think
that what the law requires us to do is
to either say we are or are not going to
have a policy explicitly stating that it
doesn't I don't think the policy the law
says that we have to put all these kind
of wherees explaining why. So, I feel
like the reason we're putting all these
whereases is to reassure our families
who might say this is a godless district
that won't allow us to pray or have a
Bible that no, we allow students per law
to read the Bible or to pray. So, I just
think if it's if we're trying to make it
clear to families that we're not
restricting those, it would seem that we
would want to just clarify that as well.
But
>> I'm not a lawyer.
>> Um, that's an adjustment that we can
make. We can add the language. Okay. I'm
happy to
>> I'm happy to talk offline if you want to
explain why that's not necessary, but I
just want to clarify and then I guess
more importantly just publicly make sure
people understand that um what we're
doing here.
>> Thank you.
>> All right.
>> Thank you. And I would add um Mr.
Walker, can you clarify this isn't
something we like just decided we needed
on our agenda. This is a legal
requirement. Yes, the the resolution
itself is a legal requirement, but I
think as um we've indicated here with
the with the whereas clauses, we wanted
to make it clear that's not language
that we had to to incorporate, but with
the goal was to make it clear that there
still is a right under the free exercise
clause exists. Again, that's a right
under the first amendment of the
constitution. So, we tried to indicate
language there to indicate what the
right is despite what we've indicated at
the upper portion of this resolution
regarding the legal requirement on
whether the board was going to adopt a
policy.
>> Thank you. I really appreciate the
clarity and in making the law clear to
our families too and and that right
clear. I appreciate that and I also just
want to thank everyone involved in
gathering the new district innovation
committee and doing that work. Thank
you. Um, next up is agenda preview
other. That would be our lone store
governance uh quarterly and yearly
evaluation.
Any comments? All right. Next up is um
number 14, Travis Central Appraisal
District Board of Directors Nominations.
We good on that one? All right. Um and
then we will have a transfer appeal um
at the end. All right.
Oh, no. We need to vote. I'm sorry. The
item for action is the TCAT nominees.
Nominations.
>> Yes. Um, so we will be voting on a
resolution now to nominate two
candidates to serve in the Travis
Central Appraisal District Board of
Directors for four-year terms starting
on January 1st, 2026. The nomination by
resolution is due to TCAD by October
14th, 2025 and TCAD will provide a list
of all nominees before November and the
board will consider action on allocating
votes for nominees at the November 20th
regular voting meeting. Uh, do I have a
motion to approve item 14.1?
>> So moved.
>> Thank you, Trusty Hunter. Is there a
second?
>> Second.
>> Okay. Um,
having a motion by Trusty Hunter to
approve agenda item 14.1, Travis Central
Appraisal District Board of Directors
Nominations, and a second from Trustee
Kintana. Is there any discussion on this
item?
>> I have a question.
>> Yes.
So, um, for some reason I thought we I'd
already seen the little applications,
but that was for something else that we
were going through. Just I've seen so
many recently. Um, where have we posted
for this to go up?
>> We posted we got Yeah. Um, Josh handled
it for us and we got 30 something
applications. So, doubt out there.
>> We sent an email to the entire
community.
>> Okay. Excellent. Thank you.
>> And really want to share our
appreciation with everyone who applied.
We got a lot of applications and really
appreciate that people were interested
in doing that.
Uh any more discussion?
All right. Having a motion by trustee
Hunter and a second by Trustee Kintana
to approve item 14.1. All in favor,
please raise your right hand.
And the motion passes by all in the dis.
Thank you. And we will now recess the
open meeting at 11:34 p.m. and move to
executive session pursuant to Texas
Government Code sections 551.074,
551.072,
551.073, 073, 551.087,
5551.076,
551.0821,
and 551.071.
When we finish with the executive
session, we will return briefly to open
session to take action on the transfer
appeal and to formally adjourn the
meeting. The vote and adjournment will
be recorded and included in all replays
of tonight's meeting. Thank you so much
for joining us and have a good evening.
Um, all right. We will now reconvene the
open meeting at 12:47
a.m.
And I have a Here we go. U, the board
will now at this time consider
um,
hold on, pardon me. Finding that this
isn't my script. Here we go. Um, all
right. We are here to consider a
transfer appeal. That would be um the
transfer on appeal item 16.1, the
transfer appeal on behalf of VM. Do I
have a motion to consider that transfer
appeal?
>> I move to deny the requested relief.
>> And
>> and uphold the administration's
decision.
>> Uh do we have a second?
>> Second.
>> Okay. Is there any discussion?
All right. Having a motion by Secretary
Gonzalez.
uh second by trustee de urost to affirm
the decision of the superintendent and
deny the relief requested. All in favor,
please raise your right hand. And the
motion carries by all those on the dis.
Do I have a motion to adjourn the
meeting?
>> So moved.
>> The meeting is adjourned at 12:49 a.m.
Thank you.